[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody it is beautiful madrid
that is hosting the long awaited
candidates tournament it is finally time
to determine who is going to be the
challenger to the reigning world
champion magnus carlson we have eight of
the best chess players in the world
trying to fight for that coveted spot to
bring you all of the action from our
studio in st louis i am grand master
alejandro ramirez with my good friend
grand master yes sir sarah juan
alejandro as always a great pleasure to
be with you and christian to call all
the action it's going to be great oh
absolutely we've been waiting for this
tournament for what feels a very very
long time as soon as of course the world
championship ended we already started to
think who is going to be challenging
magnus next well after this tournament
we're going to have our answer hello
everyone and welcome to the today in
chess show and let's take a look at the
roster of these eight candidates
and what a great field we have for you
it's incredibly strong this is one of
the strongest candidates that i can
remember no outliers that i can think of
when you have a minimum rating of
27.50 in a tournament
that is just absolutely outstanding any
of these players can realistically take
home that coveted first place spot to
challenge mangus carlson this is going
to be absolutely fantastic agreed
wholeheartedly and our format alejandro
it's a long tournament we're going back
to classical chess old-school chess an
eight-player double round robin that
means 14 rounds of chess one of the
longest tournaments still around in the
circuit marathon a marathon absolutely
and a marathon time control as well 120
minutes for the first 40 moves
60 minutes for the next 20 and once you
reach move 60 you get an additional 15
minutes plus your 30 second increment
start
allowed before black's 40th movie
and we are playing for an amazing 500
000 euro prize pool not to mention
the first place price which is what
everybody really cares about to become
challenger and our schedule alejandro
it's a very long event not just in the
rounds and not just because it's 14 of
them but also because there's a lot of
rest days we have friday june 17th as
the first round second round tomorrow
third round uh finishing the weekend on
sunday and immediately our first rest
day and it's gonna be our pace for the
tournament three rounds and the rest day
three rounds and a rest day all the way
to rounds 13 and 14 to finish off the
tournament marvelous and we are of
course joined by christian shirella
christian good to see you my friend
drill down on our players
good morning yasser good morning
alejandro and good morning or good
evening depending or where you are in
the world to every chess fan around the
world because if you are not watching
the candidates right now you cannot call
yourself a chess fan but first let's see
who these players are and how did they
get to the candidates well we're going
to start with a young polish superstar
jan shishtav duda he's aged 24 he is the
best chess player in poland his feeder
rating stands at a whopping 27.50 his
world ranking he's 16. he also was fifth
in the world at one point right now he
qualified through the world cup he is
the world cup winner and actually he
managed to beat magnus carlsen in a
match in that particular world cup we're
going to continue with timur rajabov
he's the oldest player in this event
he's definitely going to be bringing the
experience he's aged 35 coming from
azerbaijan his feeder rating stands at a
27-53
right now 13th in the world he got to
the candidates by being nominated by
fide we're going to continue with one
hikaru nakamura the american superstar
who has millions of fans around the
world his age 34 feeder rating
27.60 he's definitely surging right now
through the rant rankings earlier uh
this year he was actually 27 30 but he
had an amazing performance at the
grand prix he won that event and
qualified to the candidates richie
rapport well the young superstar from
hungary
64. he is currently sixth player in the
world and he qualified as the runner-up
in that 2022 fide grand prix and of
course representing fide right now h31
we have jan nepomnyashi the previous
challenger to the world cup
unfortunately for him lost against
magnus carlsen in november he's sitting
at seventh in the world but of course we
have one fabiano caruana the number one
player in the united states 29 years of
age feeder rating 2783 he is currently
coming into this event as the fourth
ranked player in the world and he got
here by uh through the 2022 feed a grand
swiss he actually came in second in that
event the player that actually won that
event is ali reza fierrozza the young
superstar from france aged only 18 years
old feeder ranking 27-93 he was actually
above 2 800 just a month ago his world
ranking his third in the
twist the 2021 grand swiss and the
rating favorite going into this event is
the chinese ding liran 29 years of age
his feeder rating stands at an
astronomical
2806 second place best player in the
world after magnus carson and he
qualified as the highest rated player in
the event guys we're going to have a
fantastic event on our hands thank you
christian and indeed uh alejandro do the
honors lay the table what do you got for
us for round one round one let's see
what we have in store for the pairings
yashish of duda will be playing with
white against rickard rapport dingli ren
the highest rated player in the um
meanwhile in the all-american matchup
fabiano karana will be playing against
hikaru nakamura that's going to be one
of the crucial games for me of this
round and table rajab white pieces will
be playing against ali reza farouja no
weak games in this tournament
whatsoever not at all and we know what
the uh prize is all about becoming the
challenger but there is plenty of money
at stake alejandro yeah not so bad first
place is 48 000 euros second place is 36
000 all the way down to last and you get
7 000
euros per point that you score that is
for every single player so certainly an
incentive to score as many points as you
can run away with the tournament bad
question about it what are they playing
for
the grand prize to become challenger
absolutely the winner of the 2022
candidates tournament will play magnus
carlsen in the 2023 world chess
championship that's going to be a huge
one location to be determined and of
course still with rumors that magnus
might not play depending on who
qualifies but as we saw in the press
conference in spain yes a lot of these
players don't believe in what magnus
says
well
but magnus did say i'm looking forward
to playing against alireza for rougia we
are going to determine ourselves uh our
picks
uh but an article i read but just by the
numbers the top three players by rating
have a 66 chance of becoming the
challenger yeah
interesting not just a mathematical
model so i also see it reflected in
what's the betting lines and what people
are speaking about but gary kasparov
said it very clearly that he thought one
of the three
possibilities of winning this tournament
would be the three highest rated players
dingleran ali reza ferruga and fabiano
caruana much higher in statistical
chances than the others but
do you agree does christian agree let's
ask him let's start with chris i don't
agree i i to be honest uh i i want a
darts uh table and i just want to throw
a dart at it because i have no idea
who's going to win this event fabiano
caruana was touted as the 2020 favorite
going into that candidates and
unfortunately it wasn't his tournament
especially in the first phase and this
is ex
very very important how are these
players going to start this event after
the first couple of rounds we're going
to have much more information as to who
is in shape going into this event we
have one hikaru nakamura who is just
surging for example through the ranking
he's been playing spectacular chess and
actually i was seeing these statistics
going into this event
for the period 2020 to 2022 from the
games that he has played and all the
other candidates has played he has the
highest elo performance 28 30 something
from the games that he has played so far
in this two years so he's definitely
surging through the rankings i know he
had a difficult period he went all the
way down to like 27 30 but right now
he's back and he's showing it with every
single performance and everybody else is
just a superstar going into this event
it's going to be very very difficult to
determine without any information about
who's in shape who's going to win this
event well thank you for that christian
and i
agree that this is a wide open field
having said that i'm going to go on the
record here it comes
i'm going to go with hikaru he's a
slight underdog uh coming into the event
but in my view he's surging
he's looking at his age he's looking at
the youth and he says if not now
when it's not gonna happen for me if i
don't put it all together of course we
know he's streaming but guess what when
you're streaming you're playing chess
and at 2760
he's looking at this field and he says
you know
i can do this who do you like
i feel that
daily run is currently in the best shape
out of everybody okay i think there were
there was a lot of talk about his
tournaments in china yep but i think it
prepared him well and i think that he's
put in the training the training uh he's
actually had a lot of time off compared
to a lot of these players he's not been
as busy as these players he did take a
lot of time i don't know if he was
necessarily because of his decision
partially of course because of the
pandemic a lot of travel restrictions
going back exactly to his home country
he did not play a lot of chess he
actually had to marathon he actually had
to marathon a bunch of games to meet
make himself active exactly uh to
qualify to this tournament but i still
feel he's in great shape i think dingle
ran is the front runner in this
tournament i like your pick of hikaru
nakamura to me he's more of a wild card
exactly just never know with cairo he
could be completely in shape and he
could be completely off shape and
everything will be determined in the
first few rounds for him no question and
christian jump right in if you don't
mind uh
who do you like out of these top eight
yasser i definitely like your pick
hikaru but
i don't like alejandro speak dingley
wren hasn't played a 27 plus rated
player in classical chess since the last
candidates he's been surging through the
rankings he has 27 2806 but he only beat
26 50 players going into this event i
don't know if that goes to show how well
he's going to perform in this one and
how much of a shape he's in definitely
i'm going to go with fabiano caruana i'm
generally not picking fabiano to win
this type of events but this year i feel
like he feels also it might be one of
his last chances he's already 29 years
of age he has a lot of experience but at
some point if you play too many of these
candidates i feel you lose some
motivation right now he's on his third
one i think he needs to win this one and
he knows that so i'm going to go with
fabiano carlos just to correct
yeah yeah this is fourth so definitely
the most experienced we have three
newcomers alejandro including the teen
sensation ferugia how come you didn't
pick peru we have to talk about it the
thing is that candidate is a different
breed of tournament the candidates is
something that you prepare for months
the candidates it's not your usual
tournament you show up you have all
these ideas you can be creative we're
talking about months and months of
preparation fabiano carrana and alireza
have known that this tournament was
coming up for so many months yep but
fabiano knows how to prepare for it this
is laressa's first rodeo on something so
strong yeah and we have verusion varujin
ocobian big one fabi as well and the
games are now underway
and i gotta tell you that donnie brook
between uh
fabi and hikaru
is going to be my marquee match up it's
not just because it's the american
player but i think it really will set
the tone yes both of these players very
much so very much so fabiano knowing
that hikara was going to be in the
tournament yeah for so long it's been
already a few months you're white yeah
you know that you have to prepare
against hikaru this is a this is a
chance and this is important for hikaru
as well get into the tournament not lose
against fabiano not get an uncomfortable
as black not get an uncomfortable
position with the black pieces show that
your preparation is up to par to
somebody whose reputation has been
opening his openings openings for so
long right a little undeserved actually
very underserved in my opinion but that
has been fabi's reputation for a very
long time agreed
and for hikaru nakamura again starting
out with black against his countrymen
knowing that pappy is probably a
pre-tournament favorite as we've been
discussing
getting off with a nice easy draw
without too much pressure would be an
ideal way of opening up the vent
we don't have a counter yet
one e2 e4 but e7 e5 ah this could also
be the ceremonial first move yeah we'll
be taking a little bit of a look out
some what about opening predictions for
today yasser i expect fabi to open e4
it's it's been his bread and butter
forever yeah but
he didn't d4 against wesley so in the
candidates that he won in 2018 so he's
been adding
so he started with a victory over wesley
the one that he won in 2018 yeah he
started with a victory against wesley in
this catalanish
position with uh slav catalanish
position with queen b3 that was a
crucial one because i felt that wesley
fell apart
after his two consecutive losses to
start that tournament right so important
for hikaru to start well no surprise
here in my opinion the berlin defense
this was the first thing i wanted to say
when we got word of the uh ceremonial
first move uh knight f6 has actually
been hikaru's go-to
number one
uh defense against one e4 he can play
just about anything he's a virtuosa but
uh definitely the berlin has been his
go-to in the last few years maybe even
longer
yeah absolutely he is one of those
players that really transformed himself
from being an incredibly aggressive
incredibly dynamic player
that could play gambits against
everybody again to a player that's
actually very very solid especially with
the black pieces he has a repertoire
that's very difficult to beat he doesn't
he's not ambitious at all with the black
pieces in classical games but
so difficult to get an advantage against
and he's very well versed in all of
these berlins he's
versed in the queen's gambit declined
yes against d4 and it's been really
difficult for people to find holes
against it exactly and in this
particular line of the berlin an early
capture bishop takes c6
by uh fabi and fabi is
following the dictates of uh the main
line
and again as you said it's very very
hard uh these days to get any kind of
advantage against the berlin even just a
smidge again we're going to keep this
game on a back boiler for a moment and
just going to turn it over to
christian to ask him if he's been
keeping his eye on
any of the other three games christian
absolutely guys and i think this one is
going to turn into a barn burner the one
between dingley wren and jan nepomnyashi
we know dingley wren has had a lot of
time to prepare for uh this a tournament
he hasn't played a major event in one
and a half years so he definitely had a
lot of time to improve his openings he's
already brilliant openings and right now
he's facing probably one of the best
prepared chess players on the planet
that is yani pognashi because he has a
lot of residual preparation from his
match in november and let's see where
these players are taking us c4 e5 g3
c6 knight to f3 e4 knight to d4 and this
is already a very sharp line after this
black has a lot of options knight to f6
in general you won't keep the knight on
g8 just to give yourself the option of
potentially playing f5 without the
knight on f6 you can do that
unfortunately if you do start with
knight to f6 you will not be able to
play that move f5 and continue the
expansion on the king side another
principal move in this position is queen
to b6 asking the knight where are you
going to go are you going to try to stay
in the center with the move e3 but you
know that's going to weaken some light
squares around your king or are you
going to go knight to b3 knight to c2
and this leads to some wild variations
instead of that it was yannick who
started off with d5 now this is a much
more of a principled approach you are
taking the center you are forcing
white's hand because
at this point you can play the move d3
but that just simply doesn't look right
c takes d5 seems to be one of the main
options and now we have queen takes d5
if not knight not the c takes d5 because
if you do take with the c pawn then
unfortunately this knight is going to
stay there on d4 i'm going to go knight
to c3 this queen is going to be tied to
the defense of the pawn on d5 so queen
b6 is not going to come as easily you're
not going to be able to kick my knight
away from the center and after that i
will hook this pawn on e4 it this over
extended pawn on e4 with the move d3
after you take on d3 i'm going to take
and then i'm going to have a target i'm
going to play against your isolated
queen spawn on d5 so taking with the
pawn is not a good idea he instead took
with the queen and this is uh theory as
we know it now you do have the option of
playing e3 but unfortunately if you do
uh overextend with the movie three of
course i'm not going to take on e3 my
rook on h1 is hanging be careful but i
will just simply go f3 we're going to
exchange and i just have a lot of pieces
already developed i do have a lot of uh
interesting presents in the center later
on after we exchange either with the
queen either with the bishop i'm going
to go e4 and you're going to be in a
deep danger this one is going to be a
very interesting one guys back to you
thank you very much for that indeed
christian keep your careful eye on that
by the way uh we're going to be here a
long time we hope you stay with us for
as long as you can and to make our lives
much more interesting you can join the
conversation we are ready to host your
questions you can
do it through tweet or a chat absolutely
you can tweet at us at
st louis chess club or you can ask the
questions on the live chat we actually
have people monitoring uh twitch we are
monitoring youtube and we're monitoring
facebook as well so put your questions
on the chat the best questions they will
be sending it over to us so we can have
a conversation directly with you guys so
we can see exactly what you want to see
in these games absolutely
um i'm looking at the game of fabi fabi
played the move knight b3 which i think
is just still where in the standard
dictates of theory if you will or is
this a little bit off the beaten path
it's just a little bit off the beaten
path the knight normally doesn't go to
b3 in this position i'm more familiar in
this position with both the moves b3 and
d4 because d4 ed is not really a move
right
because you just lose to e5 so but but i
know this position very well knight d7
has been played tons of times exactly
very common and i think that linear
dominguez a specialist of this variation
proved that this is equal beyond doubt
uh and knight b3 i am not as familiar
with and it seems to me that he carries
it as well because he hasn't replied
that was my question yeah definitely
knight b3 seems to have
caught yes
car a little bit yeah the first little
opening battle it's not a huge deal but
it is nice to get that first surprise in
okay so with the move knight b3 you were
mentioning that the d3 d4 expansion is
on white's agenda possibilities of
knight g5 f4 also to be considered or is
that something you you tend to shy away
from not necessarily shy away from it's
a it's a fascinating position because
based on the structure you would think
that white is the one looking for a
break either d4 or f4 the difficulty
strategically of this position is that
the more you open the position the more
the pair of bishops gains strength right
so it's a bit of a paradoxical position
in which white both wants to open and
doesn't want to open the position and i
feel that move knight b3 is a little bit
more of the kg type of of ideas instead
of trying to immediately blow up the
position with d4 or knight g5 f4 i think
white is going to maneuver around first
this knight on b3 probably headed to the
a5 square just to put pressure on the
queen side maybe also just to prevent
black from expanding himself a lot of
the times black uh his idea is to play
a5 and a4 in this position grab that
space in the queen side so i like the
move knight b3 in the sense that it's
not as committal and it still keeps a
lot of options open for both sides okay
interesting
but uh these two players certainly no
strangers to one another having played
in
many u.s championships seven wins yeah
four fabby six losses but look at that
33 draws i
these guys have played each other so so
many times clearly very strong rivals i
mean they're both from the same country
they've been playing u.s championships
for many years now and they've produced
some fascinating fascinating struggles i
think nicaragua had the upper hand for
many years and fabiano came back and won
a few games in a row uh before hikaru
caught up and currently even though
fabiano's up one game i think it's it's
a toss-up absolute toss-up between these
players let me throw it out there
i see the move knight b3 and i think to
myself you know what structure i don't
mind having i'm i don't mind having a
structure where it looks like i'm
imprisoning entombing my own bishop but
if i can take away the d3 d4 break by
playing a move like c5 and maybe just on
a very very good day threatening to
undouble my pawns with the move c4
how could white possibly take advantage
of this challenge well it's a very
sensible move and i think that it really
comes down to uh whether i can do
something with my knight on b3 kind of
quickly i mean you can play knight a5
take advantage of the fact that b6 is
not playable
because i think you're just dropping the
e5 pawn yeah that seems that's a seems
like a pawn
pretty nice fork there of the queen in
the pawn and as you say it's a very nice
bond so it forces me to take a move
along i don't i just put something on
these lines right yeah i'm just going to
defend the pawn on b uh b7 for a moment
anticipating that down the road i'm
going to play b6
i don't think i don't have anything
against this structure i think that this
is one of the positions where black can
play anything and be okay right the
thing is you do have to find a plan and
you do have to find a continuation right
and this is why i like the move knight
b3 because if we go back to knight b3
uh which is the current position on the
board i agree with you that c5 is a
logical move right but so is knight d7
a5 castles b6 right right so
the the difficulty is not finding
something that is okay yep i think a lot
of moves are okay in this position
it's finding a plan moving forward
and what are you going to do what are
you going to do in the long run
because you know that fabiano has looked
at this position he must have seen
four or five maybe even 10 moves from
here that black can play and has a reply
against most of them right so you really
want to equalize as comfortably as
possible from these structures not let
fabiano get anything from the opening
because you are playing the berlin for a
solid position you don't want to be
suffering we talk about flexibility and
the flexibility inherent in this
position from black's point of view like
you say castles knight d7 a7 a5 even
something as ridiculous as h7 h6 is just
all very very good this flexibility how
deep
you're having worked with bobby in the
past how deep therefore
can fabi possibly prepare knowing that
he's got four or five
reasonable plans that uh kara might
go for
uh yeah for the preparation for the
candidates and for the world
championship match that both christian
and i did uh for fabi
it was a very wide and very long net
everywhere everywhere everywhere so it
wouldn't be it would have shock me that
this spiral is
pages and pages long right uh he is a
very diligent preparer
he is a very diligent player when it
comes to checking moves
he is very diligent about looking at all
the possibilities all of the variations
wow he doesn't like leaving things to be
desired he doesn't really like leaving
files where he says well there's five
possibilities here i'll figure it out
right i'll get to the board i'll figure
it out it doesn't work like no neither
did gary kasparov by the way gary is
like you say very diligent very thorough
thorough and i just wonder
how you can retain all that knowledge
and then produce it when it absolutely
needs to be spot on and i think this is
part of fabi's preparation i don't think
he can recall all of the preparation for
example that we did for the 2018 match
but he still has most of it in his head
and when something's fresh he has an
incredible memory wow
let's jump over to
christian and
ask him what he's been looking at
christian
i i do have to say uh regarding
fabiano's prep i do think that for the
candidates in general is a bit more
shallow his preparation for a world
championship match we have like three
four training camps of two weeks three
weeks each we have almost a full year
going into the world championship match
so we have a lot more time to cover all
of this for the candidates in general uh
you will get one maybe two max
camps in preparation for this one
nevertheless going against hikaru
nakamura we know that hikar will
probably try to stay tight in this event
he will not engage into his usual kings
indian defense maybe some sicilians some
crazy stuff no he's going to
play more compact chess and i assume
fabiano expected the berlin and prepared
diligently against the berlin also the
berlin is probably an opening that most
of the other players
will play if not fabiano himself as well
but i was taking a look at this game
between yan shishtav duda and richie
rapport and this one is developing quite
intriguing uh e4 c5 knight to f3 e6 d4
see take d4 knight xd4 knight to c6 at
the time of sicilian we've seen richie
rapport essay uh this opening quite a
lot in recent times and at this point of
course knight to c3 is probably the main
move bishop to e3 you can start with
that as well knight acc is knight to b5
you can do a lot of things
one move that we generally don't see and
i uh after looking at it bishop to f4 is
the move that came on the board and i
was looking through the games that were
played in this variation by the way only
16 games in existence and the highest
rated player that actually played this
move only a year ago is richie rapport
with the white pieces right now he has
to face his own weapons he played
against fabiano caruana bishop to f4 d6
knight takes c6 b takes c6 and c4 and
actually he got quite a pleasant
advantage but let's see what happened in
the game bishop to f4 it definitely came
as a surprise you're going to use my
weapons against me well let's see what's
going to happen after this d6 knight
takes e6 b takes c6 and seven games were
played in this position all of them with
the move c4 trying to take advantage
that the knight is not on c3 yet i can
expand like this try to put some
pressure uh in terms of space advantage
in the center instead of that
yar shishtav duda prepared this move
bishop to d3 at home taking much more of
a tame approach inviting black to
potentially play a d5
this is a novelty this has not been
played is uh an early surprise for rishi
rapport and after a think of almost i
believe eight minutes he played this
move a knight to e7 now where is this
knight headed probably to g6 to target
the bishop on f4 i mean look your bishop
on f4 doesn't have a natural spot it's
not generally in this position
especially right now with the pawn on d6
potentially the other pawn coming to e5
and starting to target uh that bishop on
f4 and potentially i can bring my knight
as well try to hover around the king
side now after bishop to d3 i would
expect white is going to tame uh take
much more of a team approach either with
short castle or perhaps even long castle
who knows let's wait and see i'm sure
knight to e7 was seen in yanshi of
duda's preparation let's see how he
responds this one is going to be a very
intriguing game thank you christian and
uh prior to our broadcast uh i had
emailed the exchanges with christian and
he told me are you ready for this that
uh grand master lubermeer loboyevic
uh really a great name a blast from the
past somewhat i have a great deal of
respect for i stayed with uh lubo in his
apartment in belgrade for uh
when i was just
in yugoslavia so i have a good
experiences with lubremir and lubimir a
very very creative player it will be
very interesting to see their work
relationship really produces something
special so
well welcome back luvo right he's uh
working well allegedly working with
richard rafford over there in madrid he
was spotted with richard in the same
flight so ah
something to this happened something to
be said but certainly an intriguing
player right a legend of the chess world
definitely a lot of the young generation
might not be as familiar right with all
of his accolades but what what an
impressive career lulu had and now
perhaps even adding to it not as a
player but as a coach interesting just
wanted to draw your attention to the
game of ding lorraine against netball
for just a moment
uh i'm an english player i played this
position i
didn't actually play a2 a3 uh my ideas
had actually all all been
revolving around moves like queen c2 and
or the very early b3 and bishop b2 i i
didn't really you know play for a3 and
b4 i kind of felt it was too slow and i
wanted to get into
d3
i'm looking at this position and could i
just ask you a question what would you
have done against quincy too
just didn't have the answer come to me
in the jiffy i assumed it was going to
start night before
you would tickle my queen i would drop
back and i'm just gonna ask
you who defends that one who defends
this guy
maybe i actually have to play the move
knight c5 instead knight to c5
right back here
and if you were going to go a3 b4
now's the time right so b4
then i assume 96. it's the only idea i
can find right
if i take a pawn well your rook is
hanging exactly
i don't get to trap the queen in this
case which is usually why i wanted the
pawn on b on uh b3 this isn't you you're
not forced to take my rook in fact
if the pawn was on d3 i'd be able to
trap the queen so i can't do the
immediate grub
but okay
now it must be 94 right 94 i mean
because this is the big threat i don't
think knight g5 works yeah 94 has to be
the move right
right and uh well this doesn't look bad
for black the knight does look pretty
comfortable on d4 i'll uh i'll just uh
i'll just ask the the key question i my
dream
clearly i want to play rookie one and
knight takes e4 i still haven't lost my
ambition a3 i'm being told by the way uh
the move 11 a3 is actually novel
approach uh
why are you getting the earphone
am i blundering
i'm blundering the point
bishop takes b4
let me check could do we'll just take a
look quickly right
two
this is the reason
yeah you were warming up to that maybe
you actually take one e4 first
right let's take on you for first
and that would force bishop takes but i
have the feeling that black must have
more than one move after that knight
takes e2 queen h5 looks right yeah so
queen c2 was like kind of the first move
the other move i played b3 i've also
played d3 a2 a3 wow that's uh it's slow
right
slow but
in a way ambitious because if you do get
the move b4 and with the knight on a6
that night will take a little bit of
time to return to the game i will get my
bishop to b2 one day um right and if
anything it's taking nep a little bit
out of his prep he's finally played them
with rook e8 after uh quite a thing
and let's take a look at how these two
match up uh alejandro i actually don't
know uh two wins and two losses so it's
about even between them uh of course the
last game that they played i believe
that ding loren actually beat nepomiaki
in the final round of the candidates
even though that was irrelevant by that
point yes exactly that nepo had clinched
with one round to spare
celebrated a little too early here
well there was one one going
took the very nicely appreciated elo
rating points and wished him well yeah
if i remember correctly i think jillian
iran won the second half of the
candidates and keeping in mind this was
the pandemic uh
candidates where literally the first
half was played the tournament was
aborted and an entire year passed
mvl had been in the lead oh that was
this was like the stories of legends
this is what makes the candidate so
great
an entire year had passed mvl was in the
league they re returned to the
candidates round eight the first game of
the second half
fabi
produces some unbelievable opening magic
sacrifices of peace
mvl defends brilliantly like
came that close to making a draw fabby
wins the game
throws the the tournament wide open
nepal says if you don't mind me fellas
i'd like to take first place and become
challenger which is exactly what he did
he kind of ran away with it a full a
full round to spare for his victory the
results that he needed kind of fell in
his lap at the end yeah at the end and
he did have a great performance in that
tournament very cleanly winning against
some of his main rivals very cleanly
winning against alexenko which i think
was a very big difference yes between
the previous candidate and this
candidate and even though alexenko is a
great player a 2700 player it's hard to
say that he was really in ever in
contention to match against magnus
carlsen no and everybody kind of looked
at him like okay this is the
mark this is the mark yeah that's
unfortunately no such thing in this
tournament exactly in
if anything you could say well like
t-more is coming in as the lowest rate
of player but we know d more actually
duda is lower rated than t yeah okay i
didn't realize that but the difference
is so negligible right you're looking
more at current shape and current form
than rating at this point for example uh
2760 for hikaru but nobody's really
thinking well yeah that means he's three
points lower than somebody else no no no
that has nothing to do it doesn't matter
once you pass 27.50 which everybody in
this tournament has right they're all
the same yeah 27.50 is just an
incredible
high watermark for these players and
like you said timor edgevaux
three points high rated is not the
lowest radio player in the field i think
that timor people are saying like if
anybody is the mark it's teamwork but
don't take that the you know like wait a
minute this guy is really really
dangerous by the way we do have to move
after rookie 8. b2b4 came very quickly
if you say hey
right right bishop b2
and queen c2 now the move rookie 8
obviously is designed that you know one
day you can move the bishop maybe move
the queen and play bishop h3 i think
that's almost like the dream come true
from black's point of view is that if he
can maintain the pawn on e4 without
necessarily
uh messing up his natural flow of
development and get in the move bh
bishop h3 black will have done well
equalized or
yeah you start thinking about
being better you'd be h3 or d8
black is not only solid and well placed
but also it's able to target a lot of
white's position d2 is going to be a
little bit loose if you move the knight
on e3 knight g4 becomes a little bit of
an issue so
black with a lot of space and very
active rook starts to get the upper hand
so yeah i agree with everything that
you've said before and i think the move
bishop f8 is so natural because you just
played the mover k8
uh i'm actually curious about this
particular position because bishop f8
fish b2 looks so normal
queen h5 and i already like black well
it again uh
the prep how deep is it
yeah okay i mean the first moves you
like to look at are moves like queen c2
like a dream for me would be to
sacrifice an exchange where i keep
my e2 pawn like if i had some position
like this where i'm not
hanging my e2 pawn here i think my
bishops are working i've got a nice
center but queen takes e2 really uh ends
my joy
um
something we'll keep an eye on and let's
jump uh to christian and christian uh
tell us what what's on your plate
well uh actually fellas i was looking at
this game in particular and let's take a
look at how we got there because i think
it is quite interesting and i have to
say i'm mightily impressed by the
preparation of a dingley wren because he
hasn't been spending a lot of time and
it is actually jan nepomneyashi who is
spanning and burning through his clock
now let's see at this point after bishop
to e7 generally we see the move d4 or d3
trying to simplify uh the situation in
the center
especially regarding the spawn on e4
instead of that
white played the move knight to e3 much
more of a patient move i'm going to uh
wait for you to show your cards are
going are you going to go castle or are
you going to try to launch an attack
with the move h5 at this point only four
games have been played after knight to
e3 and all of them were with the move h5
nevertheless i have to say this move h5
doesn't impress me after going through
the variations for example and i think
this was definitely within dingley ren's
preparation d4 now is asking a very
pertinent question what are you going to
do are you going to abandon your attack
on the king side with the move queen to
c7 or queen to d6 we know that you want
to play h4 followed by queen to h5 and
check mate me on the king
after the move d4 if you play the move
queen to d6 or queen to c7 that queen is
going too far away from the uh battle on
the king side now you can take on d3 but
this allows me to open up the avenue for
another one of my defenders one of the
most powerful defenders the queen on d1
now queen to h5 unfortunately is not
going to come as easily also after this
exchange and the opening of the light
square bishop on the long diagonal i
have this extra option of continuing the
attack in the center you're attacking me
on a flank on the king side i'm going to
counter you in the center and for
example after the move h4 d4 this is
already the way uh i see it problematic
for black you can go queen to h5 but
this end game is just going to be a pain
to defend your attack is not going
anywhere you simply don't have enough
pieces who knows who's going to be
favored by the opening of the h5
probably is going to be actually white
but also what i can do open up this
monster with the move d5 the monster on
a g2 and after that all your pieces are
discombobulated all over the place this
position is just not easy to play for
black a very very difficult end game of
course this is not something that young
pony actually is looking for if you go
backwards to c7 once again queen to h5
is not coming queen anywhere around my
king is not coming and you're not going
to be able to continue your attack i do
have an attack in the center with the
move d5 once again if you open up allow
the king the knight to go to d5
centralize the knight followed by rook
to e1 putting a lot of pressure on the
open central fires this would spell doom
for a black so unfortunately after h5 d4
you have to know this move he takes d3 c
uh he takes d3 and queen to d4 actually
what you're trying to do is stop me from
playing the move d4 but also trying to
redirect your queen to a much better
square that is actually d8 not c7 that
is the place for the knight you want to
drop back with the knight to c7 and
block my d-pawn on d5 so that's why you
start with the move queen to d4 knight
to e2 i'm trying to kick away your queen
queen to d8 followed by knight to c7
whenever you play the move uh e4 and we
have a very very tense uh strategical
battle in this one white has these
trumps black as well has its trumps and
this would be a very intriguing uh game
to follow nevertheless i have a feeling
dingley wren knows this position and
knows it extensively and much uh longer
now he did not play the move h5
yanapomnyashi that was he played the
move
castle he showed his cards i'm not going
to attack you on the king side i'm not
going to go h5 um anytime in the future
so we're going to be discussing in the
center as well as on the queen side
definitely not on the king side
a3
starting with a move a3 followed by b4
opening up the avenue for the bishop and
leaving the pawn on e4 as it is is this
a strength or a liability for black well
who knows the answer i think is dingley
wren who knows the answer and i think
he's betting that the pawn on e4 is a
liability that's going to be attacked by
my pieces rook to e8 b4 bishop to f8
bishop to b2 and right now actually
after b4 never uh never mind
no moves have been played and i will let
you guys take it over and tell me what
your impression of uh this position is
and before we go there uh yasser you
mentioned uh richie raport and lubo
check this out
there it is this is the picture that you
were discussing off to madrid rich
reports says we see libermy lubovic uh
quite a legend yes sir tell us a bit
about that what is his experience in
world championship cycles the strangest
thing about lubo is he was a top five
player at his heyday
incredibly creative tactician
he was really noted for his sharp style
and his tournament victories but he
didn't do very well against the world
champions and in particular there was
this one guy
anatoly karpov
who didn't only block lubo's career from
advancing anatoly carp blocked a lot of
players lubo being one of them but luba
was e4 let's win let's win later in his
life he became more quiet positional
approach and
so forth and so on but uh
really a great tournament player not a
big match player
yeah i think that he really ran into a
lot of problems stylistically especially
against karpov yeah car path was
terrible yeah karpov has had a huge
score against him that's right it really
does come down to the fact that he was
such a creative player and karpov just
loved playing against his creative
players he just loved being positionally
better or taking the material defending
squeezing you exactly and luma was not
about defense no no i wanted to turn our
attention to timor versus
ali erisa
and
but but before i do that let's turn back
to uh christian christian
not yet guys because a move was just
played in that game between dingley iran
and janet it was knight bishop to uh f8
queen to h5 just a game play uh like
such it was actually knight to g4
immediately sacrificing a pawn is uh
this sacrifice valid knight takes g4
bishop takes g4 what if i just simply
pick up
the pawn on e4 i'm going to let you guys
take a look at this game because this
one is heating up and right now after
the move knight to g4 and by the way he
spent quite a lot of time on this
decision well who knows maybe he's just
a pawn down after uh white just picking
up the pawn on e4 let's see how damn
iren is going to respond to this one
well you've got a stumped christian
there's no question about it knight g4
offering the pawn in two ways we can
take immediately
e3 and invite you to open up the f-file
or as you said play knight takes g4
followed by bishop takes e4 so two
choices for white in this case i can
imagine i've doubled my pawn but yeah
but wait a minute this rook
uh is going to be nicely placed on the
half open file uh at the moment sorry
i'm a pawn grubber you know that but uh
my knee jerk is like what
do you see it i because i don't bishop
takes e4 for the moment
um
queen h5 right what i don't get it uh
good morning saint louis
keep in mind we are here in saint louis
and we're waking up to a pawn sacrifice
by knight
g4 bishop takes e4 worse
nothing like this this doesn't
impress this is an appeal right and not
at all whatever you want even f3
honestly right yeah uh
it's a little clumsy but upon us a pawn
and not only a pawn but a great
that's a beautiful uh phalanx of pawns
there from white's perspective
and yeah i can understand that you might
want to play knight takes e3 f takes e3
and
just get on with business but again
we're looking at a pawn and then finally
a move that i hadn't looked at uh which
was
what the first thing that
christian said like okay i understand
i'm helping you develop
but
at the end of the day
where's your compensation
man oh man um
christian if you could help us i mean
we're we're stumbling in the dark over
here i i think i know what he's looking
for
a little bit i don't know i cannot read
his mind obviously but i do see what the
preferences of the engine uh are and
after knight to g4 i was really looking
at this move a bishop to e4 and after
the move queen to h5 obviously you have
to defend against checkmate you can take
on g4 but that's going to allow bishop
takes g4 and that's going to probably
force you to go f3 leave this bishop on
e4 you guys were saying that you're
quite comfortable with the absence of
the bishop on a g2 the fianchetto bishop
nevertheless maybe from a practical
perspective dingley ran is not going to
be comfortable with that his other
option is to just simply play the move
h4 and this is what i think
janna pognashi has been calculating and
the first thing that i'm looking at the
position when i see the move h4 is
bishop takes h4 what's going to happen
after this how is
this sacrifice uh going to materialize
gtx h4 queen takes h4 knight takes g4
you have to once again defend against
the checkmate if you take with the queen
and unfortunately bishop to g2 does seem
to cover absolutely everything in
white's position so bishop to g4
rook to e6 rook h6 is coming and it's
coming fast f5 followed by rook to a e6
rook to g6 is also coming fast so you
have to do something to involve more
defenders around your king and the way
to do that in fact the only way to do
that not to be worse with the white
pieces right now is to play the move f4
now this is a normal move right you play
the move f4 you're going to go into e1
next you do allow this check on g3 but
always after this check on g3 i'm going
to defend with bishop to g2 you can
continue trying to check me but rook to
f3 is going to come and uh save my
position after that queen to f1 is
coming also king to f1
get out from uh this pin i'm going to be
a piece up and probably going to take
this
game home and the full point now of
course queen to g2 is not the only move
you can also play this
next sacrifice rook takes e4 sure knight
takes c4 rook to e8 now if i eliminate
the knight from e4 queen to g3 is going
to come with a check and at least i'm
going to have a perpetual right so for
example if you go
d3 rook take c4 take on e4 queen to g3
at least a perpetual after king to h1
maybe you can start thinking about
bishop to h3 not really because of queen
to d8 that's a checkmate but queen to h3
and that's going to uh finalize the game
we're going to split the point i'm going
to be happy as yana pomnyashi with the
black piece is surprised from the
opening by dingley wren so i understand
what he uh saw in this variation
nevertheless d3 is not a forced move i
don't have to defend this knight on e4
what i can do
is play the move queen to e1 and this
might have been the move from afar that
yon a missed queen to e1 and after queen
takes c1 rook takes one i do understand
you take on e4 but unfortunately i am on
exchange up your pieces are all over the
place and i don't see the compensation
i'm going to go d3 e4 there's absolutely
no compensation white is just simply
going to be better so
what is he thinking after knight to g4
knight xg4 uh bishop takes g4 is also an
option
after this move queen to h5 is not the
only alternative now queen to h5 you
guys were mentioning uh f3 what i'm
seeing is with the pressure on the e
file this bishop already on g4 is going
to be a bit difficult uh to potentially
play bishop to g2 and f3 you need a
couple of moves so i'm going to try to
take advantage of that as soon as
possible with this move knight to c7 i
know on a6 is not doing anything right i
have to involve this final piece into
the game and the way to do that is to
try to target the knight on c3 the
knight on c3 right now first of all is
pin you cannot move it because you're
going to lose the rook on a1 but also
it's the defender of the beautiful
bishop on e4 centralized bishop very
nicely placed knight to b5 is a big
threat nevertheless so for example if
you play something like bishop to g2 a
very natural move i'm going to go knight
to b5 and is it is actually black who
has the dynamic in the position and the
initiative and full compensation for the
pawn so perhaps this is what he's
looking at these type of ideas i'm going
to give you a pawn but i'm going to be
able to find dynamic play for all of my
pieces let's see how the game is going
to develop well thank you christian for
that because i needed that i i just
didn't feel i saw the compensation at
all on leandro
i didn't see anything yeah
i mean he was showing some lines where
black is uh at least uh causing
uh some discomfort there's something i
didn't understand about all of these
lines yes why couldn't i do the same
thing without giving up a pawn breeze
bingo
right you don't need to play g4 you
don't need to play knight g4 to play
knight c7 or to develop your bishop go
knight c7 go knight c7 right right it
wasn't 97 a legal move very legal very
legal uh i we haven't uh mentioned it
yet uh timor uh ratchet offers
this
unbelievable talent from iran now based
in france
zoomed out of nowhere
to number two in the world fell off
fell off the pace just a little bit but
nonetheless
uh his play was so inspired that magnus
carlsen said i want this guy yeah and i
think a lot of people do perhaps not
this cycle but definitely for the next
one when he's a little bit more of a
mature player but everybody's looking at
ali wrestle as a as a challenger at some
point he's so talented he's so
resourceful he's so hard working he's
really shined uh with this title of
chess that is uncompromising right you
just place every every variation in
every opening whether it's king's india
it doesn't matter it just does not
matter he's provocative he's very
provocative and you can see in today's
game where he is playing a variation
which i actually know quite a bit about
uh i actually did a video series on this
uh very recently yes a
little plug please please uh everybody
run out to the shop right now today and
get
well the course is called well this is
just published on limitlesschess.com
right it's a venture by chicago-based
grand master mezcan amano and it's
basically netflix for chess you pay a
subscription you get a bunch of videos
brilliant and it's a really nice way of
studying chess um
eric rosen varujan kobe and joshua many
authors in the website and i actually
published a repertoire against d4 which
was based around this neo vienna i
doubted the new vienna i didn't really
have a name before it i thought neo
vienna was very appropriate it is a
vienna but it is without the move bishop
before and it's very uh new yeah
it's a modern uh neo vienna yeah i'll
get behind that yeah
thank you i mean i'm taking full credit
right right right your marketing
department gets two stars there you go
thank you
thanks d4 and we're going through
something that's become popular
recently especially because of online
chess in which you want to get chances
on both sides right uh the first time i
ever saw that was thanks to fabiano
caruana uh the very first uh camp that
we did for the world championship he
just sat me down in front of her
computer and was like take a look at
this position
right the engine immediately gives plus
one back in 2018 right and as engines
develop better and better and better
they understood that move b5 is actually
quite good
white only really has one way of trying
to exploit the move b5 and it's a move
e5 if you don't play e5 here you're
basically transposing into all of these
botvinic type of variations right where
black didn't play c6
exactly
which is a
very compromising tempo right you can
keep this diagonal open
that's a totally different ballgame you
know it's strange i played my whole
career queen's gambit accepted yes and
ag
and if my opponent somehow tricked me
into this position bishop b4 was an
automatic automatically because nobody
would have ever without the help of
chess on it you go beef i oh that just
totally ruins your pawn structure yes
and i remember
actually i think it was shaq who is who
had played a game
and i went wow
the dynamic possibilities
for black even though it's kind of is
pawn structure uh has been compromised
uh it's actually really decent i was
it's really i find it shocking
and it's it's become as i said quite
popular i think everybody's given it a
whirl uh karana mamedyarov uh wesley has
played this nepo has played this magnus
has actually faced this with the white
pieces with actually a very bad score
yeah he's lost a couple of important
games against nepo in this champions
tour online okay uh which i based a lot
of games around in the video series and
this particular variation with the move
83 there's a lot of possibilities here
queen c1 is very uh good i think b3 is
actually a very dangerous move as well
uh i've seen both yes yes rooksy want us
to move as well a3 is possible uh a3 was
played i believe my drf against caruana
of 2018 it was one of the stemming games
of this variation in which favi actually
got a great position was on the verge of
winning i wasn't able to convert but it
was a fascinating game and after uh but
i think that game actually won bishop b7
instead of knight a5 if i remember
correctly in this position after the
move a2 a3 bishop b7 yes but i mean the
whole point of a3 is to give your queen
this c to square square without being uh
pestered by a knight
and then you know on in an ideal world i
get to develop my rooks and actually
that's that's the interesting thing what
is your ideal world here i i actually
had the pleasure of practicing this with
some of my students i have very strong
students at saint louis university and i
was playing a blitz game against a
benjamin bach you know grandmaster from
the netherlands a famous streamer well
over 2600 right and he got this position
i played a couple more moves for black
and it was a blitz game of three minutes
he spent two minutes in the movie and
said what am i supposed to do here
what's my plan what's my plan
it's not so clear actually what white's
plan is after the move a3 because you
don't have the b3 brake anymore
uh your rooks could go to the center but
then what
exactly i think it's for me whenever i
see the pawn on e5 is maybe an
indication of my being a french defense
player yeah but i see upon on e5 i think
that's the leverage i need to advance a
king side attack so i'm assuming
the moves queen c2 to e4 to g4
which is funny because one of the
variations that became very popular if
we can go back
uh a few moves instead of playing the
move bishop e3 and all the way back
yeah in this position uh actually the
move bishop e2 is the most popular
instead of bishop e3 yep uh if you're
gonna play bishop b2 and bishop e3
doesn't really matter which order you
play them right but if you're going to
play something different and you play
bishop e2 first and it doesn't matter if
black plays knight c6 or bishop e7 in
this position they're both fine okay uh
white at some point before castling
actually goes to move queen d2 or after
castling
you're right directly and goes for queen
f4 g4 and the thing is make a pathway to
the king's side the thing is if you put
the queen on g4 very early a lot of
black players just castle long they
leave the bishop on f8 and ignore you
they even put the bishop 27 and they
give you the g7 pawn but they say wait a
second i have a bishop on b c7 there's a
rook on g8 we we mentioned that a moment
ago you leave that diagonal open when
the pawn is not forced to go to c6 and
since we have a ton of time i'll show
you a very funny game between jeffrey
chung you can
bishop e2 okay
it'll transpose there at some point
bishop b7 bishop castle bishop b7
okay let me see if i get this one right
excuse me foreign d2
knight c6 queen f4 okay and this is a
very funny position because queen d7 is
played in this position okay and i
believe the move uh
rook d1 has been played okay and black
has this really cool move i saw the
first time played by jeffrey chung here
at the st louis chess club uh i forgot
against who
i think it was victor erdosh from
hungary and he played the move g5
absolutely shocking right damn but it
has a very cool tactical what
yeah if you take on g5 which is actually
not a bad move okay uh bishop takes g5
queen takes g5 there's the move knight
e7
what yeah it it's almost like magic but
rook g8 is coming and your knight on b5
is hanging
oh it's one of those
beautiful tactics it's one of the
coolest double attacks you can possibly
see in chess right that is so hidden you
didn't see that coming you really didn't
see that coming the coolest part yeah
the game just starts because white plays
d5 and everything explodes
d5 take my knight
let's have
let's have a ball you actually cannot
take that you cannot take the knight
because they're taking e6 and then you
get mated yourself right so fascinating
positions i think uh technically black
is doing just fine in this position okay
i analyzed this very deeply for the
video series and i think this is cool
this is a very cool line full of hidden
resources very stuff that you just don't
see very often
that is amazing uh christian i mean jump
right in uh we're having too much fun
you gotta you gotta give us a break and
this is such an intriguing game right
because we know that ali reza almost
2800 he's uh definitely the player that
is surging in the world of chess only 18
years of age we know that he is the
future and he has been uh playing uh in
this game against rajabov and we've been
talking about raj above we're not giving
him a lot of chances to potentially win
the candidates and a challenge magnus
and if you don't know who rajabov is you
might be asking hey why are you not
giving him many chances he's 27 53 he's
not even the lowest rate player uh in
this event he's very close to that top
well the problem with rajabov is that
he's not very active he hasn't been
playing a lot even before the pandemic
in a 2020 which kind of stopped the
world of a chess but let's take a look
at one thing and i was quite curious to
see how alireza is going to approach
this game with the black pieces is he
going to try to go for a victory and i
think this is exactly what he's doing
with his opening choice now you might be
wondering why are we not giving rajabov
a lot of chances well this is exactly
why we're not giving rajab of a lot of
chances let's look at this graph you see
this red line this flat red line this is
rajaba you see this surging blue line
this is firuja right now
it goes all the way to 2003 right let's
take a look at what happened after 2018
to get a better look
you see this flat line this is rajabov
he hasn't been playing any single games
you see all the way from here he hasn't
played a single game until here and then
he lost rated ferruja is going all the
way up he and he just surpassed him he's
playing a lot he's definitely gaining a
lot of experience i have to say
raj above this is particularly why we're
not giving him a lot of chances and i
think why he will be the player targeted
by the sharks in this event guys what do
you think
2850 performance
and maybe even a greater performance
than that so you need so
you need to put together the event of
your lifetime now for timor he doesn't
have many of those huge spikes just as
as
christians were saying you see a lot of
very very good performances at and
around his rating he doesn't really do a
2 900 he doesn't do it 3 000 that kind
of thing he's earned a reputation i mean
there's no other real way to put it it's
a solid player we're commentators and we
have to be harsh to the players but but
teamwork is one of those talents that
he's just so
so good at chess right he was almost
2800 like 10 years ago yep he was
actually 27.99 right he beat kasparov
when he was 15. exactly i mean he was
playing leonardo's tournaments when he
was a teenager he was such a huge
promise right and then
along came 2013 the candidates the
the magnus carlson wins on a tie break
by the way but magnus carlsen wins and
timor
disappeared yeah he kind of disappears
from the from the top i mean i don't
know if he had some personal
frustrations he also has a lot of other
ventures he is he's a player that is
interested in so many other things uh
he's a very smart individual uh he's
open businesses he was big into
cryptocurrency back in like 2013-14 so
he really like saw a lot of things
coming his way but specifically for
chess it seemed that he lost his edge he
was on he was unwilling to lose too many
games mm-hmm and his reputation he
didn't take risks it just felt like he
stagnated uh he didn't
really evolve as a chess player the way
that you need to
to become a candidate well of course
he's still a great player of course he's
an elite player he's made it here yeah i
mean i mean the candidate several times
yeah i mean he's a deserving player uh
of course he's made the candidates
before he's made the candidates again
but
is he the type of player that you're
gonna say is he winning this event
he really would need to reform himself
as a player coming to this event for me
to consider him a challenger to magnus
calls and let's understand exactly how
he qualified he didn't qualify in this
cycle he qualified in the previous cycle
by winning the world cup this is the 128
player knockout so he
proved himself in these individual
matchups and then because of the
pandemic he didn't want to he didn't
want to risk
uh the pandemic and and so essentially
you skip the cycle uh christian back to
you and uh jump in with your thoughts
well uh guys let's see what's happening
in uh this game between the ashish
and richie report because we haven't
looked at this one in quite a while we
left it off after the move a knight to
e7 and i was mentioning that probably
what richie is trying to do is take
advantage of this bishop on f4 target it
with the move knight to g6 and then try
to build some momentum on the king side
around the dark squares bishop to uh e7
potentially bishop to g5 depending where
you're going to place at the bishop from
f4 are you going to go to g3 try to keep
some tension on this diagonal that's
probably going to be attacked with h5 h4
i have a lot of ideas to target the
bishop depending on where you're going
to place it knight to g6 was the natural
option after c4 which uh came from yan
shishnov duda it was richie rapport who
decided otherwise he said no knight to
e7 is not going to g6 actually there's a
different piece that is going to go to
g6 and that is the pawn i have to say
this is quite a questionable
decision by black by ritchie rapport
because
right now you're giving me a lot of
dynamic play and this is exactly what
happened you committed your bishop to go
to g7 that's going to leave a lot of
squares unattended on the queen side as
well as this very important square uh
the square d6 where the pawn is placed
right now so after g6 yan shishtov duda
understood that and immediately
sacrificed a pawn with the move c5 and i
really love this decision because right
now
is putting the onus on black what are
you going to do are you going to go a d5
well sure if you go d5 and later on put
the b spawn a d7 who's going to guard
this square d6 i'm telling you who this
pawn on c5 and the bishop on uh d6
that's coming for white it is white is
going to have a dominant edge around
this critical square d6 are you going to
accept the pawn sacrifice probably you
you don't want to do that because bishop
to e5 is one of the options probably the
simple uh one in the book but also i can
just simply target the pawn on c5 with
the move queen to c2 queen to c2 i'm not
even in a hurry to pick up that pawn on
c5 i'm probably going to go castle the
knight to d2 knight to b3 maybe take the
pawn on c5 wait a night i'm just going
to have a dominant position and a much
better and healthier structure
after taking the pawn on c5 so you
cannot accept that after the move c5 the
only other move that i'm seeing is the
move e5 but unfortunately right now the
consequence of you playing the move g6
you made a huge uh hole on f6 so i'm
going to try to take advantage of that
with the move bishop to g5 now you have
to defend against that you can once
again take on c5 after bishop to f6 rook
to g8 yeah good luck developing your
pieces on the king side good luck
finding uh a safe spot for the king on
e8 uh the king stuck in the center right
now you're not going to castle long
obviously the b file is open the file is
open everything is open your king is
going to get checkmated and you just
lost the right castle on the king side
so unfortunately you cannot allow that
now what are you going to do and right
now it is richie report who is uh taking
a long thing and potentially finding out
that he is in fact in deep trouble
wow thank you for that and you didn't
answer the obvious question though
christian what about queen a5 check
and sure
no
a5 a check definitely makes a lot of
sense but what about knight to d2 once
again this knight is headed to c4
b3 to target the queen if you play queen
to a5 you have to follow it up with
taking the pawn yeah exactly but right
now i can just simply go castle yeah
roxy one is coming nice roxy one is
coming exactly i don't say you don't
have compensation you've got i i don't
too much compensation this is too much
compensation you're busted it's just
bust this is completely busted
you still have a lot of moves to make
until you finish your development all of
my pieces are out and playing my king is
safe and i have a clear target and once
you lose this pawn on d6 well it's all
she wrote your structure is completely
in shambles and your king will be unsafe
for the remainder of the game this is
not looking good no no no question
christian if you win the pawn on d6 yeah
i toss in the towel yeah but just go
ahead and kill me please bishop to d7
bishop to g7 no david seven i'm sorry to
d7 okay sure bishop to d7 what if i
continue targeting this
no no i don't want to play b4 and show
you that uh i can sacrifice even more
pawns and open up everything and you're
never going to cast along right you know
you're not going to cast along after
before right no
let's assume that b4 is too difficult to
find but what if i just play the natural
knight to c4 i was i was planning knight
c8 i didn't want to lose the dc this is
so ugly and once again b4 is one of the
moves i can prepare that with the move
a3 and it's just bad this is the style
of
i'm sure he's rubbing his hands in his
hotel room right now
oh my goodness he's not rubbing any
heads right now oh he's ashamed of what
his pupil is doing at this point after
queen to a5 he didn't play queen to a5
but just simply allowing this move c5
it's not a great look for richie because
i think at this point g6 was just a
tremendous uh blunder you have to go c5
stop me from playing the move c5 which
by the way is quite a typical sacrifice
exactly whenever we see the bishop on f4
at this pawn coming to c4 we know that
potentially c5 is going to come on the
board and try to weaken it's a very easy
way to weaken dark squares and uh if you
don't stop me from doing that with c5
yourselves then you're probably going to
have to contend with that and this is
exactly what happened i'm
i don't like it i don't like it or
richie rapport uh i'm definitely seeing
duda taking the full point in this one i
think g7 g6 is really an overreach it
really is we're looking to move c5 c5 is
really coming with with great force
strength right we're going to get ready
to take our first break of the day
before we do that we just want to inform
you that if you like our broadcast you
like to support all the great activities
that are taking place here in saint
louis go to q boutique and we do have
one of our beautiful vinyl chess boards
featuring
the saint louis chess club and the chess
capital chess capital cubitique stl.com
will have some promotions throughout uh
the event and of course today we have
the vinyl board it's very useful you can
always support us here cubatecastl.com
all of your chess needs you can find
them there absolutely we'll see on the
other side of our break
[Music]
we all know st louis is a championship
sports town from the 11 time world
champion cardinals to the stanley cup
champion blues
but i bet you didn't know about all the
championship places there are to get out
and play here like the world chess hall
of fame westport social and topgolf and
now even our own mls team so whatever
sports your team is into you can always
bring out your a game in st louis
oops sorry st lou is always exploring
[Music]
st louis university celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st louis slu
attracts students and professors from
around the globe
in 2015 slu partnered with the saint
louis chess club to start a top-tier
collegiate chess team on the very first
year of the teen's inception slu
obtained second best university at the
pan-american intercollegiate chess
championships
higher purpose
greater good
st louis university
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
ascension
welcome to our show
you guys gonna see this
[Music]
that's our show now go start yours at
this is
by now you guys probably know there's a
lot to see and do in st louis but when
it comes to the art scene
there's more here than meets the eye
from lau meyer sculpture park and the
city garden to the stunning cathedral
basilica one of the largest mosaic
collections in the entire world
so if art is your thing
st louis is on display all year long
now that's an exhibit st lou is always
exploring
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody we are here in
the 2022 candidates tournament and it is
round one and the players are definitely
not pulling their punches we have some
exciting games already every single
board with something to talk about and
these are of course our universe's
rockport dingleran against nepal yakshi
karwan against nakamura and timur rajabu
against alireza perugia
sometime but somehow uh the gods have
conspired against us and and his fate
would have it exactly when we are going
to turn to the game of timor things have
really really heated up check this out
um
you had given a very nice explanation
about this uh the pedigree of this
variation after the in the game a2 a3
knight a5 queen c2 all of these moves
were played rather quickly and after
bishop a6 fortifying the spawn on a c4 i
was really surprised by this move knight
a5 to b3 i thought that
timor's entire
setup was designed to try to take
advantage of this weak pawn on c4 and
after the move knight b3 knight e4 it
looked to my eyes
like uh ali reza was in trouble the game
quickly continued knight d2 rook d2
knight f4
encouraging bishop takes c4 what is his
plan after bishop takes c4
um
is he planning rook takes b2
uh what could what's going on here
for this pawn sacrifice
good morning good morning uh wait what
what what what is the compensation here
because rook takes v2 seems insufficient
let's take a look at that okay vertex b2
queen takes b2 bishop takes c4 i assume
is the idea
i don't know
d1 let's just pick a square yeah you
can't go to c1 which is the most natural
one the the desired desirable right rook
c1 actually does uh
well just a second the knight on c1
might be trapped there is queen a
bishop a3
uh
as well as queen d5 okay so that was why
we chose rook d1 just to keep d3 under
control and now you have another pawn
sorry it's not even a pocket it's a
change it's a bishop for the rook
but i'm looking for a pawn or something
else
that doesn't seem to be the case now
but excuse me
bishop b7
i don't believe this is anywhere near
compensation this just looks like a
flat out han sacrifice for
some hope attack i don't know i don't
quite see it either uh i do think it has
to be the sacrifice but it does
speculative to me
looks very speculative rook b2 queen b
we're missing something here
because uh
i don't know what to say i i really
don't i mean maybe you can
the thing is can i play like queen d5
and pretend that i have comp here
you definitely have a lot of control
over the light squares but
boy the material it just feels like it
is a lot of material right
and
if you had some way with h5h4h3 on the
board some immediate immediate follow-up
well maybe maybe it's not so bad maybe
you do just go h5 here and just play on
the position play the position like this
is what we wanted all along
wow that would be
stuck though right it would be a
remarkable concept uh just a a pure
positional exchange sacrifice
let's jump to uh christian and maybe he
can fill in some gaps christian
guys it's just an exchange
okay
uh modern chess looks like nowadays why
i'm saying that and why i don't think
alireza is surprised and he actually
wants to force uh this sacrifice is um
the last couple of moves
i
one hour and 47 minutes and let's not
forget they're not getting any increment
one hour in 47 minutes rook takes d2
knight to f4 one hour 46 minutes and 18
seconds he played this move knight to f4
basically forcing
this uh exchange sacrifice in only 40
seconds so he definitely knows something
about this position now if you don't
take on c4 you're going to allow me to
take on e2 and actually you're just
going to have a worse version of the
exchange sacrifice because what i'm
looking at right now as black is to gain
control of the light squares to
eliminate the bishop on e2 and the way
to do that is of course after bishop
takes c4 and i do think yes it was
played it was just played because it's
forced you have to take on c4 you have
to buy the bullet and accept that after
rook takes b2 queen takes b2 bishop
takes c4 for the remainder of the game
most likely black is going to have an
incredible setup around the light
squares i have the queen coming to d5
very nice centralized position the
bishop on c4 is going to be nicely
placed and i do have the bishop era
that's going to allow me to target your
pawns and the structural weaknesses on
both colors of the board the light color
and the dark color as well the pawn on
a3 is going to be a target this bishop
coming to d5
coupled with the action of uh the nice
dynamic knight on f4 i definitely think
that black has some compensation now i'm
looking at the engine it does say like
why it has a tremendous advantage but
let's not forget this is stockfish i
have a feeling that if we're going to
look at
leela some artificial intelligence uh
network we're going to see a much
different response and a much different
assessment of this position and i do
believe that ali reza going into this
event is one of the best prepared
players on the planet right now because
his second is ivan chaparino from
bulgaria and i know ivan i know he's
been working on in the world of chess
seconding the bachelors players on the
planet topolov he was the second of
topalov for quite a long time he has
great experience at the highest levels
and he knows how to prepare this type of
competitions i have a feeling that this
position
is in alireza's notes he knows what he's
doing he's analyzed not only that he's
analyzed he actually played a lot of
training games and this is uh just his
position but i do believe that he played
a lot of training games with this type
of sacrifice i don't feel the danger for
black i do feel the danger for teemu
rajabov because from a practical
perspective right now he only has
56 minutes and let's not forget no
increment when you get close uh to those
last couple of
any additional time if you're not close
to move 40 then you're in big trouble
and this is exactly what i think we're
going to see in this one and we're
heading straight into this one actually
this is the position that we have on the
board rook takes b2 came immediately on
the board queen takes b2 bishop takes c4
one hour 45 minutes for ali reza 55
minutes for timur rajabov and i really
like ali reza's chances now another game
that i was having my eyes on of course
uh because this is a barn burner once
again is the game between dingley ren
and yanni pomnyashi and we were
wondering we had so many ways as white
to gain that pawn on e4 well he decided
not to take it he decided to leave it
there and after this move uh b4 a knight
to g4 which surprised us and everybody
else bishop to b2 including dingley ran
he uh took a long thing and he decided
against taking the pawn on e4 queen to h
game
and now once again the second uh
alternative after the move h4 which was
played in the game was to take on g4 and
grab the pawn on e4 why not take the
pawn on e4 the same problem it allows
black to build dynamic play due to the
fact that you have to lose some time to
get your pieces back there's a
tremendous pressure on this pawn on e2
and i'm going to try to take advantage
of that with the maneuver knight to c7
knight to b5 target the defender of the
pawn on e2 in the meantime you're going
to have to drop back with the bishop
also play the move f3
and i do have a lot of time to get my
rook on the central d file as well as
the knight potentially to b5 giving
black tremendous practical pressure in
the position so dingley ran
decided to play the move h4 keep this
pawn on e4 also keep the alternative for
white to take on e4 with the knight not
with the bishop
and after bishop to f6 queen to c2
knight takes e3 d takes c3 bishop to f5
this is the current position we have on
the board we haven't seen any sacrifices
on h4 the ones that i was touting uh
earlier on in the broadcast right now
we're seeing black taking a slow
approach nevertheless after rook to d1
i like the way this game is
strategically developing in white's
favor i i do like this compact block of
pawns solidifying the control in the
center on the e-file and forcing a lot
of resources for a black to defend upon
on e4 i also see this queen kind of uh
out of play on h5 because without the
knight on the board there's no more
sacrifices you're not going to take on
h4 you don't have a tremendous attack
anymore you can try to go with g5 but
there's nothing on the h file even if
you somehow miraculously get the queen
to h2 i'm just simply going to go king
to f1 and escape
it doesn't look like your attack is
going anywhere we're going to have to
play a strategical game and i feel like
the trumps are in white's hands i'm
going to uh have tremendous pressure on
the structure on the queen side at some
point i'm going to go b5 i'm going to go
uh for this minority attack this version
of a minority attack on the queen side
and it just feels like my pieces are
better placed i like daingli ranch
chances in this one guys how about
yourself thank you christian you know
this is commercial
where guys going throughout his day and
everybody's speeding past him like
really really really quickly and he's
like what happened
did i drop off the world i mean i didn't
understand the exchange sacrifice i
didn't understand why dingler and didn't
take the pawn but there's christian
making a strong case that with the pawns
on e2 and e3 lots of squares are covered
and he's doing really really well
a little history about the candidates
first of all 60 years ago bobby fisher
complained the soviets are cheating the
soviets are cheating and then they
changed the candidate
matches so that the soviet players could
not collude even though bobby was only
19 years old at the time and certainly
not the world's best player
he changed the system or rather fide
changed the system
but
2013 is when they reintroduced the
candidates and it was the year of magnus
the first time he was in the event
that's alejandro that's right well
actually the second time that he was in
the event because he we've kind of
eliminated the candidates match by
lavone rooney in the previous cycle
that's correct and he was the winner of
the 2013 a very tumultuous and famous
wow canada's tournament it was of course
his first appearance but the way that he
got to the finish line it's like he
stumbled there his
rival stumbled there as well
he actually lost his last round against
peters midler in a very very famous game
and
kramnik who had the exact same amount of
points as carlson but was worse on
tiebreak went all out against ivan troop
with the black pieces lost that game as
well and magnus just edged him out on
the tie bricks that was a great one uh
he defeated vichyanan and of course but
then she came back and i think that was
one of the greatest returns of all time
of all time absolutely this is amazing
destroyed the 2014 candidates tournament
it wasn't even a close affair right he
really was head and shoulders above
everybody else in that event he
eventually made it to the rematch
against magnus cross and managed to win
one game in that match but wasn't able
to really come close uh to really
fighting for uh the title uh meanwhile
in the
in the next candidates
i mean i'm sorry i just have to mention
it but we're missing the 2016. yeah we
jumped we jumped i don't know why sergey
karjakin did win the 2016 they played
the match in new york and they played a
match in new york magnus carlsen won
that one the next one was fabiano
carrana winning in berlin in 2018 that
was also a very
nail but he was a nail fighter but he
really clenched under the end
he won against gristrop with black in a
game that he just had to draw exactly
and he just kept
saying no to the draw no to the draw won
that game very impressive very
impressive one a full point ahead of the
field and of course the story 2022 2021
candidates tournament between some of
the best players in the world but jane
pomnyacci really
a lot of people think was favored by the
fact that this tournament was split into
right he lost a crucial game in round
seven
and didn't spiral the way that he
spiraled in the world championship match
against magnus carlson he recovered he's
got a year to recover got a year to
recover finish strong definitely a
serving challenger
but wasn't able to show his best chess
in the match itself which brings us all
up to today and let's jump quickly to
our marquee game before we don't get a
chance we left fabi and nakamura in the
dust this was the position we got to
when uh the other games decided to
explode and got all of our attention uh
you were mentioning exactly here
alejandro that black has an enormous
flexible uh
move c5 a5
knight d7 castle short and a move we
didn't really even look at queen e7 the
game continued quickly knight a5 again a
question do you want to castle long or
not
icaru answered with the move rook b8
bishop g5 and this is where
the fun started can i put it like that
or the troubles what are we going to
call it because uh hikaru expanded on
the king side leaving us with a very
difficult question what is black gonna
do with his own king he played knight d7
and after d4 f6
queen d3 h5
we have reached the current position
and
uh icaru to play but
what is hikaru going to do with this
king let's let's assume he starts with
takes
i guess the idea is e4
h4 pardon me h4 to give me to give
myself
in case of g5 uh the square g4 it does
look a little dubious for black i don't
like
having to meet h4 with either gh or g4
but i have no option i have to choose
one of the two and both of them kind of
look a bit ugly for black in my opinion
the absolutely look very ugly i mean if
the kingdom was on a8 i could consider
ga h rook g8 something attacking on the
on the g file the fact that black's king
is still in the center however lisa's
mystified again
um
if you had time to play after f6 takes
e5 moves like g5 g4 h5 h4 if it wasn't
for the h4
and now i'm looking more seriously at gh
bishop takes queen g7
[Music]
it feels wrong i want to start out with
for black but how
wrong is it
i feel it's very dangerous i i started
looking at moves like knight c4 i
understand you have some threats on the
kings exactly but i don't see why i have
to respond to them just yet right you're
not really threatening anything uh
bishop h3 is not a threat i don't have
moves like knight g5 just shoes out all
of your attack on the king's side and i
have a very
very straight up way point i'm attacking
your bishop on d6 your bishop 1d6 is
holding that pawn on e5 it truly is and
i'm not really sure how you respond to
that and i think that's why hikaru has
actually taken with the knight
on e5 instead of taking with a pawn
yeah having to uh again h4
loses the g5 square
so he's taking away one of these uh king
side pieces so for example if you take
take
h4
i do have g5 takes h4 and you don't
thanks to the fact that your bishop is
missing you don't win the g5 square so i
i can support luke knight it takes e5 i
feel like i've got a position i
understand finally after after that last
uh 30 minutes or so of like what's going
on bishop takes if
knight takes e5 as the current position
i don't think i want to give up the dark
squared bishop that easily
um
do i have a choice
yeah i mean you could take with a knight
i don't think there's anything wrong
with that okay let's try that let's
let's see what we could get if we do it
this way bishop
no bishop before i have queen takes e5
yes yes
you could play h4 bishop take c5 bishop
b4 but at the end
the rogue rook on eight shade is hanging
so this is not any move by the bishop
can be met with the
move by the queen and as you were just
mentioning the rook is hanging
absolutely
so you do have to defend the spawn i
feel uh this bishop has to go somewhere
on e6 to open up the queen oh you could
play queen f6 i guess
and i don't know is it now
well but here i take a go h4 right
sorry excuse me h4 is a big threat yeah
good morning
good morning lewis
okay uh knight takes e5 uh
challenge a challenge absolutely and
he's actually taken with the bishop on
e5
which i assume the point of this move is
that if you take on e5 there's no yeah
here i have sword to deal with i have a
very uh yasser move in this position
queen c3 knight sequence i have an even
more yesterday move than this position
oh double attack double attack
oh thank you very much
i was afraid the training we were going
but yes indeed uh
queen takes a7 that's going to encourage
castles short sadly enough
but queen takes g5 is much more serious
yes
that is a a very very uh
i'm taking away the attack but then the
question is
yeah g4 i don't think i have time to
take on a7
because that would really be
asking for it right yeah and i think it
actually
loses tactically because rook 8 and
rotates a5 picks up a um
a piece either on f3 or an a5 yes so
this doesn't actually quite work and on
g4
i mean desirable knight g5
it's desirable but at the same time it's
a leap of faith right it kind of is
you're kind of hoping that this knight
doesn't get trapped right right right
right wow okay uh
this game is certainly as the
what is it
but what is your knee jerk
who's better
white white right oh yeah yeah because
black's king black's king feels loose
like somehow i feel that white is
getting the upper hand okay christian
what do you have for us absolutely
definitely guys from a strategical point
of view it does feel like white is on
top
structurally he's much better you see
the double pawns you see this uh pawn on
e5 separated from his up pack and
unfortunately it does look strategically
as you guys were mentioning that black
is worse but dynamically on the other
hand i'm seeing these pawns roll down
the board and i'm seeing a great attack
coming white's way and if you don't
manage to defend against that well you
might be in trouble early on and you
guys are mentioning queen to e3 that's a
double attack an obvious double attack
the pawn on a7 and the pawn on g5
unfortunately after g4 and this is what
the engine is recommending right now it
seems like black is just much better
already after g4 black is just much
better you cannot take on a7 of course
that would be too greedy even for yasser
yes after castle you can basically just
resign because rook way 8 is coming
picking up the knight on a5 as well as
the knight on f3 you cannot play chess
like this you cannot go hunting pawns
like that so unfortunately after g4 it
does seem like black is getting all the
dynamic he needed in the position to
gain full control queen to c3 is another
way to create a double attack this is
not as obvious obviously i'm attacking
the pawn on e5 but also what i'm
attacking is the pawn on b7 because
knight takes b7 so for example if you
try to defend uh this pawn on e5 with a
natural move queen to g7 knight takes b7
just wins the game you cannot take on b7
queen takes c6 comes on the board that's
a double attack i'm going to win two
pawns and the exchange with devastating
consequences for black's position so
queen to c3 is much more difficult to
defend now
what do you guys think the best move in
the position is right now
uh knee joint reaction yeah jerk
reaction i would be most frightened of
bishop b4 castle is the best
movie now you you played h5 you played
g5 you lost one of the pawns no
partnership in front of your castle and
now you play castle at move 17. yeah
good luck with that so queen to c3
castle would have been probably the best
move now i'm sure you can also play
moves such as g4
give me the pawn on e5 and then try to
weave some sort of dynamic play around
that queen to c3 would have been a very
difficult question to answer instead of
that fabiano seems to have taken uh the
immediate reaction of playing the move
knight to c4 focusing once again on the
pawn on e5 but in a different fashion
and at this point right now black has a
choice to make you can play the move a
bishop takes c4 but strategically after
that you know that you're going to be in
trouble if
white manages to stabilize the position
and uh avoid your attack on the king
side so bishop takes c4 is one of the
ways you can defend the pawn on e5 you
can also just drop back with bishop to
f7 and i do like this move a bit better
because
sure you can take one of my bishops but
when you take one of my bishops at least
i'm going to improve my structure i'm
going to take with the c pawn connect my
pawns
defend my weakness on e5 and then i will
have a lot of time to focus on my attack
on the king side definitely liking
what's happening in this game i'm not
100 sure who's better you guys said
white is better sure
maybe from a strategical point of view
but from a practical point of view with
this pawns and this pawn storm coming on
the king's side it might actually be the
type of position nakamura enjoys uh
playing uh let's just take a look at
what happened in the other games duda
versus richie rapport after c5 this is
where we left it off long thing e5 came
on the board and we discussed this
variation e5 is going to be met with
bishop to g5 and you're going to have to
defend the dark squares around your king
exactly what happened
unfortunately for black this allows me
to take on d6 and your structure is
going to be damaged for the remaining of
the game and unfortunately this does
give white quite a significant advantage
right now bishop to e6 one hour and
three minutes for which we report one
hour and 20 minutes for a do that
definitely looking like duda is in pole
position to take the full point home now
nothing happened almost nothing happened
in rajabov versus uh ali reza after
bishop takes c4 he did spend a lot of
time
on this move 15 minutes to be more
precise on this move rook to c1 only 42
minutes left for a timor and 20 moves to
go that's not a good sign and uh bishop
to d5 by the way once again in only a
couple of uh minutes and right now it
does feel like black is building up
quite a nice advantage
and what but chris
yes sure yeah why why not knight d3 we
went over this variation with yasser on
the board right right and we thought you
can't play rook c1 he doesn't he doesn't
want to uh to to bail out he he wants to
actually uh keep a dynamic position uh
in balanced position because after rook
takes c3 bishop takes d3 maybe i can go
knight to c5 and this does feel uh like
it eliminates too many pieces from the
board because after knight to c5 what
are you going to do are you going to
keep uh you you don't have a good way to
get the bishop back on the long diagonal
that's a problem right are you going to
take on c5 sure you can take on c5 but
you almost sense that uh timor is
getting closer to equality and this is
what i think he wants i have the
position right
quality
about everything i'm up the exchange why
am i looking for equality you're not up
the exchange right oh you mean before
why because you're 40 uh two minutes uh
on the clock for the next 20 moves and
because your opponent is blitzing out
his moves
i'm the guy you know that you're in the
interview wow you know that you're in
danger he spent 15 minutes on the clock
he took the decision to uh allow black
to potentially recapture the exchange
and at least equalize the game he did
not take it he uh keeps the imbalance in
the position after bishop e5 i like this
decision by ali reza and after rook to
e1 you can play the move queen to a8 28
plays itself
it plays itself exactly it plays itself
you want to activate all of your pieces
and after that
well at some point white has to do
something and what is that something are
you going to play g3 you cannot remove
this knight from uh
lights questions on f3 are you going to
go g3 yes light squares don't look that
great after that well e4 is hanging you
can't play g3 right we go queen c2 first
but that's what i'm saying later on and
by the way
how about i'm going to take another pawn
yeah i just don't know when later on
comes because bishop b4 is still
correct a pretty strong threat not to
mention that i don't think i want to
play g3 at all to begin with yeah i was
going to go with knight g5 myself yeah
knight to g5 sure and now we're getting
into some complications right right
uh knight to g6 i am well defended and
you have to make some serious decisions
because if i manage to drop back bishop
to e7 and then start pushing the a pawn
you might be in trouble but it's a very
specific position there in that final
moment
uh christian that's a h4 h4 seems to be
the best move because bishop got these
four yeah
right yeah h5 how does it go h5 already
bishop takes e4 it does seem like it's
the best move yeah you have to give the
take and then i go knight to h4
wow this is just alien it's a mess
none of these moves made any sense it's
a complete mess exactly it's not
practical to play like this and who
knows maybe ali reza actually has seen
this position in his notes we don't know
that right but you have to start
thinking about these type of scenarios
if you're team rajabov and you're
spending all of your time and your
opponent is splitting out his moves not
only that he's blitzing out his moves
he's not making the obvious move knight
to d3 right the guys that uh the move
that you guys measure and the time the
the the clock times for the players uh
christian after ruku you won 40 minutes
for timur one hour and 40 minutes
time difference yeah extra hour for ali
that's a very big time discrepancy
one i mean
the marvelous things about candidates
tournaments is you almost feel like the
players are bringing a different
knowledge
to chess it's like you know you we
evolve we we improve our
ourselves and
round one is
you know regardless of what what happens
i'm already getting the impression that
we're seeing this uh play
where
they're maximizing like everybody's
going
you know big big right yeah it really
does feel like it i mean
look at look at look at the four games
that we have and they're all a fight
every single one of them is a fight you
might be arguing that perhaps it's a
fight that's going wrong for one of the
players yeah absolutely that's a
different matter yeah everybody's
playing ambitiously exactly and
yeah sorry i just wanted to jump to the
game of fabi for just a moment yes
because one of the things that i always
enjoyed was messing up in the opening
and then castling by hand
right
and i got this idea okay here's the idea
if abby has just played the move knight
c4 attacking the pawn on e5 i'm going to
try to defend the pawn tactically with
the move rook d8 now i was hoping you'd
play queen c3 just for a moment
and i know it's going to look a little
ugly to your eyes but takes takes g4
now it's knight versus bishop and i'm
assuming you're going to play knight d
knight to e1 yeah 91 looks much better
than 92 just because i'm going to the
stable square d3 and then i had this
crazy idea of castling by hand if i
could put my tuck my king away yeah i'm
going to have to disagree yes it's not
crazy i think it's logical right yeah i
think the king belongs on the queen side
you have to get it there somehow i like
this with king d7 and then at the end of
the day what i've got are these two
pawns over on the king side and maybe h4
g3 yeah like can blow up with bishop c5
as well
and
to my eyes it's a it's a mess but it's a
three result absolutely a three years
old mass i think
i could probably take white but that i
would say it's a personal opinion more
than an objective opinion i like the
stability of the structure true
on d3 the knight on d3 very nice but i
also think that dynamically black has a
great position the king is going to be
very safe behind all its four pawn
phalanx on the queen side and you're
starting to rip me apart with g4 and h4
i do really have to take care of that at
some point
dynamic position everything to play for
exactly what we want to look at i wanted
to go to the do the game and see exactly
how bad
richard stands we have
a few moves being played uh queen takes
d6 castles bishop e6 right i expected
the move queen c2 because i thought rook
d1 was such a crushing idea queen c2
rook d1 very sensible knight a3 also
sensible taking the square c4 under
control yeah rook d8 bishop e2
and we're actually going into an end
game yeah
if i was going to i would want to
deprive black of his
best minor bishop e2 queen d1 rook 61
and we're here we're here uh it still
looks ugly very ugly for black uh the
spawns on c6 and a7 are very easily
targetable and this is absolutely bishop
on g7 is just bad
true that everything i can see that uh
the split pawns easy to attack them
uh black's chances lie with his two
bishops now the question is
he doesn't how does he work how does he
work the magic but he's good after
bishop
white also
[Laughter]
let me tear up my speech here just a
second i was working on something
well it's about to get going rook takes
d1 never mind uh rook takes d1 bishop
takes a2 might allow black just to bail
out
so for the moment i know it's a stretch
but for the guys no no no you're just
guys
no no you're taking the rook here we're
headed towards that variation and richie
rapport is uh expeditiously going there
because after rook takes d1 bishop takes
eight but b3 right it's over the game is
over knight to
this is b5 very easy move to miss oh my
gosh you might take on d1 and you
immediately take on a2 you're saying
okay i see that you're probably going to
drop back with the bishop take the pawn
on a7 and then maybe you have an
advantage maybe
you completely miss the move knight to
b5 and after this move you're almost in
resignation time territory right because
you have to deal with things like knight
to d6 king to d7 and good luck defending
this one i can take the exchange after
knight to um f7 i can even go move such
as knight to b7
check this move out this knight on b7
actually is just going to stay there
after this i'm just simply going
bishop you blocked your
pieces are playing an amazing role in
the position and i'm just going to drop
back knight to c5 followed by rook to a1
focus on the pawn on a7 you're
completely
busted and this is just uh the
complicated way out right uh i can just
simply go knight to f7 pick up the
exchange and then be uh in a better
position none of this is this one he did
take with the bishop
it's fine the thing that's the thing he
didn't everybody
he assumed that bishop takes a2 was a
problem right he should have stopped he
should have understood that after bishop
takes a2 knight to b5 is an option and
then that would have given him a a much
superior position to this one after
bishop to d1
this allows black to get the king to d7
and maybe involve the rook into play so
i'm not liking black's position by any
stretch of the imagination i'm just
saying that rook takes d1 would have
given a white a decisive advantage
objectively and even more of a decisive
advantage from a practical perspective
wow sometimes i hear you loud and clear
sometimes you do have this little tunnel
vision
and in this position where i i wanted to
play bishop takes d1 not only because in
my mind uh i wanted to keep the fondant
defended i really wanted to play bishop
b3 invite you to trade bishops on so
that i could go a takes b3 and then my
rook would swoop down on a good day and
i would get to play knight to c4 uh i
must say the move um
knight b5 is hidden but once you see
that move i'm just wondering
could black mix things up by playing f7
f5
and the idea is that i give myself the
f7 square so knight b5 is a
playable in this position bishop c4
might even be game over right oh because
my desired king f7 walks into rook d7
rook d7 is one of many issues i could
take and go knight c4 but i think we're
going to rip d7 is
more than good enough oh
oh then in that case it's not even like
uh uh disputable rook takes
just
far better than bishop takes d1 yeah
bishop takes d1 and bishop b3
let's jump quickly to ding lyrin's game
because uh that game uh our number one
seed uh has been refusing to take upon
for some time he played the move knight
a4
i always thought that he was he was
aspiring for b5
but knight a4 is a little surprised
bishop takes b2 we're caught up with the
players
i was thinking what to take back i'm
assuming the queen
wanting to keep control over the c5
square for the moment
still like white
it's funny those double pawns don't make
a a big impression but they do cover so
many squares yeah yeah wow yeah okay you
have this long-term problem with this
bishop on g2 you really need to make
sure it gets back in the game
if it if it stays
imprisoned yeah and we're playing a
piece down for the rest of the rest of
the game now the game between timor also
to me sorry i mean i appreciate
everything christians christian is
trying to teach me and
bring me into higher consciousness and i
don't get it
i refuse your higher cost
i don't get it i mean but okay he did
play rookie one and we are expecting
queen a8
with quite some uh
dynamic
double-edged things interestingly this
is ferocious first long think of the
position which comes
at a point where i think he finally has
an obvious move
and he's stopped and then he's stuck
right because i thought between bishop
d5 and knight d3 you could take a long
think and decide all right i'm not gonna
go for knight e3 because x y and z right
what do you think about it
but he didn't he just played bishop d5
tempo like in a minute and 50 seconds
like no no no no no no no knight d3
wasn't uh really high on the agenda and
after rookie one he's on the 12 minute
thing
uh on on a position which
in a bullet game
queen eight and then i think later right
exactly but no queen a8 is so compelling
because you're creating this fantastic
battery on this diagonal your knight on
f4 is really yeah you're hoping just to
get this knight to move and anywhere it
moves is terrible because knight takes
g2 and or bishop takes f3 is going to
end the game which is why
uh christian
ourselves went down this whole queen c2
bishop takes knight g5
pathway where complicated pathway right
yeah
playing for knight f6 check
our actual analysis went to somewhere
about these parts where we broke it off
and said
we don't know we don't get it we don't
get it uh crazy crazy game and finally
and lastly we're coming back to our
marquee matchup game
rook d8 on the board uh he didn't go for
that
queen c3 variation uh
uh pardon me fabi did not he took
immediately he took immediately uh i
definitely don't want to take with the
rook or the queen as that leaves a
completely shattered structure no i'm
not taking with the queen everyone
g5 and rook takes d6 looks silly because
of the queen c3 and now there's nothing
that can possibly hold me hold me
prevent me from capturing
the the pawn so
it leaves this and are we back to our
double attack i think so because if you
don't double attack with queen e3 in the
position i
don't really know you better put some
media pressure because
the bishop will actually over time
become better than the knight and in the
meanwhile g5 g4 h4 h3 will
will compel something and with c takes
d6 this king on e8 i think feels safer
even on e8 yeah like there's no real way
to get to it and it's just going to stay
there
ah so we'll just play a few more moves
for a moment i want to play knight d3
and or f3
really want to play f3 though
i said it just because i wanted to throw
you off
but yeah my rook on f1 is kind of ugly
so maybe i do want to play f3 right but
i would be happy to take isolate your e4
pawn which is on a light square by the
way by the way you're going to give me
the a pawn no i i probably should play
something like b6 okay b6 great okay so
knight d3 and i am prepping
and
and i do think that even in these
positions yeah king d7 king c7 might
still be okay you're you're you're
taking off
and i'm assuming um thanks
and you're
actually you're not completely compelled
to go there you might want to spend the
tempo in a different way in any case i
am about to play rook f1 and
i don't know
again just a three result game just hard
chess it is and this one i particularly
like black like i like the potential of
the bishop i always like having more
central phones
agreed uh and by the way that structure
now that it's undoubled the pawn on e5
feels so
so much safer i just just want to get in
another quick uh shout out to our
audience that you're certainly welcome
to join the conversation any time you'd
like we really would appreciate any uh
questions uh
about the event and this is how you can
get in touch with us alejandro
absolutely join us uh in the
conversations at st louis chess club on
twitter or you can ask us on our live
chat on twitch on youtube i am
monitoring some of them as well as some
of our moms here at the same list
they will be sending over the best uh
questions we do have a couple of good
ones please
hit me up
actually an interesting one talking
about rivalries yes do you find it
interesting this was one of the on the
twitch chat do you find it interesting
that despite being from neighboring
countries
this is right jabbo's anneli reza's
first match
first game first game ever
remarkable right wow but then on the
other hand as uh christian was
mentioning at the opening of the show
timor has not been a busy guy he has not
played a lot of games a contraire he is
a very busy guy but not in the chat
right yeah and i think that is one of
the reasons that we don't see a lot of
games between them because the rest is
such a meteoric rise right he doesn't
really have had the chance of playing
all of your top players
we knew him coming right we saw him as a
big talent on the olympics on the
olympic team i mean he's been playing in
the olympic team for many years now for
iran uh before his federation so he was
obviously upcoming yeah but you know
timor wasn't very active back then even
though alireza was from iran there are
not that many uh games between
zerry players and iranian players they
say asian championships there's other
champions but there's not that many
first classical matchup remarkable
really remarkable but uh certainly a
barn burner i mean we're completely
confused about this game in many many
respects
wow so i just kind of feel like it's one
of those games that you'll come back two
years from now and you still have some
confusion christian guys we we saw
alireza coming but we saw him coming in
open events we saw him coming at the
olympia i think his first major grand
master invitational tournament elite
level tournament was tat steel and right
now this year only he got into the grand
chess tour so he's uh nothing player
definitely but his meteoric rise came
mostly from the open tournaments from
wins against 2650 2700s
not at the elite level player but i just
want to tell you guys i'm looking at all
the games and by this time in the
broadcast in most elite level
competitions we see one or two
quick draws or easy draws
right now every single game is extremely
combative even the berlin one between
fabiano and hikaru this one as you guys
pointed out is a three result game
anything can happen black can easily
take over the initiative right now g4 by
the way was played knight to d2 and a6
and i like the fact that hikaru is not
spending a lot of time he's just making
the most practical decisions defend upon
you attack the punch or i'm gonna i'm
going to defend it i'm not going to be
spending 30 minutes on how to defend the
pawn if i go b6 or a6 no i'm just going
to go a6 i feel like my bishop my light
square bishop is nicely covering any
sort of entry squares for your knight
towards my witnesses on the dark squares
on the queen side so i have that covered
and i'm going to attack you on the king
side i am going to go rook to g8
followed by h4 and a g3 if you allow me
to do that king to d7 hide the key in
there bring the other rook to the other
side and it does feel like black is
definitely building quite some dynamic
in the position white on the other hand
has uh the upper hand when it comes to
strategical play if i manage to
potentially play the move f4 i do have
still the target on a d6 if i managed to
uh
put the cannons let's say on the d file
and try to uh target the pawn on d6 i'm
definitely liking this one very
imbalanced despite a very tame start
with berlin and everything else is just
all over the place this game between
rajabov and ali reza
it's a game of so many stories it does
feel like ali reza has uh went hunting
in this one king hunting with his
preparation
with his decision making not playing
that move knight to d3 but keeping the
bishop uh and the knight on the board
and right now we're seeing this position
in which finally he stops
for his most obvious move as you guys
were mentioning since the beginning of
the game queen to a8 um create this
battery on the long diagonal this one is
going to be a wild one
dingley rang nepo
wild one as well uh jan nepalishi right
now is gearing up to potentially open up
uh the h-file with the move g5 white is
going to try to play a4 b5 nothing is
getting simplified in these games this
is the point that i'm trying to make and
also duda versus richie report sure
potentially duda missed a big chance
with rook takes the one but still he has
a very sizable advantage at least from a
practical perspective if not only from
an objective one so
all four games right now could give us
decisive results imagine the shock waves
in the world of chess if nakamura wins
with the black pieces
against uh fabiano if ali reza wins with
the black pieces against timor if timor
beats ali reza i mean
we a lot of stories are developing right
now and we're going to be here to call
them all
well yeah i i have to agree with you
christian i think that we were honestly
a little worried coming into the to the
show that two or three hours into the
show a couple of the games would be over
we would be left with not so interesting
games
but my god they have brought in the heat
you couldn't ask for a better start to
these to these candidates no no question
about i wanted to say that as we were
developing the show opening the show
marathon marathon we were talking about
these 14 games played over these two
weeks three weeks and how the it's
exhausting for the players and yet at
the same time
starting with a win how
incredibly important that is uh
over
even though there's this 13 games to go
we it sounds like hyperbole but it's not
the case it really is victory in the
candidates it's it's among light
the pyre yeah and it's so
it's such a stress relief yeah
it's not just get that game in get that
point in because you feel that you need
to win somewhere right and you have this
pressure from the beginning of the
tournament that you have to win
somewhere if you do it early you already
put that pressure on your opponents that
you started well you're the one that
needs to be caught your draws are always
going to get you closer to the end let's
remember the way that a lot of these
candidates win won this event right
bobby started with a win against wesley
so in the
the candidates he won that he won
he got a lucky break against kramnik in
round three right and then he kind of
squeezed himself towards the end he
didn't lose that game against karjakin
but he had already built up the little
bit of a springboard that he could fall
back into and i think that closed out
fantastic fantastically right well let's
not forget this is also a physical
endurance test right 14 games played
over three weeks it's true it really is
exhausting i mean really exhausting if
you can maintain some energy just by not
putting pressure on yourself that you
have to win a game that also helps
and we do as we see our schedule we see
three games in a row followed by rest
day three games in a row as a rest day
that is our mojo throughout the whole
tournament those rest days how important
are they uh
alejandro uh
players do
get exhausted oh absolutely and the way
that they spend it really varies by
player right
face the face plant in the bed is
the way i spent my candidates
i mean a lot of players do do that i
know a lot of players like to keep sharp
and they actually prepare during the
they're interesting uh a lot of them
like to adjust their strategies going
into the rest they go following up the
event so
wrestlers actually are play a huge role
in tournaments and the fact that we have
so many of them in this event yeah uh
changes the dynamics of a lot of these
rounds it gives a break to a lot of
these players the momentum right shifts
a couple of questions that i want to
present to yourself and to christian as
well and they go like this
in our modern candidates going back to
2013 so we played five candidates
only one time
has the rating favorite one
magnus 2013 2013. and he did it backing
across the finish line right by losing
so the number one seed
doesn't win these candidates at least
by modern standards which means players
like nepo
who were kind of counted out after the
first half with mvl but then he had this
uh gorgeous return which is why hikaru
is such is not such an outlandish pick i
don't think i don't think he carries an
outlandish pick at any point i think
that he's largely underestimated when it
comes to classical chess he's a
brilliant classical chass player yes he
is uh the thing about hikaru is that
he's not his focus and his repertoire is
so predictable which might not matter in
a rapid match it might not matter even
in a tournament
but for a candidates where you play
everybody twice when you have so many
rounds when you have so many months to
prepare that's like his greatest
weakness okay in my opinion and i think
that if he can overcome that if he gets
the strong seconds if he gets the
chemistry with the seconds to get the
openings that he wants right hikaru is
such a dangerous player exactly out
calculate anybody in the tournament he's
rapid and he's confident yeah and he's
hungry he is
one of the hungriest players in this
event because he's 34. what does he carl
have left yeah he has not played a world
championship match he hasn't even come
close to playing a world championship
match the one candidates he played in
2016 i think he would finish
peter
that that that their queen's indian that
they prepared
so he's looking at this like saying i've
done everything in the chess world right
this is what i have to do this is what's
left
uh and i want uh
christian to also jump in here with a
comment my thought is to win this
tournament the tpr is going to be 28 50
and above
and usually 98.50 and above 28.50 is a
high exactly you got to go plus three
plus three uh won the last couple of
candidates right right those were 28.50
results christian
2018 and 2016 it was a sergey who won i
think with plus four if i'm not it was
plus four because he had to be because
bobby had to be sergey and he went all
out and sergey actually demolished him
exactly
uh so he there sergey had a better than
2850 result thanks to the plus four so
then you look at the field and you go
okay
one of these guys would do something
crazy and perform
exactly what we discussed at the
beginning of the broadcast and going
into this event hikaru uh in the span of
the last two years 2020 to 2022 is the
only player in the field that high that
has a 28 plus
rating performers
and this tells me that hikaru is
probably the most in shape player
in this field now whether he did those
28 100 plus performances against top
elite level players or in the grand prix
now that's a different story and of
course we know that in the grand prix he
probably uses different type of openings
as well much more aggressive because he
needs to win a lot of games in this one
out of 13 you only need to win three
games
but will he be able to do that that's
that is the big
question and it does seem like fabiano
also in 2018 he scored plus four yeah
also with plus three he would have won
at that event but he scored a final uh
round victory against greece with the
black pieces totally unexpected yeah
exactly we discussed that so again
coming into the event who are the
players
you know
a very streaky player and when things go
right boy he he looks like a world
champion challenger yeah but when things
go wrong we see dubai
and it was not a pretty sight it wasn't
i think nepo is one of those players
that you can never count out he's just
so dangerous uh he's so fast right he's
so creative and he's not afraid of
playing things like knight g4 i mean
knight g4 today is just such a nap wow
it's just such an epic move
he is an uncompromising chess player and
that's what makes him so difficult to
play against dangerous yeah maybe a
little bit to himself as well yeah and
it's been his downfall in many
tournaments i remember a tournament in
zagreb where yes he was plus three he
was going three and if you just beat
fabi with black and everything was going
his way you give that tournament result
to wesley so yeah he makes a draw here
makes a draw there finishes the event
plus three cruises to first place right
but no yeah he like ended up one plus
one fifty percent something like that
and i remember very famously um i think
it was christian who was interviewing
gary uh
and and gary says well has nepa played
magnus yet
and that was
that was the door closer right there
yeah he didn't get past magnus and then
he kind of just like soured a great
start a great start so we're looking for
the player who's going to win this game
and who's going to win this tournament
become challenger is somebody's going to
rack up at least a plus three score a
28.50 tpr tournament performance rating
or better
uh to be challenger and
farruga i think is a player can do it
fabi has
has proven it several times he can play
like a 3 000 clip
and of course uh nepo is
now
richie
see the thing about paper ball
capable but it's not again consistent
it's not about his chest strength it's
about consistency and it's about
mentality
when you think about strong players
mentally richie is not the first player
that comes to mind he's very
self-critical yes he is oh we saw that
so much so much
in the grand chester and he is prone
of making a mistake and destroying his
fortitude for the rest of the tournament
right i mean
for example what happened to him in uh
in bucharest yeah where he blunders and
move 40
against dak right and he just never
recovered that's true we never saw him
again right and i'm worried about that
by richard great player great tactician
when things are going when things are
going well kind of like nepal things are
going amazing right but can he keep that
up that's what's going to be his biggest
concern i think and that is the reason
that it really matters who his team is
and if he can find a team that brings
him the support that is able to pick him
up from the inevitable something goes
wrong in this tournament because for 14
games something will eventually go wrong
exactly uh can you pick yourself back up
recover and do well anyway and that's
where i think richard needs to work on
can he bring it to the candidates that's
his weakness
and finally my last questions to
ourselves before we get into the
audience questions
a defense wins championships and what i
mean specifically by that is you don't
lose yeah you don't lose you just go
through the event undefeated
maybe you want honest fury
but throw in a few wins not just all
draws but you don't lose games yeah is
that what it takes you can lose one you
can lose one yeah and you to win to win
the candidates by losing two games
it's that's a big ass because then
you've got to win five yeah i don't
recall anybody that's won the candidates
recently with two losses except for
did magnus lose two i was i was going to
say he lost to peter theater that was
good
i had the impression that he might he
might have just double checked i'll
double check in a second
but besides that i have to agree with
you you have the the right to lose 1 out
of 14 that's not a big margin no
christian is that true
1 out of 14 and no more i think so yes
you can lose one but if you lose
2 i think you're completely out because
it's so difficult to win games in this
type of events and you do need to win a
lot of them you need to win three maybe
four of them if you have to win five of
them you already lost two and we know
that historically plus three probably
will win you maybe will take you to a
tie break and let's not forget for this
particular candidates it's the first
time that we use a playing tie break so
for example the players finish uh equal
points they will have to play a match to
determine who's going to be the
challenger before that there are all
sorts of other tiebreaks uh direct
victories and so on but right now they
will play a match if they finish with
equal points so right now you're
probably going to have to be looking at
the plus three maybe plus four to win
this event out right if you lose two
already and you have to win six more
that's probably not going to happen you
have to win five more that's probably
not going to happen so i don't see it
you can lose one game and that's it
after that you have to start get uh back
on your winning path and i was looking
by the way at this graphic of fabiano
caruana and why did i pick him
you see this highlighted 2014 may 2014
his rating was 27.83
since then he hasn't dropped anywhere
close to that right now he's at 27.84
but unfortunately in may 2014 his trend
was trending positively upwards right
now he's training downwards check this
out
2020 rating 28 35 since then it's a down
slope and right now he's at 27 84. why
i'm saying i'm going to pick fabiano is
that every time he reaches anywhere
close to this level it's like lava for
his rating he just jumps up he goes back
to 2800 he has a monstrous performance i
remember in tata steel he actually won
26 rating points a couple of years ago
with them
when he was in islam he had somewhere
around the same rating 27 89 and then he
won 26 rating points and he went back uh
to 2800 plus so this is what i'm seeing
historically from fabiano caruana
whenever he gets close to this uh level
he jumps up and this is what i'm
expecting from him in this tournament
also he has experience winning this type
of winner takes all events long winner
takes all events status still is also a
13 round tournament candidates we know
he has plenty of experience in that one
and he tends to get if not winning them
gets close to that winning spot
generally okay second position
potentially nevertheless it gets close
to that i'm expecting a monstrous
performance from him in this event and
to win it all bouncing off his floor but
let's take some tweets let's take some
tweets uh a quick note that magnus did
lose to yvonne chuck as well in 2013
that i remember so he actually won five
games wow and lost two but besides that
i don't recall anybody else's lost two
games and taking the candidates but
let's take a look at our tweet uh thank
you everybody that's joining our
conversation here from actually from
youtube
question for yasser who was harder to
face
rybovich
well first of all you're talking about
two of the greatest yugoslavian players
of all time
and i remember the first time i played
goligrich the audience was practically
cheering the moment he walked in i was
like look what am i a potted plant
[Laughter]
i walk in there's no applause
he walks it everybody
prays on their knees it was just really
rather hilarious i won that game by the
way
of itch by far lubo at the board there's
just certain players you know they that
have this
toughness like like at the board
lubo was beastly he really really played
incredibly hard
i i played more often with lubo than i
did with uh svedazar svetizar also got
his licks in against me
and with lubo i don't know what it is we
brought out the worst and maybe the best
in one another as very few of our games
were drawn
and we were just cooperating each other
taking big bites
out of one another's heights uh yeah and
lubo is a great competitor again both
players were great
uh but thank you for the question man
the memories great question yeah
right to very sound players when you
think about yugoslavian chess i mean
sure and what great culture you have
over there in all of the yugoslavian
countries former yugoslavian countries
right it's just amazing
the olympic team they're supporting
everybody's competitiveness when they
have matches stadiums oh yeah you have
auditoriums full of people watching this
game still after today yes it is really
a great chess culture over there right
and uh happy to be returning not
specifically to where they're from but
we'll be going with the grand chess tour
to a former yugoslavian uh with zagreb
coming up in july we have more tweets
let's take a look at what else uh the
internet is bringing for us
what's your hair routine christian
now our
demanding viewers want to know
how do you do it how do you do it
it's not that complicated you have a sea
salt spray you have a spray you have the
gel you have the rice no i'm joking i'm
dry
the three types of scissors wash my hair
every
morning get another dryer i put some
i
single
gel some product in it and that's it
that's all is it is it real cream it
takes me maybe five minutes ah okay
it's not that bad not bad not bad you
believe that demanding yeah yeah yeah
question demanding questions uh funnily
enough uh jumping back to the game for
just a moment after queen a8
which was the longest thing
uh of alireza king queen c2 the box
there was nothing yeah and now another
long thing which is like really
confounding i think i mean you
sacrificed the exchange in no time and
now you stopped i thought grenade was an
automatic but here i think there's more
of a room to to think okay because
bishop a3 and those lines that we were
looking with knight fg5
yeah we threw them easily because it's
not our king
but yes but it's true but you know you
kind of get made it if you don't
calculate this properly if it goes wrong
if it goes wrong it goes really wrong so
you really want to make sure bishop a3
works if you want to play that move but
it's not a forced move no it moves like
rook d8 rook b
man even h6
has a sense it has a sense just because
there is this kind of awkwardness yeah
and there's rook on d2 isn't
everybody's happy yeah and you've got a
well okay it's a laborious effort but
after rookie three you're going to try
to untangle you know you'll move your
knight maybe the c5 or maybe the c3
yeah okay
i'm just looking from
when i'm down material
oftentimes i have
whether it's right or wrong this mental
approach that i better do something
rather immediate
i can't let
the opponent
unwind untangle and and i think it's a
it's something that we've learned more
and more
through previous years that even though
you're down material sometimes you can
play it not like your down material but
just play like a normal position
play move like h6 it's not a quick move
it doesn't take material back
immediately no but at the end of the day
your real strength is your bishop on d5
right and h6 works with your bishop on
d5 because of the knight
it stops knight g5 it stabilizes in some
way the knight on f4 if it gets it you
can go g5 yourself if it doesn't get hit
um then you know it's just very well
placed there you don't want to play h3 a
useful lift a useful look back like you
later in the game you never know when
you're gonna get mated on the eighth
rank just useful useful useful useful
okay and non-materialistic
i think this is what he's considering
between bishop takes a3 and h6
and then of course the materialistic
because bishop takes a3 isn't just about
winning upon it's about the desired uh
bishop before in order to secure an
exchange and win back the exchange so
slow move h7 h6 materialistic move
bishop takes a3 active
activating right away with moves like
rook b8 and rook b3 rook d8
this is where
it's not just the creativity i i want to
say it's a it's a style yeah
yeah it's
the factor it's a definitely a style
thing at this point
complicated position i think it's easier
to play with black but you have to do it
in a way
that
squashes white's activity and i think
that knight fg5 even knight eg5 are such
compelling moves right that i would be
very tempted not to take one just
disallow just this allow it yes yeah
okay cool well definitely we'll keep an
eye on that one and uh christian uh jump
in with a game that's caught your
attention
i was uh looking at this game between
the two americans fabiano versus hikaru
and fabiano played this very intriguing
move b3 what does he want with this move
b3 does he want to jump with the knight
to c4 force the exchange and potentially
try to pressure on the b file the
problem with that you're also giving
yourself another huge weakness in the
position the pawn on c for the double
pawns on the c file so i'm not saying
sure what white wanted with this move b3
so i think what black should have done
at this point is continue his attack on
the the king side with the move rook to
g8 now rook to g8 not only that it
prepares the move h4 h4 followed by h3
and potentially if you're not paying
attention h3 as well but also for
example if you try to play the move f3
and we've seen uh this move from fabiano
in the game and we will see that in just
a second the difference with the recon
g8 already is that you have this extra
move queen to g5 and this almost forces
the trade of the queen's queen to hg5
i have their position as black white
because my king is already in the
nicely uh in place in the center ready
to defend the pawn on d6 but also open
up the
rook on d8 to double up on the g file
and once again put tremendous pressure
on white's king side so i do think that
this position is favorable for uh black
also we know that the cooperation
between the rooks and the bishop is much
better than the roots and the knight we
know that queen and knight is usually
better at least considered to be better
than queen and bishop rooks and bishop
is considered to be better than rooks
and knights so this is what he was
supposed to be looking for in terms of
exchanges black that is
rook to g8 was not played on the board
actually a completely different approach
for uh from hikaru he played the move
castle at move 21 with all his pawns
already
out in the open castle was played and
immediately fabiano took advantage of
that with the move f3 you get your king
to the king side i'm going to open the
kingside and i'm actually the one that
right now is going to be looking for an
attack against your king queen to g7 f
takes g4 this is the current position we
have on the board if you do take with a
bishop i'm going to be able to jump with
the knight to c4 finally uh give this
knight a job attacking that pawn on d6
trying to target the weaknesses in
black's position if you do take with the
h pawn the problem is right now without
the uh rook on the h file you no longer
have an attack on the h file so i'm
going to be able
to d1 prepare uh the strategical play in
a white's camp i'm potentially going to
target uh this maneuver of the knight to
g3 and go to f5 i really like white's
prospects at this point and i have to
say castle surprised from hikaru we know
that he's a very aggressive player when
given the chance and right now he was
given the chance he could have kept the
king either in the center on e8 or as
you guys were mentioning quite a few
times goking to d7 transfer the king uh
to the queenside get ready to uh get the
rook from d a to f8 and put tremendous
pressure on white's position on the king
side he did not do that and now it does
seem like white is taking over the
initial
sorry i was going to go to the top seed
dingler in yeah before before that i
wanted to say that one of the biggest
lies i was ever told in my opinion as a
chess amateur learning chess eight nine
years old queen and i better than queen
and bishop right i think john watson
convincingly refused
yeah i think that that was just like
some myth that went around since the age
of capablanca and i think it was
precisely that guy that was actually
that guy yeah
he won some games and he convinced
everybody because he just won them so
very easy so very easily but i i do
think bishop and queen are actually
better better better pieces bishop and
they work well yeah let's just jump to
the dingler in first yeah because a lot
happened right and it doesn't seem to be
going well for the chinese player
because nepo has consolidated his
position precisely that's exactly right
this knight coming to dt5 it was ugly on
a6 right pretty on d5 very pretty and
now what we've seen from uh nepo he's
basically mobilized everything yeah like
and the knight is good the rooks are
really good the spawn on e4 we mentioned
that it's imprisoning this bishop on g2
and much more importantly this queen on
h5 is hovering
uh just
kind of saying you know what one day i'm
going to play g5 let's make a bad move
for white i'm not sure how bad a good a
move like a4 is and if we get something
like this this is where things go wrong
right away dingler
is in deep waters here queen h2 bishop
h3
white could get mated just end of story
so it's one of those things that
you've got to destabilize the knight on
d5 yes you could even consider
sacrificing exchange but i think uh
things have become a little bit critical
here yeah you
better rush whatever it is you're doing
with white sorry no i agree it's
important that white does something very
quickly the moment the g5 appears on the
board you better have a response you
might want to have a response before the
phone actually arrives on g5 this is a
very quick attack yes i'm actually a
little surprised uh if we can go back
one move if the move
rook no queen is fine
is it
absolutely necessary is there a reason
not to play the move g5 right away i
assume that at that point dingleran
would have snapped on d5 yeah i don't
see another
whether it's including hg or not
but in this case the bishop on f5
is a tempo so you're not an important
tempo because h6 queen h2 is non-mate
it's just a check exactly
um
now
it gets a little bit
messy yeah and i'm thinking
right resources right but if you be 95
then you'd think to yourself golly i
would just like to have my rook on e
yes and maybe that's why we have the
mover k8 on the board
preparing in some way the move g5 it
mobilizes everybody it's not a committal
move okay it's one of those moves that
allows you to have all of your ideas
still on the board right without putting
your pieces in awkward squares so i
really like this one yep
and
one of the things also about our number
one
for quite a number of years uh
especially his olympic performance which
is so outstanding i mean it's just like
like crazy when the chinese won the uh
gold medal and one thing's wow
i don't know where actually yeah that
was just so cool uh his previous
candidate's apparent
even though he beat nepo in the last
round it's not something he will
remember he came into the second half
yeah hopeless exactly right yeah just
such a horrible first house yeah
but
because of the pandemic because of the
shutdown that was happening in china
this layoff this forced layoff that he
had okay you mentioned the the training
games
impactful
we'll have to see because it's all he's
had and he hasn't had the experience
that of some of the other players have
been able to have whether they're taught
to steal the traditional tournaments
that you think of right right he hasn't
been able to play in many of them he's
given himself the chance to play one or
two tournaments during the pandemic but
it included the candidates that he
wasn't playing much for in 2021 so he is
underexperienced in the last couple of
years compared to everybody on the field
right how this is going to affect them
we don't know he was even scheduled to
play the grand prix
and he had to skip out pretty much last
minute
so dingley ran great player not a lot of
experience might be showing up today
because i like nephi's position yeah
okay
and then as we go on a break we prepared
for you it's easy for me to say a very
special very
very nice event with duda and warsaw
absolutely because remember jeans do the
last tournament was
warsaw rapid and blitz the local boy and
wild card was able to win a
scintillating tournament
really in front of the home crowd really
everything could have happened as we see
there at the museum of the history of
polish juice in warsaw beautiful play
hall by the way
absolutely scintillating let's take a
look at how this tournament ended
explaining the winner of this tournament
depends on this
seven wins he didn't find it he did not
find rook takes g7 winning the game duda
is back in it he might have a horrible
position but he's kind of back in it
rook c6 is very clever it covers the
third rank in many positions so the
knight takes e66 rook takes e6 defense
h6
so this could go
anyway
everything to play for and shivchenko
down to 30 seconds yes do this in
tremendous pressure but so is kirill now
wow yeah girl carol was it wasn't easy
but he was winning by four by four yeah
he no longer is winning by force just
better queen before eight
clever reply why is still of course of
course in control here yeah
yeah
uh you can you can do all kinds of
things here i'm kind of thinking rook g3
g3 whatever you want but it's ten
seconds against eight let's do it to
make a move you gotta make a move
[Music]
wow
same move faster was better yeah a3
queen b5 and now put it back yeah that's
i think is correct procedure here that
was very good okay seven yeah with rook
on a seven rule
[Music]
having not won the game by force you are
now kind of struggling to to actually
win it right because right
it's not yeah now the entire thing will
come off along the c file and yeah
knight before he very much stabilized
here
yeah remarkable remarkable absolutely
remarkable wow can we take say four oh
no no plundering real quick yeah kirill
not gonna blunder queen h4 check there
yeah for
shuffling they have only how many
shuffling commences well sorry
is that black wins yeah i think he's
made tremendous tremendous price that
rook got to e4
the knight will now come to f4 yeah
should have come to f4 in the previous
move rook g1 was kind of a strange
choice yeah to allow roxy too absolutely
very bizarre choice yeah
rugby one rook only four is a
surprisingly
yeah
oh f4 with knight f5 coming no no he
just lost the full rope there fg oh no
wait wait that means the tournament
that ends the tournament that ends the
tournament that ends the tournament and
yeah
wow anastasia is going to be
very happy with her prediction i know
right who else can do that
i think i don't think it was just her no
yeah i think there were two i know right
was it me yes it was me
we all forgot
and this she did win this game too by
the way but this
but it's not going to be enough this is
a full rook extra for the local hero in
john
shishtoff dude
he's got enough he's got enough he's got
eight seconds it's a rogue it's a rook
wow
yeah
yes it is remarkable scenes you know
that's a nice idea i like
oh queen h5
g4 knight coming to f5 everything comes
together and there's every
dominated
yeah he is yes he's just looking looking
at his book and that's it
yonshir duda wins in a spectacular
fashion
the final round gives him the victory in
poland because chefchenko could not
finish him off when the time came to
draw the sword give the final blow to
his opponent he was unable to do so jan
shishof do the first place in poland the
local hero 40 000
down to the wire
but what a tournament what an incredible
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to the
first round of the 2022 candidates
tournament held in madrid spain as we
see the very first bouts young
christophe duda is nursing an advantage
against richard rappler dingleran seems
to be in a worse position but a fighting
one against janna pomnyacci fabiano
caruana is in a crazy berlin against
hikaru nakamura and meanwhile tamara
java
against ali reza for ruja which means
that we have four exciting
everything to play for in every single
one of them yasser we're having a real
donnie brooke as you like to say right
off the get-go and it's wonderful i mean
i'm telling you we've waited so long for
the candidates to start almost from the
time dubai match ended we say okay
when's the next one grand it's coming up
folks we're seeking a challenger and
we'll start uh our we'll resume our
coverage of round one uh with the game
of ding ler in because during our break
we're looking at the position a little
bit more deeper
and we're beginning to understand that
although it doesn't look anything
special or anything terrible
nepo has a very dangerous advantage
it's one of those positions that could
very very easily just
drift away from you if you allow black
to just continue his king side attack
with the move g7 g5 this rook is poised
to
uh jump across to the h file and
anything where there is that when
there's a pawn on h2 and a queen is
landing on h2
it's just mate yeah you're gonna get
mated as long as bishop on f5 survives
and i think i think by the way on a
22-minute
thing and it's just kind of
you know the
waking up to the realization is basic is
is
crying and i think the main problem for
dinging in this position is that the
moment the g5 lands and i think this is
why rook 88 was such a clever move let's
make any move for the rook rook a8 no uh
up for white rook 88 rogue i don't know
d1 whatever yeah uh and we go g5 yes
let's include takes takes because why
not
and then we take on d5 we wanted to give
up the exchange just to open up a little
bit of the position make my pieces
coordinate better not get mated on the
king side right away exactly the problem
is that you take on d5 you take on d5
and i just go bishop g4 and i ask you
yes very nice you open the d file
congratulations what are you doing with
it what are you doing with it and i am
still just mating you
in the meanwhile in the meanwhile bishop
takes e2 is a threat rick h6 queen h2
bishop h3
to defend
against things that rook takes d5 did
not help you with right the knight
although nice is not directly
participating in the attack exactly and
you really didn't open that many avenues
for your own place so
what is what is why to do in this
position and i think that's why ding is
in such a deep thought as he was
realizing what's going on
yeah and le
and let's just remind everybody that
this isn't
i want to say an old timer's time
control it really is so this is predates
the bobby fischer chess clock where
bobby fischer said well let's give the
players increment for each move they
make no
in this time control each player can get
120 minutes for their first 40 moves
they're welcome to use that 120 minutes
any way they would like if they'd like
to spend 10 minutes on move one and two
and three eventually you have to make
all your moves within 40 minutes 40
moves within 120 minutes or you lose the
game yeah there's no increments at the
moment
ding doesn't have the luxury of that
much time no that's what he's been
sitting yeah he's sitting he's burning
the clock
but okay let's go to christian as he has
updates on another game
well uh guys speaking of uh long things
uh do you guys remember when ali reza
was up one hour on the clock i i think
you do it wasn't a long time ago just a
couple of moves ago actually in that
game queen to a8 he spent 23 minutes on
this one that's not it queen to c2
bishop takes a3 a very obvious um upon a
grabbing situation right now bishop
takes a3 just grab the pawn and think
later right you don't have to worry
about checkmates or anything of that
nature
he spent 36 minutes on that move right
now his time advantage is down to only
15 minutes and that is because timur
jabot has been thinking for the last 10
minutes after bishop takes a3 a big big
moment right now in this game queen to
c3 is one way to stop the move bishop to
b4 it makes a lot of sense bishop to b4
is a threat after all you are gaining an
exchange back and also you will be left
with an extra pawn now that is one
option the other option is to just
simply go knight to g5 and this is what
i believe is
calculated right now and i think was
played by timur rajabov he just played
the move knight to g5 by the bullet and
think later of course this is a big
threat right now bishop to b4 is
impossible knight to f6 would finish the
game in a couple of moves take on f6
queen to h7 that's a checkmate knight to
g5 uh brings a huge threat to the table
and how do you defend against that h6
that's not a defense knight to f6 is
going to come still on the board
followed by queen to h7 g6 that's not a
weakness that's not
a defense knight to f6 is going to come
on the board with devastating
consequences so the only way in which
you can defend in this position is by
either giving up the bishop i don't
think you want to do that or knight to
g6 and i think this is what we're going
to see from ali reza but of course after
knight to g6
this is what we analyzed an hour ago
and
for and the game was getting wild right
now i'm seeing
how many minutes 30 minutes for uh team
raj above
43 minutes for ali rezain this one is
going to turn into a barn burner it is
very intriguing what's going to happen
in the next few moves now another one
that is developing in an unexpected
fashion is a game between fabiano
caruana and hikaru nakamura and we saw
this move castle by hikaru i didn't
necessarily like that but at the same
time you are uh making the connection
between the rooks not with the move king
to d7 you had to do that at some point
you had to find the connection between
the two rooks you either do it with king
to d7 or by castling he decided to uh
castle but after that he follow it up
rook a to d1 normal natural move just
improving my position improving the last
piece that wasn't playing an active role
d5 came on the board he takes d5 c takes
d5 rook d1 and
this just looks like an overextension
from a black's uh perspective because
right now how are you going to defend
the pawn on e5 you're forced to play the
move e4 and i'm going to be able to
continue
um corral around this pawn with the move
c4 exactly you're not going to have the
connected uh pawns in at the center
you're not going to be able uh to get d4
on the board without losing the pawn on
e4 this is just not looking great for a
black right now and if i manage to
weaken the pawn on e4 once i get that
i'm also getting to your king that's the
problem if the queen lands in the center
queen take c4 then you're going to have
to be
around the king to maintain the defense
i'm not liking this position for hikaru
right now and everything changed in the
last three moves guys
just to complete the thought though um
christian yeah that final position that
you had and if i'm in hikaru shoes i
want to bail i want to get out of here
could i take on f1 in the position that
you had christian and then take on c c4
okay so yeah we we had this position
after e4
and then c4 and you know undermining
uh the black structure then i'm sitting
there saying okay against rook at f1
knight takes f1 i think was previously
what
was the recapture that fabio
had intended but in this particular case
uh
i'm wondering can i bail here is uh
honestly
it doesn't even look bad actually after
the move e4 even though i understand the
move c4
i wouldn't be drawn to it actually the
move e4 i feel is already a concession
yes that you actually wanted to play the
move d4 and keep your pawns on dark
squares when your bishop is on a light
square color exactly if i can get my
knight from d2 to d4 i mean the game is
after e4
over it's over i mean traditionally
positionally over the knight is just
dominant over the bishop and it's not
going to get better yeah so i mean
ideally from black's
point of view he would like to keep his
pawns on e5 and d5 for as long as he can
to control as many scores as he can and
if he if he's ever required to crush one
of them he'd rather push the d pawn put
his bishop on d5 and say i've got
something
conversely after the movie he won and
he's provoked e4 just what you said if
on a good day we could ever get our
knight to d4 it would be like uh lights
out and for those reasons you start to
think well look maybe yeah maybe
something like before maybe you take on
f8 first something along these lines
secure the dark squares before i commit
to c4 that i'll play eventually uh yeah
in a better version right when your
knight is already out there so when i
saw the move c4 i i i like undermining
the the structure but i did see a
bailout here for hikaru which
um
i'd grab with both hands actually yeah
absolutely there but we do have e4 on
the move
e4 on the board no no the rookie you
want us on the board but not e4 oh
naughty for oh yeah
you might be considering rook takes f1
what's the times uh we have 30 minutes
for carbon 38 for fobby so still quite
even even yeah yeah with not that many
moves to make 14 for each still very
manageable we showed this highlight
earlier but in their individual um
games that
it's like seven to six with 37
33 that's right
these guys play each other a lot they
know each other wow and you were you
were saying that kara actually got the
best of fabi early yeah and then fabi
started catching up yeah i remember
hikaru uh
he was
kind of the the top brother he was
number two number three in the world and
he had this terrible score against
magnus yes he did he was and he said or
something yeah that's true but look at
my score against fabi and favi actually
turned that around
because higaro did have a crushing uh
advantage four to one or something
something along the lines for the one
five to one and it just
flipped uh five it did get the better
car in the last previous uh games some
crushing defeats
uh for
for hikaru and i think that has become a
real rivalry in in what is american
chess of course two of the top players
uh they've split along with wesley most
of the us championships except for the
one that sam shanklin won right in the
past what like 10 years right like
they've played almost all of them
there's a great quote by fabiano so
three rounds to go in the u.s
championship and he scored two and a
half points and he was thinking okay
give me the first place check and then
sam goes three out of three
and finished the term and it was like
what
and he had a great score but uh our
congratulations to sam we never get
tired of
those us championships they're just such
great great events i do keep on
monitoring the chat and they're telling
us to go to the dingley run game because
things are breaking because things are
going south even further for the chinese
whoa when we left it we just left it
what king h2
rook ae8 was and we saw king h2
whoa i mean the idea of rook h1
the i mean the move g5 is screaming and
i think you're absolutely right that he
had intended
defense
with rook h1
hg and king
whoa
uh let's turn to uh christian for this
exciting breaking
things what that is happening in this
game christian what do you have for us
on this yeah no this is not looking
great and uh from an objective point of
view it's almost losing now the question
is is it also from a practical point of
view almost losing after the variations
that you guys were mentioning g5 rook to
h1 is the only reason why you would play
the move king to h2 take on h4 box your
king and the rook on h1 with king to g1
h3 sure you attacked that one as well
i'm going to go bishop it looks awful
it looks terrible i i just need to find
a way to open up the g-file and
the only way to do that is to actually
push my pawn to h4 and i think queen to
f5 keep control of the pawn on h3 bishop
takes h3 doesn't work at any point sure
you can take this but you don't have
time to take that
what are you going to do next knight to
c5 sure i can leave the rook here and
give the exchange but i can just simply
go rook to f2 force this rook to go to
e2 to defend the pawn f2 and after h4
you don't even need to calculate at this
point you understand that the white king
is just getting crushed right now well
knight 25 rook to f6 came on the board
after king to h2 what is this
guys what is this why not g5 why not
force the white king to go to g1 the
rook on h1 the bishop on f1 visually it
looks horrendous why would you start
with the move rook to f6 and give white
the option of retreating back
i can explain this but it's a very nepo
approach to the game it's a very natural
approach to the game where he likes
putting pressure not just on the board
but on the on the clock and he sees the
move king h2 and he says if i play rook
f6 your only move is king g1 do you
really
want to do that right because it is
sometimes hard for chess players to do
that to play
back and immediately take it back it's
not something you want to do
so but what else right and i think napo
is taking advantage of that right now
that psychologically he's telling
dingler and hey man you know you messed
up do you really want to admit it right
no seriously it's a very good point and
it's something that ben feingold he
likes very much uh when he when we were
growing up i'll say ben and i uh the
soviet players like to do a repetition
and uh after king h2
they would like this move rook f7 oops
excuse me it's like knight a5 they would
like this move rook f6
king g1 like
how how am i getting this repetition but
hey rook e6 and then it's sort of like
they're saying i'm the one
you know uh pressing the action
um and now having said just though
on your g5 was really compelling to be
honest sorry christian but just to build
up
four point and i'm starting to
understand nepo's point quite well right
now because after king to g1 which by
the way was played and g5 most likely is
going to come on the board finally the
only way to not lose badly right now to
not get checkmated in the next few moves
is to play the move b5
which is not an easy move to see of
course it makes a lot of sense you have
to undermine the support of the knight
on d5 and you have to do it fast right
okay but after g takes h4 i take take
and then knight takes c6 sure but http
comes on the board now i can also do it
and by the way g5 is on the board okay
after you took on c6 i can start by
taking on g3 and this has to be
calculated very precisely by uh dingley
ram in order to play this move a b5 and
if you don't play the move b5 you're
just simply lost take on g3 now i don't
even have to take on c6 by the way i can
just simply go queen to e5 focus my
attention on the pawn on g3 i know that
if i manage to get the queen on g3
follow it up with rook to f2 or bishop
to h3 the game is over right so you can
take on b7 you can get close to
promotion you can take a knight on d5
i'm checkmated i'm the one getting
faster to your king and this is exactly
where i do believe
lines if
dingley ran finds the move b5 we're
going to get to this position and at
this point it will be nepal who will
start thinking he will see b take c6 as
an option he will see hg3 as an option
and at this point who knows how many
minutes dingli wren will still have on
the clock if he finds b5 and this is the
practical pressure that you were
mentioning alejandro that nepal is such
an expert at instilling
onto his opponents rook to f6 played
fastly
40 minutes for an apple 20 minutes and
counting 21 minutes and counting for
dingley i think he's in trouble i i
agree wholeheartedly that ding is in
trouble but there was another thing that
flashed in my mind there christian i'll
put it on my board
after the move g5 b5 yes i want to take
uh take
now obviously in this position you're
attacking my knight and if my knight
weren't hanging a move i'd really like
to play is the move h3
because uh getting to play h2 and uh
crashing through on the f2 square so
let's imagine i play a move like rook f5
for just a moment
uh it's your turn
and
am i crashing through or not here
it looks
looks awfully so i think on b7 let's say
take on b7 right
only that i'm taking a pawn but at least
i'm getting close to promotion
definitely that's a big weapon so
h3 bishop e4 is that yes probably well i
can also go at bishop h1 i don't really
bishop h1 i run i run for my life
i am running baby get on your sneakers
and let's get out of town
ah
bishop on h1 blocks yes and the king
only one unless you have room for xf2
wait wait wait wait yeah bishop f3
bishop f3 how are those sneakers working
out for you i don't get it i take on f3
queen takes f3 bishop takes f3 oh you
have rook h4 at the end
[Laughter]
[Music]
nice nice okay so there's dangers there
and unfortunately
uh b5
box i mean it's just because it really
is box because it creates threads
white needs to create counter play if
you take on b7 you might be wondering
why not just take on b7 it is a pawn uh
it's just a pawn and that's the issue
that's the problem
you take one pawn on the queen side i
take one pawn on the king side but it's
on the king side where the king resides
and uh checkmate as we understand still
wins the game uh this is this is
breaking through and that's why
undermining the knight with the move b5
uh earlier uh was basically forced yeah
and i think b5 will be found by doing
learning out of necessity yes uh there's
just no other move uh exactly which is
getting made it but how did you
inaugurate it after b5 context pawn
takes c6
understand you're destabilizing me for
so for such a small amount of time but
what if i like take on g3
take on g3 and go well this is the
thread
and then there was this queen g3 that uh
posting up right that one that was
pretty scary it was very scary how did
you defend
i'm not sure
uh i've been i'm worried that if i play
rook takes e4 queen takes g3 oh excuse
me that's a check hanging yeah you can
you can't move on d4 so if you take this
pawn
uh
i've always got perps but this is where
bishop
g3 bishop pardon me bishop h3 knight
takes e3
i mean rook f2 we're all winning the
game
all winning the game for black
wow uh which is why
what is the difference
because this is what we're recommending
right no uh excuse me this was the
moment where we were taking on g3 taking
on g3 queenie pride
i guess you could play queenie one
queenie one knight e3 not rookie four no
rook the rook is defended ah
okay uh did we blunder into it
we blundered what do you mean it was
part of the plan yeah yeah yeah
uh rook ef4
is
the issue
boy this just feels so bad for for for
white but
you got to win it right you got to stay
in it
this is still bad after like b takes c6
rook takes actually is it so let's
continue queen uh knight to c3 right now
what
what
i'm just trying
and at the same time
where you're hitting the knight on a5 i
think it forces you to take right not
only i take c2 is a big problem yeah i
don't i don't see eddie
i have to go
back to e1 loses queen e3 check on you
pick up my rook right rook f2 is a
thread queen enthusiast bishop h3 is a
bigger threat how big can i connect
those queens to f2 can i go rook takes
no rook takes e4 bishop h3
uh that's the problem that's checkmate
let's just check me you just don't
defend i'm not able to defend
so rook takes e4 everything is hanging
but you're just pointing out that after
bishop h3 rook takes actually you do
have a defense g7 queen takes up six huh
queen takes f6 followed by rook for one
and rook
f2
in a minute and what about king h7
queen
d3 rook h8 yeah okay this is about
rookie shake king g7 right stakes rook
f1 kg7
[Laughter]
[Music]
h so that in this variation i still have
my
motion so i'm not 100 sure how that
position is so we were we were laughing
that we got to this position but somehow
because we
take on b7 i think this is and then uh
christian said well wait a minute don't
forget there is a passer yeah i think i
think i think i think black has to bail
this pretty quickly
i don't know how we got here
in that whole
uh by the way
[Music]
because of the very very forcing nature
of this line and the fact that these
guys are
much of what we just saw what it was
going through it's going through our
minds because exactly at this moment and
perhaps you don't see knight c3 from
afar but you you realize that this is
all about tactics anymore strategies
it's gone out the window exactly you
weaken the kings and you weaken the
queen said it does not matter uh
material doesn't matter either can i get
to the king fully or can i not get to
the king fully 15 minutes for dingley
ran with 15 moves to go and a completely
wild position totally so much to play
for in this position and knight c3 is
just one of those
right but he has to make a decision
because 15 minutes is not a lot of time
and he still will need that time later
does it make sense for me to first throw
in the move
no no because knight takes c6 actually
hops
it covers e5 right threatens rook takes
d5 at some point in the rook on e8 moves
um yeah yeah i i think it's just too
much
so
i he's taking a b7 we just spent like 10
minutes
he's done the move we said you can't do
knight takes b7 well gh is automatic
there is now
that defense that ding had prepared with
rook h1 doesn't exist
uh
he has to take on e4 i mean what what
ph rook g6 even like oh no this is just
terrible yeah no you're just losing too
much tempe
uh opening up the g file as well so
i'm with you okay we take on e4
you take on e4
or you take well we have very quick
moves yeah g takes h4 knight c5 blade
g takes h4 knight wait but does
christian's line work now
what was christian h3
that was my line
well yeah but it was bishop f3 uh like
h3 yes no because the rook is still on
the correct spot what am i saying okay
bishop h1 yes h2 okay king f1 okay
that's the only move right right so here
i was trying to make bishop f3 work but
you don't have to go queen f5 finish the
game
that's not that hard that is not hard at
all
93 is on tap if you try to queen queen
one yeah 93 that's actually a very
very nice looking smothered mate you
don't see that i don't think i'm going
to do that i'm going to go beach page 3
after cleaning one green 193 you're not
going to go queen knight e3 checkmate no
man
i'm going to have to look for better
bishop and bishop h3 is just simply
better better because i'm getting the
second queen yeah
why not
i get that queen uh knight c5 guys is
there
other ways of winning i wouldn't be
surprised this looks like black is
coming with too much well let's go down
the line because h3 in that case i am
absolutely forced to take on e4 okay i
don't know with what yet
well let's just throw something out okay
so h2
h2 one and prey
h1 almost forced right yeah i don't see
how king g2 so let's take on f1
why not
i am taking on e2 followed by bishop f3
and that's just the checkmate
so how do you define the game
i'm just getting blasted what am i
looking at i mean this is terrible yeah
not only that but also rook takes c4 is
coming okay
the vultures are out right right
everybody just suddenly got all excited
um
this looks terrible uh so it's actually
this is is that on the board not yet no
knight to c5 he's still thinking he has
plenty of time to think and find the
right way to blast through by the way h3
is completely winning but h takes g3
also exactly
you have to take you have to take right
follow it up with queen to uh e5 if you
want to be more precise just defend the
pawn on e4 with bishop to f5 not only
that open up the g file to g6 is coming
queen to g5 is coming i feel like white
should be up a piece it's it's bright
right it's bad yeah yeah yeah
you put a pawn on b7 a white pawn on bc
i've got some compensation for the fact
that i'm going down on the king side but
this is just
uh yeah you're just hitting me with too
much i've got one defender
that's that you've got that is the
problem
two massive
overkill queen bishop and rook and i'm
defending with the
e3 i love the move bishop f5 by the way
i would be surprised if there was a i
mean even
uh just setting up everything
and that's saying yes not playing h3
which which we think
might just be yeah yeah this is very
very forcing after knights oh pardon me
after knight c5 excuse me
this is our current position we think
this might be winning but our first
instinct
was to uh
kick the king away essentially from the
f to pawn
and we were we were trying to do that by
doing something of this nature what was
it no how did we get our
our queen to
uh queen five just between five
yeah
it's just it's just over wow
if dingley ran loses with this game with
the white pieces the first classical
game against uh elite level competition
in a year and a half this is going to be
a tremendous blow and i have to say i
don't know if you will be able to
recover from that now we don't have a
huge sample size but the last tournament
he played the candidates the last
classical tournament a year and a half
ago two years ago depending on which
part
you want to talk about the first part he
lost two games in the first one and
after that he was just simply devastated
he couldn't come back sure in the second
part with nothing to lose he won a game
but unfortunately it wasn't enough now
this is what i'm seeing from dingley
wren right now he's not a player
that deals well with losses and once
again we don't have a huge sample size
in the last couple of years and that is
uh partially the fault of the pandemic
but this is what i'm seeing right now
from him he doesn't deal well with
losses a loss in the first game
with so much at stake i don't think he
will be able to stop like that
i'm seeing dean loren
in a very perilous situation right now
yeah i think i think this game is over i
feel a weakness in the in in the force
as we uh prepare for a rematch
and we have some tweets uh
alejandro let's take a look
we have a question from youtube question
to yasser over california
what happened until work circa i hope in
1975. uh gm now radisky shout out to the
newest in new york times columnist yes
we're proud of you daniel
very good i'm very proud of him this is
amazing for trust uh he's such a great
ambassador for chess shout out to daniel
naraditsky i mentioned you had a story
from back then uh yasser is this fake
news yeah i think so tilburg california
i don't
know california well first of all
tillberg of course tilburg holland
uh was the site of many many great
events the interpolis
insurance companies sponsored each and
every year one of the world's premier
events that everybody looked forward to
we called it tilburg
but 1975 i don't know
no no it might be circa like it might be
close to 1975 like around that age
what did i do what happened no no guys
guys this is just a trick question dania
is a great impersonator he has great
impressions of gary he does a great
impressions of yourself as uh well and
whenever he starts a story in your voice
when i was in tilde earlier
that's the question i see i see so no uh
no great fake news fake news fake news
dania strikes again with fake news and
now he's writing for new york times and
that's all it takes man you do
impersonations and you're good to go all
right nice uh h3 played on the board
here between dingleroon and janna
fournier this might be
the first decisive result of the
candidates
wow
it just looks devastating
i just don't see it i just don't see it
well once again if we move the bishop
has to move if we move it to h1
shack we can't go to g2 that's the
easiest mate we've ever found and if we
go to f1 queen f5 is devastation we're
threatening mate we're simply crashing
through which leaves us only with the
move bishop takes e4
then after bishop takes e4 we've played
h
to check again
king up only invites queen so we've been
moving king over and we've been looking
at rook f2 and then we're pulling our
hair out
looking for a defense to rook takes e4
bishop and bishop f3 and finding no
defense
we gave it a rest yeah we give it up but
we just think it's winning and we do
that's exactly it
but uh
well there's no time at all here boy
you got some haters in the truck i mean
look at that dude i mean
the guy hasn't even resigned
it's over for you alejandro it's over
for you
you see all all it takes is for you to
win one world championship and then
people you've got a mark on your back
what's going on you know your team
uh wins the world championship and they
got to bring you down you know it's okay
it's a nice ego check thanks guys
well
not starting great with the white pieces
of course it's a double round robin and
it's a long term but you waste of white
thing
it is such
a difficult thing to recover from
specifically dingleran
has had a history of bad results right
in some of these tournaments in the 2018
candidates he wasn't one of the
favorites but he kind of disappeared
from the tournament
you know he made a couple of draws i
think he finished on 50 okay nothing
really remarkable
on the second one he was actually coming
in as one of the favorites he had he
finally established himself as one of
the top three four players in the world
and he bombed yes there's no
he played tournament spoil to fabiano
caruana played the best one of the best
games i've ever seen i guess is
phenomenal phenomenal
bobby with incredible preparation makes
one inaccurate move straight out of 20
move prep right digloran under time
pressure recovers wins in an amazing
game but it's the only game that he wins
in the first half and just does not
recover enough in the second to even
come close uh to challenging for the
first places
does he start bad and just disappear
again yeah well
before i answer that question i just
have to echo your thoughts especially in
in a sense ding played an absolutely
marvelous game to destroy fabby's
chances in that candidates
and
players
for me nepo
along with hicaro two incredibly streaky
players but ding if he had if he starts
with two wins
uh uh
look out but the field is in trouble
because he could uh just run away with
it from nepo's point of view holy smokes
what a way
the best start he could possibly hope
for
farouja
is magnus's hope for opponent should we
jump in because this one looks looks
lost
let's not not forget bingo was one of
those guys that actually broke the
record of no losses
in more than 95 games which was i think
closer to 100 yeah
and then he broke that and that was in
2018 after that his results once he got
that loss and that's why i'm saying he
doesn't really like losing and he
doesn't recover well from a losses he
got so used to not losing during that
historical stretch that right now maybe
also since the fact that he's not
playing a lot of games maybe he's just
not used to losing
so there you have it there you have it
and then eight minutes on the clock no
increment remember here's a move 27
against 34 minutes 34 we don't really
expect this to last no no no no i mean
no and how did dingle iran start his
2020 candidates
losing with the white pieces against
wang hao completely shocking
to the chess world right one house
sacrificed an exchange and he rolled his
pawns on the king's side i just told i
mean boy
i was totally uh
forgot yeah it was a huge upset right
and it was a huge blow to dingler and
just didn't recover right what is he
doing in this candidate losing with the
white pieces against nepal miyachi not
the way you want to start he's played
the move rook takes e4 let's see how
this works out tactically for him
is it forced mate is the question right
exactly we're looking it takes
we take with a check of course it looks
like mate to me we've got a threat of
mate in one that you have to take on g2
it sure feels that way i stopped playing
f3 f4 but okay
go go ahead and show me uh the fourth
rook two as me
rook f2 is just made yeah king takes
queen h2 and whether you go to f1 or e1
eventually
you're going to be forced to go to e1
and there it is that's it we'll cut two
uh
too easy
uh rook takes e4 it's over it's over
right yeah
c8
you're threatening me you've got to take
with a check we move our king out of the
way
um
i guess i have three i don't know
but i mean i pick i just pick up your
rook i don't have to think about this
variation
yeah
funnily enough i i'm i'm pretty sure
there should be a force mate with rook
takes f3 yeah like something stronger
right right
like but yeah winning the winning the
rook of course is uh it's good enough it
looks interesting not only that you're
winning the rook you also threaten to
get another queen on the board that's
that comes with a big threat so you have
to take
on g2 after queen takes a1 and let's
finish that
line so you take on a1 you take on
g2 and is there a checkmate like bishop
to h3 maybe i think h3 is actually me
because you cannot take i mean you can
take on h3 but after queen h1 king g4
that probably is checkmate now you don't
have to calculate it just kind of no you
just assume yeah and this is me and
mates
yeah there's no way out yeah you're not
getting up no
that's it no that's it it's actually
forced mate yeah it's the force mate
yeah i don't
wow uh quickly let's play catch up on
some of the it did not take on g2 yet we
expect him to take on g2 nepo usually
guys take a look at what's happening the
game between fabiano and hikaru because
this one has stabilized and has
stabilized with quite a nice advantage
for white i have to say a strategical
nice advantage the king is very weak on
g8 now i managed to put my pieces on
there are probably ideal squares right
now this knight coming to g3 i have
options i can get the knight to g3
target this pawn on e4 and put a lot of
pressure like that or
i can use this knight as a blockading
piece on e3 and that's going to target
another weakness in your position
seeing right now from hikaru over
extension the king is weak you don't
have any prospects for a successful
attack against my king this one is just
looking like a very pleasant long-term
advantage for white and this is uh
specifically what fabiano was gunning
from from the beginning
no question about it uh christian i echo
your words wholeheartedly i
uh
in in terms of uh
at a knight that attacks the pawn on e4
or knight that blockades the pawn on e4
i just love the blockade don't ask me
why but you put this knight on e3
this king is tender the rook will come
to f1 the pawn on g4 we've always got
queen g6 and you know what this part is
what's that
something you know counterparts are just
lost yeah like even if you man your king
is very weak on g8 yeah you trade queen
you trade queens and you say oh what a
relief i got into the art game and then
you get to this and you realize yeah
it's like
there's no relief
three king g3 might be straight up
mathematically lost you might just lose
the g4 pawn and lose the end game
exactly so i'm not saying it is
but i'll say all right
it feels like a win to me it really does
and it just seems so easy and the knight
on e3 blockading everything and hitting
that pawn on g4 and what is your bishop
doing the rest of the game yep it's
controlled by the 82 and v3 pawns it's a
target for the pieces because it doesn't
have a good anchor square the only good
anchor square it has its own c6 where it
does literally nothing other than defend
the pawn on e4 absolutely right
for all of these reasons it really feels
like uh hikaru got wrong footed in this
uh and he put all of his pawns on light
squares
and he's suffering and may just be lost
uh
but guys we also have to go to this game
between uh timur and ali reza because it
is exploding and they are following the
line that we discussed
after knight f5 knight g6 came h4 came
on the board and by the way
rajabov is right now ahead on time
incredible after being a full hour
behind
with what looked at least as one simple
move queen to a bishop to a3 was indeed
a big decision allowing the knight to
come to g5 you had to calculate a lot of
things but quint wade probably had to be
played a bit faster alireza did not do
that and right now he's uh falling under
a tremendous attack because you have to
be extremely precise not to lose
instantaneously right now already bishop
takes d2
is a bad move after knight takes d2 you
are in deep danger you can go h6 but
unfortunately this is just not looking
great for uh for a black now
bishop takes g2 is one option bishop
takes e4 is another option and now you
have to contend with either rook takes
c4 bringing the rook uh into the attack
or knight takes e4 and what i'm seeing
on the engine right now is something
very concerning for ali reza the best
movie in the position right now is
knight h4
not knight to e7 but knight to h4 and
that is because you need to keep uh
contact with this pawn on g2 and not
allow this knight to easily uh
remaneuver from e4 because queen takes
g2 is going to come on the board knight
to e7 is a much worse version because
after h6 softening up your dark squares
around the king you're in big big
trouble this is what i'm seeing right
now bishop to d2 was played knight takes
d2 is an option queen takes d2 is also
an option how are you going to respond
to this
right now what i'm seeing from ali reza
is a shaky hand he has less time than
timur rajabov with still 15 moves to go
and a position that is simply exploding
right now knight f6 is on the board h6
softening up your dark squares is on the
board and by the way how do you defend
against that do you go knight to e7 i
think after h6 you might be just
completely losing now the queen on d2 is
even better placed because i'm ready uh
to target your dark squares
what are you going to do there was after
the simple quintex
is h6 right h6 would be h6 great move
but what if i just take things
take with what i mean with one
who asked this question
thank you king takes f7 is by far the
better move i mean okay i don't have an
engine right
[Laughter]
why because the king has to run you have
to run away to e8 your kingdom you've
got on your
speakers position right here white
playing the move f3 next closing up the
bishop you see this knight hovering
around your king you understand that
you're already worse you know i i really
wouldn't have thought that i really
would thought that after the move rook
f5 i'm not really doing so poorly but
then you then you see your queen and
bishop is excited what if i play this
one dimension this simple movement
i have three i understand but which is
not the best i don't know what if i play
i just don't get it guys i i understand
everything that you're saying but i
think i have a i have a bishop on d5 i
have work on f5 yes how are you mating
me i have a passport i'm going to push
it where is your i'm not somebody
explain this to me
with the move f3 no no i will mate you
with the move g4 but let's assume what
why the
what i have a bishop on d5 a queen on
eight i get and you play the move g i
get it from a practical perspective this
doesn't make any sense i i mean how's
bishop h1 not winning somebody
exclusively
take bishop to uh h1 f3 and actually
you're losing if you take i have this
nice check
check queen takes it
don't shoot the
messenger this is what i'm seeing right
now by the way
yeah
at the end i'm like queen g3
but i'm surprised i'm surprised i
wouldn't have it on the board let's see
how alireza deals with this because
right now 15 minutes and counting and he
needs to calculate all of these
variations so does timuraj above and he
only has 18 minutes a while position
anything can happen and uh the
assessment of the position can change at
every turn yeah it could change
dramatically this is also one of the
things that happens in these marathon
events
is you're going to get tested oh yeah uh
you're going to get positions where
you're better and you're going to cruise
and hopefully you smash the guy and you
win very easily but then you're going to
get these positions where you started
with an initiative it backfired suddenly
you're on the back foot as
this position goes and white's the one
attacking and doing the exclamation mark
moves and you've got to find some
nasty defensive
reactions
so it's a it's a challenge
the
[Laughter]
here we outrage i'm confused what
this is our good morning saint louis
like i can i can rip the lips i can read
the lips i i can't give up i mean what
i hate engines that's all i'm gonna
that's all i'm gonna say
uh what does magnus had this great line
uh do you play against engines and and
and and how do you do when you
what do you feel about playing against
them and he goes depressed
interesting uh by the way we
played f3 we tried
f3 it wasn't working
uh ding
tried f4 i don't see that i got news
it's not working it's not different yeah
it's not working i mean king takes you
two bits of h3 is the exact same thing
right well except the pawn was on f3 in
that other variation but we're looking
at bishop h3 once more and we're
expecting that somehow this king is not
long for this world yeah i mean this
looks like mate after it
it's just like you've got to walk the
plank yeah rook g6 is kind of good but
queen h3 i think might be faster i like
queen h3
it's over guys it's over
don't don't play with your uh parade
come on
it's over he's dead he's resigning his
bishop h3 check and he has to sign our
first result it's a decisive result
the challenger of the 2021 world chess
championship has defeated dingley red in
an amazing game dingley wren not found
today
yeah he's kind of missing in action
right and it was like this move knight
g4 that
well it confounded him
ovulated him he did not know how to
react he was given upon e4
he very meekly decided not to take this
pawn and it cost him because he was not
able to organize his position
and as we just go and again where it's
hindsight so we understand that but
somehow
when this pawn on e4 simply survived
yeah
black's idea all along had been to
cement his knight on d5 and then do
something on the king side and somehow
this whole maneuver with
bringing the knight to c4 versus
bringing the knight to d5 was very
favorable for the second player black's
knight on d5 is doing great the rook on
e6 and
all along i mean it was just king-ish
too also king h2
very strange you talk about getting on
your your your tracks this is you know
getting out of dodge might have been the
king h2 that would
a bad game to start for
it's a time it's a test for the chinese
player mentally yeah he failed it last
time failed it pretty miserably last
time he did not recover from his loss to
one
because wow what a way to start nobody
found just got rolled over no question
about it that was a a really one-a-sided
match let's just check in on a game that
kind of just like faded from view for a
moment but we'll get right back to it
dude versus
uh richie uh
first look holy smokes it looks like
duda is killing it he's got the two
bishops oh i agree i just wonder if he
was killing it more before
oh it was that bad i i i've just caught
up to it now i don't know what really
happened no i mean from the opening
right when yeah from the well more or
less i thought maybe just around these
parts that
richie might have writed
you know i'm not sure about the move a5
by the way but okay somehow around here
it doesn't look terrible
but it's soon
what we've got i'm not sure it's so bad
because takes takes it really i think
hinges on the next move because if i can
get my bishop to d4 right now
maybe this is not
so bad by the way i didn't realize that
uh bishop
i i was under the impression that white
was playing bishop f2 right right yeah
if you get bishop f2 the game's kind of
over because before there's just winning
very quickly exactly but bishop the
bishop e3
could
could be
defensible well
think about it uh christian you have
something for us
absolutely well another position that is
crumbling uh right now is hikaru's
position we were looking at this game
and we were mentioning knight to g3 also
the idea that you like a lot to uh
blockade this pawn on e4 with the knight
get the knight to e3 and think later not
only that but it also attacks an
undefended weakness the pawn on a g4 if
you manage to get that you're going to
get two connected passers that's going
to be all she wrote and this is exactly
the thought process of fabiano caruana
with the following moves queen to h6
queen to g7 queen to d6 this is
what hikaru right now is staring at
incredulously because he cannot believe
what happened to his position in the
last few moves it's just crumbling
there's no way to defend the pawn on g4
i'm going to go knight to e3 next move
followed by queen to f or whenever
whatever you do at some point you will
by the way have to defend knight to f5
jumps as well with devastating
consequences first uh
with the bishop are you going to go to
c6 sure simple move knight to e3 how are
you going to continue defending this
pawn on g4 you can go rook to f8 you can
try to sacrifice
3m by the way
after g3 i can even consider playing
moves such as h3 leave the pawn on g3
take it later and keep the connected
passers but of course taking on g3 also
makes a lot of sense not only that but
right now i can also focus on your weak
king i can get the rook to f1 all my
pieces are involved into the attack and
any sort of end game knight versus
bishop with a pass pawn on this side is
lost for you so you are staring at so
many losing scenarios right now with the
black pieces and only
12 minutes to go 12 minutes to go nine
more moves to make for hikaru and the
next few moves might see him in a
completely losing position right now the
computer is saying plus 1.5 from a
practical perspective i think and i feel
it's much worse than that
yeah
uh wow well yeah i mean we always felt
there that hikaru had overdone something
overdone something and he was getting
punished and while we want to go on
break
this this uh this game is also crackling
too the uh the thing is for you guys our
players are down to 13 minutes if we're
going to break in now we won't get it at
all
all right we're going to take a break
very quickly and we'll be back with
crucial results exactly we'll see on the
other side
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back we have already a result
in the candidates it's the first one and
a decisive one as jana pognachi is the
first victory of this tournament and
with the black pieces and against the
highest rated player of the tournament
dean liran from china a great start for
yan in his quest to seek a rematch
against magnus carlson no question about
it in the words of jackie gleason how
sweet it is winning with the black
pieces to open your campaign yeah and
i'm seeing across the boards
a lot of decisive
positions are these potential decisive
positions let's go straight into the
action as we go a little bit around the
horn to see what's going on we're in
time pressure in every single board okay
so we have to go a little bit quickly
we left it off right at these this
moment yes
it was queen d6 knight bishop c6 knight
e3 rook f1 and knight f5 in its lights
out that's all she wrote that will be a
winning king side attack
g3 and let's jump to christian well
alejandro i'll take you around the horn
on this one this is the position by the
way that was seen in the game between
rajabov and firuja
20 seconds later 20 seconds he took with
the king
on f7
this was the move that you thought would
never
come on the board
i just wanted to point that out nice
knight takes g5 king to e8 f3 king to d7
knight to e4 bishop takes e4 this is the
position we currently have on the board
i have to say that this one might
actually peter out into some sort of an
equality position maybe a draw let's see
what happens
in this one i'll give it back to you
guys well i mean continue uh christian
by all means please
rook takes e4 was that completely
convincing to you uh
uh that it was gonna peter out sure i'll
put the queen on d5 maybe maybe
i will start my my pawn march let's go
e5 let's let's go it's true you're gonna
go with the passer and
i've got to get it your king yeah this
cake is actually not so bad on d7 that's
why he took with a king on f7 well he
got on his running shoes and boy did he
zip right off the king's side
it does it does uh for some reason i was
thinking that rook g4 was going to bring
me more than rook f7 kind of it's
a dead end it kind of is right rook g4
rook f7 and yeah you have some nice
pieces especially the requiem g4 does a
nice job of defending g7 right sorry
defending d4 and attacking g7 yeah but
at the end of the day i have a passport
on the a file not on the king's side how
about this move though see if i can't
disrupt you maybe maybe i think that's
what christian started with a5
diddy yeah and that's fine you can go
queen d5 also it's it's not real
a5 d5 i think with the pawn
i have to take with it yes you have to
take with the pawn taking with the queen
i'd hurt your feelings with the move uh
rook d4 the problem is right now we're
starting uh to play uh for three results
right because black can easily win this
one oh
that was always the case i was just
trying to see if
uh white is the one
with any forcing so let's go king e8
maybe or king c8
even though king c8 e7 does feel like
you're getting very close
i'm one square away from the promised
land yeah it doesn't feel like a three
whole game
there are still chances
by the way queen d5 was played
okay queen d5 okay but in the in that
case i was just kind of warming up to
the
respond before you quick question what's
the time situation
uh time situation is seven minutes for
alireza actually only two minutes left
for uh rajabov and whoa
this could get dicey and again
exactly
to remind everybody no increment
and this is how people lost on time in
the good old days because
now with that 30-second increment you're
not seeing people losing on time unless
the position is just absolutely dead
lost
but
these old time controls where you've
suddenly got eight minutes eight moves
to make in two minutes can easily cause
you to flag now this move queen before
uh double hit right there's a threat to
the rook but there's also a threat of
check and picking up the passer that's
the pride and joy in black's position
you don't want to lose the a-pawn
no i don't want to lose the a-pump what
what if i move the rope let's say to h8
i don't know okay rook h8 let's give it
a go
uh and so give me a check and i have to
move queen c6 i think this move is kind
of important
because you've got your own sources of
camera i have my own source of
counterplay i don't know
if it's enough
i have the feeling it is
let's take a look for who
checks right yeah
this is looking very ugly for a while
yeah rook f1 even sorry h1 sorry about
the idea of f1
still not me
what at least you have a check of the
rook h1 i do have some checks to maybe
disturb
maybe this is not more than a draw
actually yeah well there's counter
there's counter play button and with no
time on the clocks this is a game uh
that's really really hard uh checking in
on the duda report
game uh we just left at the position
where you had mentioned bishop e3 put
your bishop on d
d4 samantha cement the bishop there and
you're doing fine
well white had other ideas check and
give me the button
and we're just catching up to the
players quickly
and now this looks like a two bishops
versus bishop at night position
favorable for white after king e2
the why is it terrible for white i've
got the two bishops
[Laughter]
i'm very nice to bishop yeah but okay uh
bishop can go to b4 the problem is my
bishop on a6 it just completely stuck
right i need my bishop actually to be on
d5 i mean if i just play bishop d4 when
i sit
uh go ahead take my take my pawn i don't
care i mean when i start putting my
pawns over there on the dark squares i
like that move h4 exactly just to
continue with the g5 so that when you
eventually do take
because otherwise my bishop really is
stuck yeah i take we're in the bishops
of opposite color
and that looks
very drawn very very very tape and
finally uh hikaru
yeah
i saw that move g3 is a bit of
desperation desperation we thought the
move rook f1
was so nice uh inviting takes on h2 king
g1 you're dreaming of knight f4 no
defenders no
upon defending black's king we thought
that this was really really strong
for uh fabi he decided to take they
can't blame a man for winning the pawn
uh h takes g queen e5 queen g6 check
and
we are now up to date with the players
we're out today with the players uh five
repeating position uh to get closer to
move 40 and how is the time two minutes
for fabiano two minutes and four seconds
for fabi and hikaru is down to under
four right now so how many moves to go
uh just a few well three for fabi four
for hikaru okay
uh still
you have to survive with black exactly
and then tell me how i'm going to do
that because it's not it's not
obvious to me how i'm supposed to
survive here uh i'm assuming that queen
takes g3 is just a no-no and that after
a move like rook f1 uh
the the king is simply too exposed uh
here
so you have to play queen g7
queen drops back to jesus because knight
g4 is also a threat right oh i think any
time you can get introduced the knight
is just going to be there but now i'm
going to
f4 let's introduce knight yeah and then
we're on rook f5 you have knight
knight f5 g4
that looks good enough or knight to
fight rook f1 followed by knight h6 no i
i i agree we're vulturing yes we're
definitely vulturing yeah let me in here
coach
i can take him i could take him so we're
seeing a decisive game in this one one
that is not going to be a decisive game
is the one between rajabov and firuja
because the players are speeding up
necessarily speeding up for uh timor
because he's down to his last minute uh
into this end game after um
queen two before rook two g8 was played
we set rook to aha that was one move
rook to d8
but uh all roads lead rome because after
queen to a4 you are going to get this
pawn but i can force this end game
rook to a8 we're going to take the
knight the king is going to c6 the white
is never going to lose this one black
most likely never will lose this one
either for example king to c6 rook to g4
and now i just
this is going to be made by king to d5
this one does seem to be
an easy end game for a black and i think
this one is just going to be equal and
finishing the draw and this is exactly
where we're going king to c6 is on the
board by the way still
three moves rook to g4 was played how
many seconds did he have one minute and
29 seconds one minute and 13 seconds
this is what we have right now rook to
g8 rook to g6 maybe i can even take
taking to d5
rook to e7 and then start pushing it
upon
whenever you go f4 i have a feeling that
i'm going to be able to corral this pawn
maybe look to f8 followed by g5 or just
see i'm too active yeah it does feel
like black is too active at this point
king to e4 followed by g5 is also
probably an easy way out yeah this seems
to be the easiest way out just simplify
the position do not allow with the king
on e4 uh the pawn to go to f5 and this
is just all she wrote is going to be a
draw by the way i mean there are draws
in their draw this is just an incredible
idea an exchange sacrifice uh by ali
reza and he
he forced some action there that i
thought he was taking
tremendous risks and that
then the position kind of turned against
him for just a moment
he hit the brakes and uh
wow
this is a very very good game i mean
this is what you want to see from a
candidate's game absolutely absolutely
so this game between ali raza and timor
may be a draw
but uh again there are draws and there
are different draws this was a great
draw this was a really really wonderful
fighting time
and now once again ooh
he did take the pawn i thought that that
was
that was uh i would say a taboo you
can't do that queen takes g3 rook f1
queen g7 queen h4
and that is a very very exposed black
king
white is setting up for uh moves like
rook f5 and rook g5 i am assuming
but then he made mufordi oh he's made
his main move 40 which is an extra hour
big
that's a lot of times
um what is the i was thinking
g4 knight to g4 right you're you've got
the
winning threat of knight f6 check i
guess you're going to play rook of fate
still right rook fedor
but rook f8 okay
um
i don't see a killing blow yet
if i take the rook and i go into a queen
and knight versus queen and bishop
if i go into the minor piece ending the
minor piece on game looks everything
looks bad i just want to kill you
directly i understood yeah how how can
we kill directly maybe we can or maybe
we cannot
you have options right h6 knight f5 for
example
well this was the ending that i was
actually uh contemplating this one right
here i take
take
and then i put my king i hope on f4
and just try to yeah
you might want to start with the move
knight f5 because here e3 i think just
draws ah
you are so right e3 is a beautiful
tactic that uh
on the spot on the spot you know like no
discussions
yeah
this is no i mean that there must be
something better right exactly wait a
minute wait a minute what are we doing
what are we doing we're catching
ourselves right yeah we're catching our
chips too soon let's just keep the girls
on the board
how about queen queen h3
if uh anticipating rook fa queen e6
check hoping that you'll get into
trouble all right i'll i'll keep chasing
queen h7 seems kind of forced okay
and of course when the queen was on h4
hicaro did play them with queen h7 so as
a kind of indication can i ladder my way
into the position later at where though
like where is it going right like i i
got here and
you got here
it doesn't seem like a lot of progress
uh it's true
i don't know okay queen on c5 but it's
i am on the other hand all i need all i
need is to introduce
right yeah and that will be curtains for
the black king maybe this is actually
very strong because
oh you don't have rook f8 no that's
crucial detail right exactly now you
could go queen e7
and somehow do that same harassing yeah
but in this one i have queen c4 and then
comes in or knight f5 i've got quincy
for queen e6 yeah you're still alive
like that
christian uh put us out of our misery
for us will you could you tell us how uh
fabi should be
cashing his check
well just a side note for uh the
connoisseurs of internet culture the
world champion did throw his uh hat in
the mix he said literally does not care
about king's safety after this move uh
d5 for uh uh for a hikaru uh poking
hikaru a little very nice uh little
tweet there by the world champion right
now we have queen to g3 queen to g7 it
does feel like queen to d6 has to be
played on at the board now there's a
dance going between these three queens
right you you get you give me one more
move by the way with uh black and i'm
going to go knight to f5 and the game is
over right knight to f5 or rook to f4
and try to invade via the g5 right so
you have to always keep attacking my
queen right queen to e7 how do i get
away from it queen to g6 queen to g7 how
do i get away from from it i'm trying to
understand queen to h7 queen two
this guy is going around circles as well
yeah no it's it's not that easy to get
away from uh
leading us to the promises
i think right yes yes
yeah we we actually ended up the best
move right now is queen d6 back so this
is what i'm trying to understand and
this is about queen queen of forces
queen of four because rook fan had a
five ah this is it there we go the dream
yeah that's a dream so you
and if you defend the fi square with
bishop to d7 i have a feeling probably
just knight to d5
so this is what we're seeing and
obviously you have to draw back to e3
you don't want that
um you have to prepare the move knight
to d5 with rook to d1 an interesting
dance of all the pieces actually not
only the queens i'm attacking this
knight to f5 then you defend it then i
go to the d5 square now you have two
threats to defend against knight to d5
as well as if you try to defend that
rook to d6 so for example if you go
bishop to c6 rook to d6 now my rook
invades you have uh two attackers to
deal with not only the queen you're in
trouble so we know that as soon as white
gets another attacker involved into the
game the game is over so this is what
hikaru is trying to limit right now the
inclusion of another attacker
very very nice and that's what that
dance was all about right is giving
white the opportunity to gain a tempo so
that he can play rook to a rover rook up
the board and over to the king side uh
just picking up on the game of um
teamwork for just a moment we do have a
two versus one
rook and pawn endings as they say all
rook and pawn end games are a draw this
one is a little bit tricky to my eyes in
the sense that okay the rook is kind of
cutting the king away from
f6 and we do have a pass pawn
i must say that for myself i've never
had this two versus one i've had like
everything you know like really like
every kind of uh rook ending i don't
recall
this at all and
although you know you you would like to
just say draw and you know let's go on
to the next game i think there's still
some work
that uh ali riza is going to have to do
it still feels like suffering in this
position yeah
white has a pretty clear plan right just
bring up your king
slowly slowly slowly advance your pawn
and uh wrong foot the black king so that
if you could ever get your king to f2
your pawn to g4 your king to g3 and you
get in the move g5 i think it's gone
it's gone at that point i think you're
winning right
exactly so that's what's on a team wars
side of the table once again we were
kind of giving richie a little
uh
easy draw is
we were thinking that black is going to
put his pawn on d4 he's going to put his
bishop on d4 he's going to sit with his
king back and forth between c6 and d7
and he's going to say to white
do your best
what are you going to do you can put
your pawn on a5 but you can't move your
bishop the knight dominates
um
we said draw i don't see
and actually we don't have the game on
the main screen right now we have ali
reza versus uh timor uh the guys that
the game that you guys are analyzing
yeah we're looking like
duda yeah this looks communications that
draws me so yeah we're as black we're
putting our bishop on d4
we're putting our pardon on g5 we're
putting our king back and forth between
the two squares d7 c6 and we're saying
to white
the best that you can ever do is
capture the knight and capture the pawn
and we think that bishops of opposite
color where this bishop is patrolling
the a7 square is a draw
it's a very easy draw well set yeah yeah
it's actually a very easy so you just
put the king on a7 you put the pawn on
g5
you attack the pawn on h2 with bishop to
g1 yep and then you can even forget
about the phone on f6 because whenever
you take on f6 i keep the bishop on f4
and i just move my key exactly and and
that's it you don't even get my phone
yeah i'm not giving you my phone
and uh remember that after move 40 they
are allowed
to offer draws yes okay
and that's fair i always felt that the
first time control you know you you got
to give a performance fair enough and
the first and i i kind of dislike it in
the no draw games where it's so
obviously obviously drawn and the
players are looking for a threefold
repetition and sometimes they can't find
it uh that they allow the draw offers
speaking of a repetition we do have
another move that uh which game uh in
the fabiano game he didn't go queen d6
which i think was
the one we really liked yeah he wanted
queen h4 back and carl could go queen h7
okay so he does assume
he hasn't played it yet right but i
assume that
you don't play queen g3 you actually
want to play for more right and and it's
been that dance it's been that down here
that we've been trying to avoid how do
how do we play for more just queen f2
queen f2 the problem that i have with
queen f2 is i so desperately wanted to
play any rookman but we also have queen
to f4 right and we were getting queen to
f4 with the queen on g7 which i think is
a little bit better for uh black
but with the queen on h7 queen f4 isn't
that much easier okay so now at night at
five right ah yeah thank you that clears
the problem
[Laughter]
actually
wow
uh yeah well so quinnish i'm queen of
four is kind of lights out now that's it
yeah queen h7 queen of four which i'm
not 100 sure why fabiano hasn't played
it before i guess he was just trying to
he didn't have time right i think he was
just trying to make time control he was
down to seconds that is true actually
yes one minute and 39 seconds as we
entered move 39 and then he made
yeah with one uh one minute and 20
seconds
yeah quinoa h4 right now hikaru has all
the time in the world by the way both of
these players were down to their last
minute
right now 58 minutes for hikaru he's
going to spend
a long time trying to figure out this
position and try to figure out uh what
the best defense uh is what is his
position bishop to d7 by the way is
another move that has to be taken into
consideration well then you got knight
to d5 but 95 queen d4 right oh sorry
sir sorry that that actually i was
looking with the queen on h7 oh what if
i go wrong
yes this makes the most sense because
we're going to find 95 right here
or look to f8 let's make
let's make the normal move natural move
knight to d5 problem and i'm wondering
if you can take on f6 at all because
queen takes have sex might just win
knight takes up six minutes no let's say
i go bishop c6 it's not the best move
but let's say i go bishop c6 you can
survive this well i can pick up your
queen but i don't know if that you can
yes so this is the idea that you are
should be is this a whip yeah well if
the bishop was better
i would doubt it but the bishop cannot
easily participate in the defense you're
just going to push the jeep
i actually had a very similar end game
once uh and all i had to do was push my
phone uh the rook the bishop and the
king actually cannot hold yeah because
it does and you never control the dark
squares that makes a lot of sense
exactly yeah so okay let's say you're
not going to give up the queen right
there's one way to defend against that
so for example after knight d5 instead
of bishop c6 i can go to f7
geez
and if i
yes that's crazy yes yes yes so right
now you can take a pawn right right and
by the way i have to go to g6 i cannot
go to g8 because of 99
so i have to go to g6 and now you can
just simply take a point that has to be
with this has to be winning right yeah
everything else everything but we're far
away from that and bishop d7 by the way
is not the easy move and another natural
move given how the game has been played
up until this point this dance of queens
queen to h7 queen to g7 we've seen this
position before so right now hikaru with
queen to h7 would repeat the position he
might get the conclusion uh after
thinking for a while that after queen to
f4 he's busted a question i have uh
even another question yeah after the
move bishop d7 if you could help me out
yes if i just go directly with the
anti-positional knight f5 exchanging my
beautiful knight
bishop one of the best moves one of the
best but i take take and i threaten rook
g5 oh
really i still have a defense right
regardless the game goes on and you
still have a great advantage but do you
want to assess this position
i mean this looks pretty good this looks
very good this is why you're completely
winning right i pick up at least a pawn
and i still have a safe safe king versus
black's
body dodgy does it look more winning
than the one with the knight on e3 and
the bishop on c6 or d7 with the night
potential to jump to f6 understood yeah
this is the question that i think
fabiano will have to uh ask himself and
also decide at some point because knight
f5 is a big decision if bishop d7 comes
on the board we don't know whether
that's right there i think they both
just
knight five bishop d7 on the board by
the way it is on the board yes
right um
just to clear the cobwebs on another
game uh the um
the timor's rook and pawn ending it's in
the table base and i suspect
table base
because you want to play e5 and king e6
as asap right i think this is what he's
running yeah yeah king to d6 was played
now the
f4 right right so if you go e5 i go f5
this was precisely my question this is
still a draw yeah it's still a little
yeah yeah you know still a draw yes
because the key gets in
and i'm going to be able to find my own
counterplay you can go g4 g5 right push
yeah let's go and
it's sort of like this
is oh i just follow oops sorry
yeah they follow
i follow and at some point i'm gonna try
to win with it yeah
right because once you get to e1 then
like right
yes and then suddenly the game is uh
three results i'm not going to go keen
to e3 though
actually king e3 is losing e3 is the
only move that uh draws in this game
right
cool okay well uh
yeah that was my question was f4 and
meeting e5 with f5 so i have two
connected past pawns was that a try well
there are the candidates you expect them
to be very well prepared and remember
it's not just open operation they also
review all of the rook and games they
review their bishop end games and i
think this two versus one is one of
those typical positions that you get in
a uh training session yeah and you just
toss it to your player defend
i i know that we did with that with fabi
uh going into the world championship
match was like here have this awful rook
end game good luck right i remember that
one of the things that i like to
practice
too with was some kind of very basics
like for example i never got into my
career ever king and two bishops versus
king and knight
i don't i don't think i've ever seen it
yeah there was this wonderful game that
ian timmon played
i think with jonathan spielman in it
tillberg
sorry
and uh
the it was almost a problem like end
game and like jan got like seven moves
in a row perfectly right wow
went on to win the game at the time
there was almost a
thought that it was a draw it was only
engine solved it that they thought that
the king and knight would hold
the king of knight technically doesn't
hold but it's very long right right
right
if you get the correct setup position i
don't know why you would ever
get there somehow i know from like being
a young kid studying end games that the
best defense for black is to put the
knights on the equivalent of g7 g7 g2 b2
bc
square fiance squares are the best way
to defend
against the bishops i don't know why i
know this remarkable uh
but you're absolutely right that is the
way
and i used to look at that as a way of
kind of training for calculation right
right i mean
there were some practical
aspects to doing this type of thing but
it was just uh also you you just need
technically to exercise your muscles
that makes sense yeah exactly um all
right uh the move bishop d7 and did we
consider the the
the best way
where's the knockout what was there a
knockout what are we trying to say we
found a knockout we found very nice
things like for example you can pick up
the e4 pawn with a lot of the lines of
rook f6 yeah uh which kind of forces
black to exchange these rooks in some
kind of awful way honestly because
you're giving up a e4 with chuck but at
least you're surviving and the other way
is knight f5 which looked super scary
for uh the black side and also i think
wins the e4 pawn technically also that
kind of thing that we were just seeing
where
because black's king is so uh exposed
yeah and rook g5 is such a winning
threat that rookie five has to be forced
exactly and it's almost a miracle that
it really really you're not picking up
anything
it is amazing uh
which kind of makes me think that i
would
like i'd like to play with maybe maybe
right you know just to again uh
just set up with
the rook nicely there and also as an
attacker
i see rook have six i think rook
favorite e6 are forced one of the two
right i don't really care which one you
play exactly because i'll play knight d5
yes
and if you're telling me that the move
rook cafe 95 the only defense for black
in that position is rook f7
wow i mean
that's hard yeah sometimes you just tip
your head
okay he didn't see that
i'm not even sure how it works
wow rook at seven uh
that's where the the boss chair and you
said just a second could you scan my
opponent you know like is he connected
to a microchip what's going on yeah but
hicaro is one of those players that's
incredible at defense when it comes to
tactically defending his position
remarkably remarkable yeah really gifted
so easy to collapse in this position
no i mean indeed and and
that's one of the things that makes all
of these players in this field so
remarkable is their ability their
tenacity
defending what are really bad positions
everybody knows how to check me
but
holding a position where you're
seriously worse and probably even lost
practically lost and these guys do it
almost
i've seen the guys like just
hold hold positions that immortals would
just say okay i'll resign
so this is one of those and uh hikaru
certainly earned his bones by holding
bad positions and let's jump over to
christian and ask him what he asked for
his uh christian well i was uh taking uh
the pulse of the twitter sphere and
another great player is throwing his hat
in the mix that is anish giri who is uh
missing from the candidates he says
completely irresponsible play in madrid
great and a popcorn emoji quite a
quite interesting uh take from that one
irresponsible would you call the play
that we've seen so far from a ding i
would assume this is what he's thinking
about also potentially from hikaru that
moved e5 just over uh extending as he
did and unfortunately got himself in
trouble would you call that
irresponsible i'm going to leave that
with you in just a second but let's see
what's happening in this game between
duda and rapport well it doesn't seem
like a lot has happened since we've left
it bishop to b4 followed by bishop to d6
is always an option for white if uh he
wants to simplify the position and go
home make a draw but he's still trying
dude is still trying duda must be
disappointed by uh the fact that he
knows probably that he lost a big
advantage rook to d1 and it goes all the
way back
to that moment rook fd1 queen takes d1
rook ft1 rook takes d1 and immediately
responded with bishop takes d1
if he would have stopped at this moment
and try to look for ways to punish
bishop takes a2 because whenever you see
a bishop come uh within your grounds on
a2 you know that there are some options
in which you could potentially punish
that piece especially when the king is
uh not castled especially when you're so
far from involving your pieces into the
defense and rook takes the one even
after way too by the way knight to b5 is
one move right but knight
white a tremendous advantage the point
being your king is not as easily getting
uh to a safe space you have to go f6
followed by king to f7 and even that is
not going to be safe enough because
knight d6 comes on the board he should
have stopped this was a big big moment
for him he took with the bishop on d1
and this allowed the king to escape once
the king escapes i'm getting my own play
the route comes
on ba the rook starts attacking some
sort of weaknesses on the queen side i'm
getting something to play for after rook
takes d1 allowing bishop to a2 black
would have absolutely nothing to play
for and i think he would have a white
that is cruised towards an easy victory
unfortunately for him took on the one
with the bishop and right now it does
seem like richie rapport might be saving
uh this one quite an important save for
him as you guys mentioned and i'm
starting to get a bit worried about
fabiano the computer is still saying
that the position is completely
devastating for uh black knight to f5 is
indeed the right move probably the most
precise move in the position but i have
to say i'm looking at the game and it's
a difficult move to make it's a
difficult decision uh to follow through
with knight to f5 allowing this trade e5
and after that you have to start
calculating i'm a bit worried for
fabiano caruana who is my pick um and
objectively the position is starting to
become a little bit difficult to win now
at the same time it's much more
difficult for black to actually defend
this one than for white to win it so i
still give fabiano a clear edge in this
one and of course rajabov versus ali
reza we still have the same position on
the board e5 was not played f4 was not
played this is going to be a long one
well thank you for that uh
i'm still
on that game
of hikaru and i must say that if i was
in
favi
shoes
i would resist playing the move knight
e3 to f5 i would want to do it without
the possibility of black giving up his
light squared bishop for the night and
so
i mean the computer
sits there and says yes
absolutely knight f5 is the best move
and that is the way to go
and as the human player i'm resisting
making that move yeah the reason that
you resist it is because you feel there
should be something cleaner yes the
knight is so much more powerful than the
bishop and within the size so exposed
there must be an easier way of doing the
same thing so i'm dreaming that with my
queen my knight and my rook that i will
overwhelm the defenses
and
the light squared bishop
will be patrolling a diagonal that just
absolutely means nothing
and
otherwise
i will get my my knight
and
land on the f6 it's almost shocking that
the knight d5 black doesn't need to
resign exactly and for me
to play the move knight f5 that the
computer is pounding the table and i
think that that's
a criticism that i would have about
against chest pants
that the chest fan sees the chess
engines and the chess engines are
screaming play knight f5 play knight f5
but as the human player i'm resisting i
don't want to
give you a chance to trade the light
squared bishop and yet
that might be the best move knight f5
remarkable
uh how are we doing in the ferrugia game
do we have any updates uh we left it no
that this was uh where we were trying to
play f4 and e5 and create two connected
past pawns versus one that turned out
not so well for white and after king f2
i think we're up to date with the
players i'm expecting either a rook
check or
e5
so that you can play king e6 again
if you could just allow me the
i almost feel like it's just two moves i
just need g4 king g3 and it's almost
there and it's gone and i mean by
so like i'll make a bad move uh forgive
me uh
but i'll make an i'll make two bad moves
in a row for black and this is where
white sails home to an easy victory
he gets to play g5 king g4 and literally
walk his pawn right up the board and
this is what you have to avoid as black
and i think one of the things that you
also need to do is get your king
essentially to the f6 square which is
why
we are starting with a move like e5 and
in case of g4 we get to move our king
over and keep an eye on this past pawn
e5 on the board
as expected and again this is in the
table base and for me um when table
bases became a thing yeah
it was like really a revelation it
really was because just from those
endings of king and two bishops versus
knight right now you knew the absolute
truth yeah it was sort of like there was
no speculation anymore right and it just
solved such mysteries like
when queen and two pawns versus queen
became a thing like how is that even
possible
right like you make a draw right like
like you're you're you're two pawns down
and they're connected pawns too queen
and against queen and two points yes yes
yes how did that become
i mean like what that just that just
threw as
like
what i i felt like i didn't understand
anything about chess anymore yeah i
think the table bases are just
i mean they're truth but not something
we can ever figure out right yeah wow
okay
and this is one of the few ways guys in
which you can lose this end game and i'm
trying to just try to understand how you
can lose this end game with black for
example after rook to f6
king to d5 loses so the natural
d5 stay close to the pawn loses after
the move g4 it makes sense right um so
you have to stay behind and allow
yourself to be cut from the defense of
the pawn on e5 nevertheless it does seem
that after rook to b6 i'm going to be
able to cut your own king from coming
towards my pawn and attacking it with
rook to a3 and this seems to be just
enough for a black to maintain equality
now
let's try to understand king to d5 g4
why is it losing
if you go e4 most likely i will be able
to just simply take now that you're cut
on the f file i'm going to be able to
get the king to g3 push the pawn and
that seems to be enough actually take
take king g3 is a draw right i'm
thinking maybe g8 is that it king g3 a
rocket shade
no the g5
right yeah so for example if you go rook
f7 king to e5 this is a draw yeah right
right now because whenever you give a
check i go to e6 right that's a draw
right so this is um a a draw but with
the king cut on the other on the side of
the board yeah then you're losing so
rook to f5 critical move instead of rook
to f7 then i'm going to be able to just
simply go king to h4 follow it up with
g5 not only that but you kind of have to
wait right now how are you going to wait
on the g5 you can go king to g7 but then
i can just simply go king rook to a5
then push the pawn and this is the plan
right i'm going to get the rook to a5
your king cannot come back g5 king g4
rook a6 g6 king g5 and so on very very
easy win so
this is one way
in which alireza could lose if he
doesn't know that he needs to keep the
king on the seventh rack let's see if
rook f6 is going to come on the board
let's see if white is going to give the
option for black to go wrong with king
to d5 yeah there was just one other
important tactical point that you to
mention was that after for example rook
f6 check
king to d5
g4
e4 i've got rook f5 check it's not even
so easy
for black to trade there goes
d4 rook f4 exactly king d4 rook f4 and
you don't get to trade off uh the e pawn
for the f pawn but i'm sure rook f6 king
e7 will come in in a second because king
d5
really has that air light wait a minute
i'm leaving the g pawn it doesn't feel
like it's going the wrong way exactly it
really does now having said that uh rook
f6 is
is that really
the most testing uh alejandro like if i
go g4 i think it's the same right i go
king
e6 and i put my i kind of park myself
on
around e6 f6
okay so you you you park yourself and
essentially i park myself right i'm
trying to
on a good day i don't know
my way all the way to g7 that's very
true that sounds very nice um
one way to do this but if i just wait
for v8 or whatever or okay three no i
just don't want you to go king g3 i want
to make king g3 with
e4 aha so king g3 e4 yes is uh
nice and i think after rook f4 take on
f3 rook f3 this is exactly what we
discussed
and i do believe that after rook to a8
this might be it yeah yeah but just
first of all
yeah
basically that was the uh
the simplest agreed that is the so rook
a3
that make
yeah that said yeah gosh darn it because
that means i just don't even get to get
you don't even do anything you don't
have a plan at all actually no
no now i have to go like king e3 and
somehow
oops excuse me the rook all the way down
to d3 oh gosh what did i do
i don't even know
what i opened up their apologies and
yeah and now it's not working
not working at all
you can definitely try right so yeah
yeah oppressed by the way we were
talking about that also yesterday
the the idea that this event
this event especially it rewards playing
to the very very last very end yeah i
mean and
if you get a position where you're upon
up you should
play it as long as you can because who
knows maybe it'll be the best position
you get for the rest of the tournament
so you might as well enjoy
uh playing uh from uh the sunny side and
here it is
500 000
uh euros in total prize money and
additionally 7 000 euros
per point for every player and the
ultimate prize is a date
with magnus carlson i believe it's going
to be a two million euro
match in the future this one
maybe in 2023 maybe magnus will say well
i don't care who i play in that case
a lot of money but
he has said that playing these world
championship matches
incredibly stressful
not a lot of fun for the world champion
and he's looking to
just play as the world's number one and
just let
the official world championship i can
kind of understand that i mean chess has
become very demanding and the last few
years especially opening preparation
analyzing your opponent
it really is and
my one experience was working one world
championship with bobby and we spent the
whole preparation together christian
myself bruce and cassandra and fabi were
together for like four or five months
right
i remember the camps you guys were going
to yeah
where's everybody oh they were in spain
yeah we spent actually more than a month
right in spain and that was just for one
right right you spend like four or five
months just for one world champion
how many the fifth time
like that yeah and that's a lot of time
that you're spending just for matches
and they're grueling days it's it's days
that you don't see your family you
barely have time to talk to anyone
that's not like you're going out every
day exactly it's just dinner chest
dinner right and that's it and even for
those dinners sometimes you're
in such a state that you don't even want
the decision what would you like to eat
no no no no you just
put something in front of me it doesn't
matter what it is i'll eat it right and
every yeah i remember uh our break times
where uh you know movie night that
started at 11
and
and bobby with his laptop right he'd be
watching the movie with his laptop still
on right
it's really crazy when you think about
it i don't i don't blame him at all and
something along what you were just
saying and describing for magnus uh just
napo he just went through the experience
one time yeah and he was like rocked at
the end of the thing and he was saying
like my god
was that necessary
anybody for fisher random
so i don't have to like literally give
up my life
you know i i didn't have a life for the
world championship said nepal something
along those lines
it really did feel like that that it was
very rewarding experience but if you ask
me to do this every year i'd be like
i'm not really sure about that exactly a
long time second
the grand master from denmark peter hein
yeah has been working with
both officials bishop and ben magnus and
he has more world championship match
experience than anybody and i think he's
probably at this point you know like
burning his bridges i don't know how he
does it right i mean i understand that
he has taken on many roles that he's
just not just an analyst now that he
also just manages a lot of the things
right and lets other people do the work
but
it is so grueling it is absolutely so
grueling and it's just putting in time
and more time and more time more time
i remember
i had two world championship match
experiences as a second with victor
corchenoy for murano in 1981 and for jan
timon in his match in 1993
against karpov and i remember just
putting in the time and i was a young
guy you know as strong as an ox and
everything else and
boy uh at the end of
these
like say months
long period you needed a good rest yeah
and for magnus
i was stunned that magnus left dubai
and then he went on to play this world
blitz championship and rapid
championship in a very short
time frame afterwards yeah it was a
couple a couple of weeks if that if that
right and he performed very credibly of
course and he magnus's magnus i mean
nepal didn't do badly he actually played
the finals right against that
exactly
uh
wow yeah remarkable very very rewarding
but absolutely grueling so no surprise
that there are talks of magnus not
playing we'll see what happens fire
doesn't believe it he said it in the
press conference himself in spain that
he thinks this is just bogus that magnus
will play whoever it is okay we'll find
out uh for the not for the time being we
have a lot of rounds to play until we
determine who's of course of course we
are i feel that ali reza is very very
very close to sealing that draw after a
long long thing actually a 20 minute
thing i think yeah fabi did make a move
and they played
did we see this room at all
something of this
nature that we just wanted to activate
the rook
the knights
well the nights where it's supposed to
be right i mean and you want to you want
to play rook here or rook here and you
want to be able to swing it over but you
know what else i like about the move
rookie one is it controls the d4 square
there were so many moves in which we
wanted to play knight d5 and we just
couldn't because the queen d4 check
forced my knight back nobody was
defending the knight exactly uh
that takes away he takes away that
square right right
and now uh
well once again we're ready to introduce
the rook into play whether it be on the
d6 square or on the d5 square keep in
mind
that for example we're going to play a
bad move a5 rook d5 rookie 5. you think
okay i'll i'll stop you from
and furthermore if you go like this i'll
stop you this way and so you think
you're stopping me keep in mind
uh queen h uh queen d8 is going to be a
very very big deal and that will win the
house so um
the reason i like rook d1 is it just
emphasizes to hikaru
you're the one who's going to have to
find some really really great defensive
moves now having said that there was
that cat and mouse game that was going
on earlier queen e7 in this case it
doesn't work because d7 is hanging yeah
for example if you play the move queen
e7 right exactly that's what i was
thinking and if i go queen g3 you might
just have to you can't go back because
well trade queens i'll take the bishop
i'll win the game so rook d1 i like the
move
and
for a calculator like hikaru that was
probably the last
move you want to see yeah
all right so let's let's try to put
ourselves in hikaru's shoes shoes i've
got to make the best resistance i can
right in a very awkward position
i hate being in a car or shoes
[Laughter]
i'm just so glad i'm not
it's not just that it's a difficult
position it's that every move seems to
almost lose immediately maybe you have
to play okay
bishop e6 but
it just drops e4
amongst other things right although
maybe i'm happy about that
that i'll take e4 you won't have to
defend your your isolated pawn anymore i
was going to say
let's try to resist uh in this fashion
rookie pipe and queen a good way to
resist after queen d8
queen david a bishop check
bishop blocks wow that's uh barely
holding barely holding but once again
i'm just dreaming of getting my queen to
e7
are you going to go knight d5
oof 95 was one way i was i was hoping
for e3 in that case i'm supposed to
flipping rook d5 maybe just wins right
now yeah rook d5 here you cannot take
correct
any particular threat knight f5
something
good okay just wanted to be sure that i
i didn't overlook something here i
specifically wanted to go queen c8
oh yeah oh yeah so that you don't have a
check on c5 and if you take take
and you no matter where you move the
queen
i take on e8
banana second yeah
if you're winning the fun end game no
ifs ands or doubts about that one queen
c8 nasty
nasty uh
god
why do i have it why do i have to defend
that position
and you volunteered i mean yeah that's
true that's true i certainly did
oh boy oh boy
oh boy uh
yeah it's very very very difficult
christian uh
how do you defend this position with the
black pieces how do you actually not
defend how do you hold on
it does seem like rookie seven is the
only move only
yes rook to v7 and it's a bit
counterintuitive because you do allow 95
with tempo you encourage it that's not
something that you generally want to see
on the board but you do get this setup
with the rook on f7 this seems to be
what the computer is striving to get
this also allows white to take on e4
just simply take on e4 and get this
position and here we go we're going to
play with the pawn up i understand maybe
you actually wanted me to take this pawn
so that you open up the long diagonal
bishop to c6 now has uh an active role
in the position and maybe also you're
going to be able to uh find the
perpetual
this is what the computer is
recommending rook to e7 bishop to e6 as
you guys were mentioning again knight to
d5 and this trade-off after bishop takes
d5 rook takes d5 seems to be the best
way forward for white and i know a lot
of people in the chat
are saying why didn't he play the move
knight to f5 this is the computer's
recommendation this gives white a
tremendous advantage it's not easy when
you have such a powerful knight locating
the pawn on e4 but also just a couple of
moves away from delivering uh
devastating checks to the black king you
want to keep that and you have to keep
those options on the board and this is
exactly why after a long thing he played
this move to d1 let's wait and see
whether hikaru is going to be able to
defend this one he is going to be able
to put the best resistance forward
does it actually say rookie 7 b4
yeah yeah yeah i again i don't want to
go into what uh necessarily yeah
a3 by the way is the best move in the
position
yeah nobody's going to play a3 nobody's
going to play a3 nobody's going to play
b4 because
to be honest they don't make any sense
what we have like
six pieces uh on the board and you're
going to try to play for suzwang i mean
that's that's not how chess works
it is and at the same time
make a move it's sort of i understand
i get it there's no move i'm going to
have to play rook f7 and give you the
point
i had a very more direct question it
might be a two's one what is the move
after rook d5 like i'm just going to
play rook d5 rook g5 is a thread no but
now i get queen a1 right king oh forget
seven i said
probably also queen to h8 though i'm 100
sure how that end game is uh for example
to g5
i think
this feels winning but maybe it's not uh
and by the way rookie seven was not well
this would be winning if your pawns were
on before
if only if the pawn was on before oh
yeah i know oh my goodness but there was
a rook h7 uh
sightings
none of this will happen because he
played the move bishop to e6 uh inviting
white to take on e4
interesting decision by uh hikaru once
again knight d5 tremendous advantage
knight d5 here knight d5 tremendous
advantage no actually that makes sense
because in the other lines we had to
play queen deep how do you defend
against it's a better version than with
the rook on f5 because now the rook on
d5 controls the check on d4 so always is
going to be a better version that's why
uh the assessment is even more
devastating the difference here is that
rookie five queen da root d7
another yes yeah yeah that is yeah a
great point yes
yeah yeah so what what is the difference
after 95 seconds 95 rook to f8 you're
kidding me 97
king f7 i'm not kidding you what can i
do i'm not dance shoes yeah let's go
let's go yeah wow that's tango the other
running shoes uh on rook to f1 is going
to be met by like
you keep running i i don't catch you in
fact after
by the way rook f1 king eight white is
completely black yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah because i i
trapped my knife tonight right right
right right they'll
hate that when that happens right that's
not going to happen no
that's not happening on the board now
the question is does white have better
options what if i just simply take on e4
and this is a very tempting move to make
by the way very very tempting
i'd like to take the pawn sir yeah loses
a lot of its advantage already maybe
take the pawn afternoon really
a lot of its advantage is lost after we
take the pawn i'm not even sure this is
winning anymore oh my word
i mean i'm not convinced i understand
the computer is saying plus one uh an
extra pawn
this usually means that black has enough
compensation to find the dynamics
required to make a drawing that's
remarkable oh that's not within my radar
but okay knight d5 rook f8 and just do
the same thing but here i play queen
takes e4 because if you take on that's
that's the best way forward exchange all
your pieces that is unhappy right
they're a very happy camper in this case
that is the best way forward i mean here
i take with either 65 queen takes d5
this is going to be winning um yeah
let's wait and see what he does and by
the way fabiano doesn't he only has 28
minutes left 46 minutes for hikaru now
just to take you back to the game
between rajabov and ali reza we did
indeed have this rook 25 look to a3 as
we anticipated look to f8 king to e7
unfortunately for white he just doesn't
have this king to g3 anymore and that's
a problem i'm going to go king to e7
you will probably go on that long route
of getting the rook all the way to e3
kicking my rook off the third rank and
then trying to invade with the king but
unfortunately that's not going to be
enough i'm going to keep my king on f6
so for example if you do this i go here
you try to go all the way to e2 that's
okay
probably actually you don't want to run
into you're not going to go into f1 yeah
you're going to i'm just making yeah
with v3 b3 rook to e3 rook to b2 and
we're going to get into this position
and now
with the king not cut on the e file
this g5 square is not available so after
king to h4 i'm just simply going to give
you checks there's no king g5 there's no
entry square for you and this one is
pretty much impossible too yeah this
feels easy actually yeah this
i don't think uh ali reza will have any
problems defending this now
i've been scouting and remembering some
games from his past and we know there
was a lot of talk about ali reza not
necessarily being at the elite level yet
in terms of end games specifically
because of a couple of accidents now
this was one of the accidents that uh
the naysayers are usually mentioning is
the game between himself and magnus
carlsen from norway chess 2021 after
knight takes h5 and they got all the way
to this position
alireza panicked he only had a couple of
seconds
on his clock and he played the move king
to c3 which instantaneously loses to
king c5 if you don't play king c3 it's
actually a draw you can play king to d2
and after king to c5 you're going to
maintain the opposition nevertheless the
point being there's this accidents that
are occasionally happening to ali reza
pointing to the fact that maybe maybe
he's not at the elite level when it
comes to end games that's why i think
raj java right now is still trying and
rightfully so is still trying to win
that game nevertheless i reza is still
at 2800 level there i don't think we're
going to see any other result by drawing
this one yeah thank you christian i
think it's time for us to take a
commercial break
and take a look at what we have so far
in the tournament we only have one
result right a very important one indeed
is the first victory of this tournament
he is currently sitting on a full point
after defeating dingley rand the
tournament favorite when it comes to
reigning and with the black pieces which
makes it even juicier for the potential
rematch for the player here reminding
everybody it's a double round that is a
double round round super long tournament
plenty to play for but that's a great
start young no question about it and
we'll continue our coverage on the other
side of this break
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's our show now go play yours at
prison.com
[Music]
a st
public radio journalist's most precious
possession isn't a notepad
camera
microphone or recording device their
most precious possession
is credibility a journalist's work
revolves around the truth
finding it
verifying it
and reporting it
great journalists work hard to find the
facts and put those facts into context
examining all the arguments and
including differing opinions
amplifying fascinating voices from our
community
telling captivating stories
offering facts that may have been
omitted
we work every day to earn your trust for
news turn to st louis public radio
when you visit st louis you'll probably
want to watch the cardinals or the blues
what about after the game
heading back to the hotel would be a
major error
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the blues
their name at the national blues museum
broadway oyster bar or even the
legendary blueberry him so whether you
love the cardinals the blues or the
blues come play with us
and you guys know i can't play this
right
st lou is always exploring
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the 2022 candidates in
madrid as we
only result so far in the event dingley
run with the white pieces fell to yan
nepal nyachi in a sharp game where the
chinese player kind of disappeared
the middle game was reached you're
absolutely right it was a very one-sided
game in fact
as nepo kind of sacrificed upon which
was not accepted and he sees the
initiative and he just cruised right
through big big disappointment for our
top seed i'm very worried about dingley
ran he started the same way two years
ago against wong hao and he never
recovered i want to see him back in the
tournament he's clearly one of the best
players not just in this tournament but
in the entire world he has earned his
second rank in the world rankings just
not out of coincidence right no
absolutely no very very deserving
another game we think is going to a
decisive one and that's between
um fabi versus hicaro i just love the
way fabi is approached this position he
had a very comfortable advantage
probably a winning advantage in my
point of view i love this move rook d1 i
think this is a tricky
difficult move to meet ikara played
bishop e6 knight d5 offering that piece
exchange but on the d5 square so there's
no queen d4 check right ideas and after
rook
uh pardon me after rook f8 he clipped
the pawn queen takes queen h6 this is
the position they have reached and this
masterful move rook e1 on the board by
fabi not yet not yet i'm sorry i i'm
looking up there i thought that was the
life but in any case
uh rookie one was certainly the move
that we had anticipated i apologize
rookie one on the board wonderful and
that was a move we had anticipated we
thought rook e1 was an iron
winner uh you hit the bishop and it's
just the problem is it's the exposed
king it's a combination of factors but
most importantly it's the exposed king
the queen knight rook working really
really well together any
trades end up being immediately decisive
for white after bishop takes queen takes
d5
and there's simply nothing in the
position uh for hikaru to do after this
move rookie one you know it looks
completely dead uh
if you don't take on d5
you're probably gonna mate it exactly if
we drop back with the bishop it's like
this night check is just going to be ah
you basically stop calculating it
exactly okay i cannot survive i can't
yeah and so you you you look at captures
and queen takes and we were not
surviving this ourselves so uh
talk about starting with a bang this is
this could be two
decisive games we do think that richie
somehow put together
uh
can we say miracle fortress i don't know
a little bit i think the point but i
mean a little blame on duda
because he was given a lot of chances
from the opening true uh not just the
move rook takes d1 even later in the
position there were a lot of chances for
duda to actually create chances
he didn't take them he was unable to
play precisely and really allowed
richard back in the game and
that should not happen right
right i mean you're given
this kind of chances you're not gonna
see them very often no you get a plus
one point five two position from the
opening right you really need to put
more pressure than this exactly and uh
he's been nursing the two bishops for
some time but the last move f7 f5 was
met by king
to see
three yeah and then attack
the capture on h2
really takes h2 what am i missing
i don't think you're missing anything
well that's too easy though
maybe i could take on c4 and
it's probably still going to be a drill
well
g5 i do have to go back but that's okay
right well we were looking at a position
like this where the king would drop back
uh the bishop would go to f4 we'd just
be say a fortress what are you going to
do you put a bishop on steve c3 a king
on d5 you allow me g4
yeah we were looking at actually with
opposite color bishops that's true
that's true this is that right yeah
yeah this is the same color of bishop
this is the same color but it does i
don't think it changes the evaluation of
the position
okay so how is uh the evaluation after
just simply taking on e4 taking only
yeah
c4 and then i take on h2 maybe
with knight d6 included because i don't
want to allow you to run to b5 so what
if i go knight d6 then i take on h2 and
i'll pawn up at least
well exactly i mean
you know i play i understand you have
the two bishops and you're most likely
going to be able to have enough
compensation for equality do you have
more
than equality as well i highly doubt
that
truly uh
the king on c6 is simply excellent yes
you have a passer but this king on c6 is
very very close and the knight is doing
stuff and the bishop is doing stuff
bishop will come back final go
takes e4 and i think we're going towards
that variation because he did take on e4
and
it doesn't really make sense that you
wouldn't take on a c4 i guess you can
wait for bishop take c4 and then take on
e4 like for example just take on h2
first
allow the bishop to get to c4 and then
play the move knight takes e4 no
that would help me but
because bishop to f7 also comes on the
board at some at times
no i love the idea of leaving that force
keeping that bishop on a6 the bishop is
terrible on asics i'm not i do feel it's
a position in which um
every move is a draw right yeah it
doesn't really matter which move order
you play this in the concept of the
position is that white is down upon
right you're gonna probably have to
sacrifice some bishop for the amount of
pawns that black has and then it's just
going to be
some sort of draw
yeah but from such a dominant position
yeah that's the thing
i mean duda must not be feeling very
content with his decision making this
game and rapport is in cloud nine right
now yeah
i feel this crazy sense of deja vu
i have been talking about two bishops
versus a knight
and what are the chances no no no no no
no no no
no no no no no i wanna
end up good
i wanna go to sleep tonight
can i be the expert on on the panel
having actually studied this one ending
that i never had in my life
let's go back to the favi game because
he is putting the final touches
played after which uh rook d8 was played
what rook d8 uh so that drum queen 6 26
thank you
yeah i was about to say i got the
hanging the bishop but
at the end of the day and it's possible
that that end game is winning but 97 is
just cleaner and 97 played 97 checking
out any move other than king f7 drops
the bishops i'm assuming king of seven
is forced it was played knight f5 was
played as well it's another position
where you just cannot take on f5 you're
just too weak with the king the king is
too exposed i agree
and after the move queen uh knight fight
queen f6 game on the board
i kind of expect the move for kf1
resigns as the fought as a sequence
because i don't really see a defense
can i move my king you're good i'll i'll
keep chasing you with queen g4
what okay yeah
and now i'll play rook f3
well that's
that's unfair
hold on we'll look at three just a
second what am i missing they should
have five oh
oh okay okay so you survive
i mean i got like with nine lives i've
been surviving just barely i feel like
i'm
you know sliding down a cliff with my
hands just but but if but if you keep on
in game well let's continue this line
let's see queen g4 checking eight shade
okay sorry so this is the current
position we're anticipating king g8
as opposed to resigns right queen g4
king h.a
let me let me let me think for just more
than one second uh wait what is your
move after queen h5
i have to move my king and then i'm
going to get h6 knight
and that's a discovery that's a queen
yeah
that's
easy oh thank you that is simply uh
that will provoke resignations for sure
yeah yeah i'll give that one a rest and
i think that if i play king f fate i
don't really i mean i'm sure there's
many ways to win here but knight knight
e3 i thought i don't know
it's not oh my god i'm like blundering
everything
queen before what about there we go
queen before you don't have a place for
your king it can be foreign so king g8
walks into knight e7 check king e8 walks
into knight d6 check
was played i discovered against the
queen what was played
as expected it just feels like at this
point you resigned right
[Laughter]
you guys are hoping
there's no way there's another one in
the record books then you can't survive
this come on no of course not but he's
been
he's been on the edge for quite some
time yeah if this wasn't the candidates
i think you just resigned but it is the
candidates you try your best every half
point is just absolutely so crucial
exactly and uh let's take a look at how
tries to keep fighting in this one
because
so king g8 queen g4
king fa queen d4 before was really a
nice sequence that he played bishop d5
okay
bishop to david five okay
fine
there has to be like ten ways to win
this position
a hundred ways
does knight d6 96 wins but i kind of
want
more
that's kind of cashing your chips in
early uh
i suspect uh it does that early it is
completely winning right like 96 takes
rook takes f6 you have to take with the
king queen f4 king e6 only move g4 right
let's find something more brutal than
that correct we're looking for the
brutal
what are we looking for the three
the the you know the cart to take away
which ones queen e3 queen e3 or queen b4
somewhere where i control your only uh
check in the position which is queen b6
also i'm threatening knight to h6
exactly so how do you defend against can
i
i can't drop back with my king because
once again knight h6 check and if you go
to g8 yes knight to eight six i don't
play f8 i just move the knight right so
you have to move the queen right oh by
the way knight h6 was played
okay which makes sense
oh this is this is probably even easier
king g7 is the only move
and queen to g4 is coming
oh yeah this is much easier
no no no
knight to five knight five check and
then queen h4 and then i pick up the
rook on v8 okay you can also play rook
f7 and pick up everything there's made
on g2
i i pick it up with chuck
because you have to go k7 then i go
queen h4 then you have to go to g8 g7 is
controlled then oh
that's everything is not also an issue
ties together nice no this is over okay
yeah at this point i mean every time
knight h6 check queen g46
queen g4 check already on the board
right now he's blitzing out his moves he
knows it's over and actually we got the
resignation and wow what a result for
fabi
terrible for hikar terrible
not the start you wanted no he
this game hikaru comes in with the black
pieces thinking if i get past fabi with
black
i can really make some hay in this event
conversely losing
really takes the wind out of yourselves
it's like damn damn damn uh that really
really hurt but for fabby's chances
double his odds
it isn't amazing i'm just trying to um
remember what were the predictions once
again maybe the producers can help us i
got like a 12-gauge
very long tournament christian
uh well done fabi and uh big big result
there we've got two uh games going let's
just jump again to the team
for quite some time that has been a rook
ending that we've been thinking
well it's a table based draw will
ali raisa
just
hold it and he's doing very very good
job thus far
this is the easy version now that you
got your king to f6 and the rook had to
maneuver all the way back to e3 e3 right
this is the easy version of this end
game
relatively and
essentially the one thing you don't want
to do unless it's absolutely absolutely
a basic draw just trade rooks yeah you'd
never trade right right yeah and we're
expecting rook check and something like
for example king up and we can harass uh
the king we just don't let the king
waltz up the board actually through
we actually have a bunch of new moves we
do
wonderful yes yes yes so the king is
already i think rook to b2 was played
after rook to a3 we have a rook on a3
and then rook to b2 was played and now
the question is what if i just give you
a check on a6
i think this is the position we
currently have on the board i might be
wrong because we're having some
difficulties with uh transmission but
is what i have anything that defines e5
right and um
that's the thing i king g5 don't if i
lose this to rook e6 that has to be
loose right
yeah
this is just
e5 is a pretty basic right
so now you go to f7 and if i go here
how do you do you just attack the f3
pawn yeah yep this is it and now you
cannot even go back because once you go
back i go e4 and that's it
um makes sense makes sense so rook to b2
it seems like ayuresa is still very much
in control in this one
and timur ajabov is running out of ways
to try to swindle his uh young opponent
let's see where that goes well that's
the whole point too you've got to put
you each move is kind of a testing
a test for your opponent what do you do
if i do this and if he answers all the
test questions right well that's uh how
he earns the draw
but once again we have two uh results
both of them decisive and both decisive
yeah fabiano carona
they're the ones with one full point out
of one meanwhile hikaru nakamura and
dingley ran rally gated zero out of one
and we're still trying to figure out
what's gonna happen in the other two
games it feels that a draw is a clear
favorite in both uh most likely most
likely but
still stuff to play for in both uh where
we still think that well timor is
running out of resources but in the game
between duda and rapport well things are
yeah
four minor pieces on the board uh
richard i must say probably has the best
position he's had since the opening he's
actually a pawn up remarkably enough
uh and considering that he barely got
out of the opening that was not uh g7 g6
i don't know i mean he's very very
creative but sometimes a little bit too
much so and uh richard got himself into
trouble but fortunately for him he
actually was not punished and up to date
uh he's just played the move e5 e4 which
is
sure looks tempting to me let's go up
what do you do with past pawns you gotta
push him baby you gotta push him baby
yeah not too far guys
don't go to e3 because bishop is going
down
let's push him baby not
if you get all the way to e3 bishop f3
and i think you can reside oh
now this is what duda is trying to get
he's trying to find a way to get his
king involved and past the midline
of the board how do you do that maybe
bishop to d1 followed by bishop to a4
and then try to get the king to c5 let's
try to figure out how the position
develops after that so i go bishop to d1
i understand your pawn is not going
anywhere the other pawn the pawn on the
g file is not going anywhere because i
control the light squares
that's why the majority on the king side
for black doesn't matter at this point
how do you play so let's say i
i've got some skin in the game let's go
bishop to a4 correct bishop to a4 check
now you were mentioning that the king
uh it wants to cross uh the middle of
the board right so the idea i want you
to cross them yeah okay so we we we we
go here i understand and if you go king
c5 you gotta are you walking into a
trick no bishop i don't think so i take
on d6 and i have bishop d1 at the end
and i think you're defending both
what sorry no take stakes even this
might be a draw
i you want to go g4 no this is not a
draw i have uh
but now i go king c5 followed by bishop
to c6 i mean bishop c6 is a draw but
okay so you didn't like that you won
somehow i wanted to try to play for a
victory there but this is winning for
white yeah you go bishop d1 and i just
stop your pawns
nice yeah bishop d1 and i pick
one g4 no so g4 has to be played right
right that's is that going to be just
okay guys black's not playing for a win
why am i giving up
it doesn't matter after king c5 i would
much rather play for three results and
put my pawn on e3
like immediately like immediately okay
now i give you a check
bishop to c6
okay let's go to f3 okay i'm not going
to allow you to go all the way through i
have knight b7 check though uh
i i i i like 94 knight b7 king
you're going to follow it up with
bishop d6 right
uh sorry how how are you responding to
bc okay so let's say i go king i
understand king to b4 you're going to
play bishop to d6 right but what if i go
no no go back keep going
no no keep going after bishop f3 knight
b7
okay
what if i go king d5
but i don't understand what what are you
playing for a loss
no no definitely not bishop f4 bishop
before gets made it i understand but if
i take on if you take on a5 i take only
three and i'll just make a drawer
it should be a draw
again i still have the two bishops your
pieces are a little bit off right i
understand yeah it's probably a draw i
mean i could even give up all your
phones
it doesn't matter right but even this is
not
okay this is probably easier i take on
f4 it's not what i play h3 i give up my
knight for free
i'm gonna if you're in time yes yes you
are in time okay i mean look guys your
standard position is a draw i understand
look he's enjoying
he he he's playing for uh white there
knows the position i learned something
today right push him baby
but not too far
okay uh that you get you got to be
cautious you got to push it so you
so um
objectively the evaluation is even we
know exactly
yes do you think that white should be
the one playing christian this
is the one play you think so okay i mean
we we don't know whether he should be
playing right we know he is playing
uh bishop c5 was played because he was
the one that gave up a pawn when he
could have easily played bishop before
bishop to hd6 and make the draw right
yeah bishop z5 does feel like i'm trying
to bail
almost a bailout bishop takes d6 always
is going to be a draw
well for the moment we see a6 and yeah
and if bishop f4 i think you still go a6
and especially i do have a check yeah
but i you don't catch my phone
right right bishop f4 a6 so where do you
put your king
b3 b3 probably yeah so that you don't
have yeah knight c
and b right yeah i don't have any uh
tricks tricks well maybe we should uh
show that yeah exactly so the idea of
bishop c5 is that in case you play
bishop f4 we're going to play a6 yes and
then after bishop d2 check you
disconnect the protection of the bishop
but after king b3
you don't
stop the pawn there is the move a7 which
explains why exactly is that decisive at
this point so bishop d2 king b3 is the
pawn on a6 already decisive
that seems unlikely
you are threatening a7 and
king b7 bishop takes d6 now how do you
defend against that well
is it
to see it makes a lot of sense yeah can
i give up my um
don't give up anyone
why why we're so happy giving up things
on b7 i just got king v7 so you're like
wait wait wait wait wait bishop a6
no no no no bishop a6 knight c8 a7 king
b7 i have bishop a6 at the end that's
very true that's game over
you know you pick up my knight oh
ouch
i'm not so happy if i have to give up my
knight as long as this bishop on e2
survives yeah there's no real guarantee
that i'm going to make a draw which is
the whole point that christian is
expressing that the two bishops
even though white has sacrificed upon
with the move bishop c5 in practical
terms he's the one
uh pushing the action so is there a way
to force things right now is there a way
to force any sort of exchanges for a
platform
knight b7 okay that makes a lot of sense
but i am bishop b5 isn't worried about
bishop b5 check it
is annoying c7 most likely then i get to
play
so this is the problem is
if i
if i prematurely force
certain things
then i am getting
uh a scary looking setup
with um
the bishop coming to
and maybe you still defend right knight
to d6 even though
d6 bishop to c6 and you can steal
another
a7 a7
a7 king a8 bishop c6 and then king b5
king yeah
like a study right viking a6
i feel like i'm going to get maybe
i think so
even
my last move may not even be one equals
queen when i get mated you know
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy so there
there are difficulties still for richard
to overcome perhaps practically right
they're still
yeah i'm convinced it is white that's
playing for a win here but yeah
but uh
i again i
i just find this
remarkably funny that i could get a
position like this one
giving up my bishop
for the pawn and having the two knights
versus partly the two bishops versus the
knight
uh you still have a pawn on g2 but that
would be uh
wow that would be a deja vu let's try to
find something a little cleaner exactly
bishop c5
on the board we're told instead of
bishop d1 i apologize c5 right
uh you know my problem is that this
night is so
uh
wrongly placed like c7 would be for
example an ideal square i could put then
put my bishop back on d6 um
maybe just bite the bullets it's like c8
yes that was what i'm thinking as well
knight to c8
uh intending uh bishop to d7
b8 and you know you can get your pawn
here
but after bishop to d6 now my knight is
actually doing a great job at
controlling the a7 and i do have a
majority
over there after all so maybe knight c8
is
is the easiest
it's kind of ugly but it might be
sufficient christian if we could put a
test to you uh we're settling in on the
move knight c8
how uh does the engine feel about the
map c8 not as clean not as clean not as
clean uh i'm going to go bishop b5 and
then i'm actually going to play this
move bishop to e3 i can play knight d
sec
knight d6 back and then
a6 and how easy is that
you know take take how do you how do you
ever
expel me from aaa a8
yeah
he's putting a path but can i go bishop
to e7
and go g5 g4 by the time you're winning
my e4 pawn yeah that's it that's it that
doesn't even matter right yeah i just
get yeah but no i get that and you get
g5 g4 yeah and you're right in time to
go g4 exactly i also think the passive
defense with bishop on g3 is good enough
also good enough okay
must be must be the material is just too
simplified at this point knight to c8 of
course is one of the moves it's a bit
passive and maybe that's why he's going
to reject it knight to f5 is the
computer's choice even the lines that we
analyzed we looked at with bishop to f4
a6 bishop d2 king to b3 and now
it does get a bit dicey because you do
have to find some very precise moves one
of them is knight to e8 knight to eight
try to defend
the promotion square from c7 that's the
best movie that is seems to be
giving uh black enough for equality
will he want uh to allow the point go
all the way to a7 does he even have an
alternative at this point i'm looking at
it and i don't see it it does feel like
this a pawn is going to push the way
you're going to defend and the way
you're going to try to stop him from
promotion that's going to be the
question for the next few moves and
let's wait and see what these players
are going to come up with now the game
between rajabov and ali rezab
i don't think anything has happened in
fact let's see no we still have moves
coming in now this is the other game
it does seem like we
there we go
this is the game between rajabov and ali
reza nothing has happened the king is
still stuck
to the defense of the pawn on f3 king
cannot go to g3 the only way to get the
king to j i think this is just a draw i
at some point we're going to see some
sort of a repetition uh rajabov cannot
lose all his energy trying to break
through uh an immovable object so this
is exactly what's happening yeah it's
actually a good point right this is a
very long tournament yes
everybody prepares physically for this
event as well right as mentally and over
the board
and
but also you talk about pacing you don't
you talk about pacing and of course you
have to try you have to try but i also
feel like this one you tried as much as
you can right you already got your work
on the sixth round you brought it to the
third rank you brought it to the sixth
rank
you're running out of ideas right i
remember i was playing in the candidates
and i had this adjournment now they they
you to talk about the old school we had
uh 40 moves in two and a half hours
followed by a break and then a german
and i was playing uh vaseline smithslav
and i was on this worse
end game
and i was making one fortress and
another fortress and he
tried and he said draw
i was expecting him to go even that
extra half measure
and i went thank you
and i said well why didn't you try this
and he says well you just gave me the
answer
like you were ready for that and i have
to conserve my energy
wow conserving energy okay yeah
sometimes you got to do what you got to
do our schedule it's tight it's three
rounds and the rest day three rounds and
the rest day three rounds and arrested
and we finally finished with the last
two championship rounds on 13 and 14 is
a very long tournament i mean we're
looking at
independence day being the very last day
of this tournament and we're halfway
through june i'm looking at the schedule
now i seem to remember that the old
schedule that i played in montpellier
was
two games
of chass
uh adjourned game day rest day
two games of shadows a german game res
day so that schedule
looks really easy you know what i think
about it we have an interesting we have
an interesting question in the chat
where we stand and where we stand of
course dingler and lost the nepalese
lost to nakamura
there in first place
an interesting one for the three of us
yes uh a predictions one yo from goblin
attenborough in uh twitch chat
what opening trends do you think we'll
see in this event and i think that
from the first round it already broke
some of the things that i expected and
we already saw some interesting things i
expected the berlin i mean yes i think
everybody saw hikar playing the berlin
from 20 miles away right uh but taimana
finally kind of did it i don't remember
the last time i've seen that especially
with very very rare it's very rare with
the bishop f4 especially this english
has become very popular recently i am
not surprised to see the english i think
it's very common but for ruja neo vienna
that's something brand new to the
candidates brand brand new and i love
that we're seeing new stuff at this high
level of trust i think that uh one of
the things for queen pond opening
players especially
is they've been kind of more cagey
they're not just playing d4 and walking
right into a grunfeld or whatever right
rather than playing knight f3 c4 they're
doing
different move orders to get
a d4 position but trying to avoid a lot
of things on the way so that's one trend
berlin i think is here to stay yes i
mean against one e4 just all the top
players are playing e5 and berlin so
that's and it's a good question by the
way and it's not only about the trends
but it's also about the players and
taimanov could only come it seems like
it from richie rapport because richie
rapport does play the taimanov also
richie rapport in uh previous interviews
he mentioned that he's probably not
going to have time energy or seconds or
a team that will be able to create a new
repertoire with and this is exactly what
we're seeing he's playing the exactly
the same things that he's been playing
for the past few months so i think from
a ritchie report we're probably going to
be seeing um the same things that we've
been seeing in the past few months and
potentially just a couple of
new things if lubomir manages to find
some new uh ideas but definitely i don't
see i like this neo vienna trend
definitely one to follow and i know a
good course by one alejandro
if you had to pick only one opening to
play for the rest of your life as white
which would it be well if i only had one
and
i'm looking for as much
action as i can as e4
c4 because
there's
that there's uh galaxies it seems after
e4 whether it's in a sicilian complex a
french complex car con
perks
think of all the things that black can
challenge alekhines that you can get
challenged with against one e4
and i think e4 is actually the richest
of all of the openings and too too much
work which is why i never you never did
it right well i did it but i was a
dabbler i wouldn't call i actually i'm
on the same boat as you i i play e4 as a
dabbler like i do play e4 in very
important games and i have lady for an
extremely i think the most important
games that i played both started with e4
but again i do specific preparations and
i i just hate building an entire
repertoire with e4 because you have to
renew it every so often like right geary
comes out with the new colors on the
night or well guess what you have to
redo your knight or somebody comes up
with a new idea in the french guess what
you have to redo your french right and
it's it it is a lot of work to keep up
e4 it's such a demanding opening that's
exactly whereas throughout my life if i
i arrive to a tournament where i haven't
studied chess and months and i go knight
f3 c4 g3 bishop g2 castle i'm always
going to get a good position and i'm
going to play some chess exactly that's
exactly that was me all the way lazy
man's guide
because you know whether it was school
work whatever it was i was doing uh i
couldn't be the devoted uh
chess grand master that i wanted to be
for me it's probably going to be uh one
uh d4 and everything that encompasses uh
under that umbrella because after e4 i
have to deal with the petrov i have to
deal
and i'm just going to simply hate my
life
i prefer the queen's gambit decline you
know qgd we're going to play that i'm
going to be able to come up with some
new ideas that will throw you off and
give us an interesting game what do i do
against the petrov what do i do against
the berlin i understand i'm probably
going to go d3 anti-berlin and so on
still for me it would be 1d4
good question thank you to the audience
pudding is on the spot uh with some of
these challenging
uh moments trends in chess
and uh one of the things for me that has
always been the most remarkable thing
about the chess world is how the fashion
changes yeah very quickly i mean i had
never
i mean
kind of prided myself in some ways in
anticipating where modern opening theory
was going but i never saw the berlin not
even you know
10 miles away and in 1975 it played in
the u.s open in lincoln nebraska and
there was one
arthur bisguire
a top grand master from the united
states whose entire career was playing
the berlin
and he said to me yes sir yes sir you've
got to learn to play the berlin you got
the two bishops and all you've got is a
double pawn you got to play the berlin
i'm telling you it's a great defense i
went yeah sure arthur
35 years later
he's totally vindicated
and another question
about trends let's go all right from
patrick and uh shout out to patrick
daley he's like one of our best uh
subscribers always active on the chat
nice have neural networks truly
rehabilitated some of the riskier play
that went out of fashion during the
stockfish era is that what we're seeing
in this tournament more risk actually it
is a good way of putting it uh leela
specifically uh when we talk about
neural network engines uh we're not
really talking about alpha zero anymore
i mean people keep using alpha zero as
the right but it's so outdated i mean
zero would get crushed by modern engines
wow and uh that's a scary thought it is
really scary i thought when you think
about it right but leela is a
riskier player
playing risky not riskier but different
a different understanding of the game uh
stockfish really thought that a lot of
uh openings were unplayable uh
the french yeah i mean if you put in the
french winner even today you put
stockfish 15 on e4 e6 d4 d5 knight c3
bishop b4 e5 you just put that position
in stock right it's like plus point
eight
i mean it's a huge advantage for white
wow but you put it on lila and it
literally just doesn't care lila thinks
that long-term black is going to be fine
and
it goes down like if you compare both
engines they eventually both converge on
the poison pawn win over french and
eventually stockfish realizes that it's
actually equal
with extremely precise play like
extremely precise play so a lot of these
openings that were considered unplayable
and i think one the one that is making
the biggest comeback
because of neural networks is the king's
indian
no way king's indian is absolutely funny
for black no at the computer level there
are no problems with the king's indian
we just saw uh
ali reza in bucharest having some
awkward moments with the kings indian
and it wasn't
like uh dayak or others were playing the
absolutely most challenging way against
the king's indian but the engines are
now coming back to the kings india yeah
they're coming back to the kingston
saying look this is just fine uh there
is and it's dangerous
because you get this king's indians
where
you're not lost
and as long as you're not losing in the
king city and you're you're you have
chances i mean the king singing is one
of those openings when with so many
positions you're down a piece
you're okay
you have an attack you're going you're
pushing falls you're making a bonus
and i think that's why it's become such
a popular opening for a lot of my
students because i think five years ago
when my chess program started at slu
yeah i mean i was already working with
2600 level gms none of them had the
king's indian not as white not as black
they didn't have to look at it for white
side because who's playing the kings
indiana's black right the new generation
the ones that are 18 19 20 years old uh
yeah king's indian is bread and butter
wow and i'm thinking where where did
this come from where the passion comes
back fashion comes back i mean it was
completely obsolete in the 90s right
hikaru and rajabov dabbled in the early
2000s they were the rare birds they were
the rubbers and they gave it up right
right completely gave it up doesn't play
the king hikara doesn't play king's
indian he's known as a king's indian
player from games that are 15 20 years
old right and now
look at it again yeah it's funny because
in my day gary kasparov was in fact
playing the king's indian and i was in
fact
doing a lot of uh work on the king's
indian ass for example was anatoly
karpov and they and their world
championship match bouts
the king's indian acquitted itself
pretty darn well all things considered
and the king's indian was a
was tough and uh
i must say that i enjoyed
the work
of the kings in the indians it was
a a very dynamic defense that allowed a
wide approach yes you could castle sure
you could cancel long you could go for
the you can play the center four g three
whatever you're taking on e5 going into
endings it was uh a very rich defense
then everybody started playing the
queen's game but declined and it was
like
trying to play a risk-free defense yeah
i think as he was coming up also ding
was quite an expert in the king's indian
if i'm not mistaken for like a year with
the black pieces he played it for a year
but he played it very successfully so
that's quite interesting and just to
give you kind of an example of most
likely
an ai that came up with this idea as
early on as this position in the
sicilian probably if you asked me a
couple of years ago what i think about
bishop f4 i'm going to look at you and
i'm going to tell you to stop drinking
bishop f4
is apparently a playable move not only
that but as you go along through the
lines you start understanding that black
does have some problems to solve most
likely stockfish would have never
thought about this move and i guarantee
you that leela probably came up with
this idea quite interesting and it also
opened up a lot of avenues for us as
humans to dabble into very risky uh
territories and
pretty much in every single move now you
look at
the nidorf let's let's take the nidor
for example
d4 see takes the f4 knight takes d4
knight f6 knight c3 a6 right we know
that everything can be played bishop b3
bishop g5 f3 g3
recently bishop to d2 was played a move
that once again if you would have told
me about it a couple of years ago what i
think
this would have came bishop to d2 is is
the
about
just a crazy move a3 h4 g4 it is just
incredible what the engine actually
finds
nowadays and uh what humans
how many possibilities humans have to
follow up with crazy ideas that will
probably work if you use the new engines
yeah and uh to make a final point i
think uh something else that ais have
given us or not exactly ai so neural
networks are giving us um push the h
pawn
yes it really is it really does seem
that when i grew up as a chess player
you push the h pawn against some
fiancees not all of them and
it's usually like a fringe idea some
attacks with h4 will work but nowadays i
think you just play h4 in every position
you play it against the knight or if you
play against the king cindy and you
played it against the group
and people you know i asked him well
what do you play against
oh i play bishop e2 h4
what what do you mean that's like such a
fringe line like nobody really plays
that it's so dangerous
and they're like no what do you mean one
of the main lines no no no it's one of
the main lines and the whole h4 complex
was just really very funny because i was
playing uh the perk defense as black i
was trying to induce
them you know trying to trick people
into advancing their h-pawn prematurely
right and now it's sort of like oh yeah
that's the standard just want to go back
quickly uh to the game of timor because
when we
left it we really thought that well okay
uh we're getting really ready to sign
the scoresheets rook check we we did
point out that the move king g5 was a
loser because
this goes into a basic king and pawn end
game that is winning for white so you
don't go king g5 and black did drop back
and we got to this position
and
all right he's going to go all the way
to g4 which is some progress i mean you
got to say i mean if it was white to
play so what if i give you a check on a4
right if it's white to play i'm ready to
go rook jack and king f5
so
uh we're expecting rookie for check yeah
even that's a joke
or okay three four
king h5 okay three king h5 rook 83 was
like how do you continue to go back i
guess you have to go king h6
well king h6 and hope change 6 was also
a draw i can take on f3 right g6 king of
6 g7 right and just go king h7 instead
of uh g6 maybe yeah but then you go g3
it's quite easy i catch your pawn in the
foreign is the cleanest i also don't
think you have a threat
sorry you thought in this position that
would be very disconcerting like if i
played g6 that's like keem g6 okay
wonderful well this is what i was hoping
uh she would do
yeah king g7 kg7 and aren't they
threatening
you are but i'm thinking of seven and my
trick is that when you're playing f5 or
just a king g7 doesn't matter the moment
you're playing f5 or king yeah king of
five walks into four that's my idea
right and if you play king h5 you don't
really have a
yeah this is good because after king
takes rook takes g5 is pretty basic
yep yeah and if you go to h5 again you
don't have a threat uh rook f6 kg7 king
h5 i guess in the long term you'll play
like rook b6 for b7 but take so many
moves here i have the time to go rook a1
and uh
check me let me just check you forever
and
the moment i step to f5 then you'll hit
my f pawn yeah something like this
i i think we we played this one
no because here you have uh rookie seven
right let's go back a little bit before
before rook h1 here yeah i think you
define the point again you don't i don't
think you have a threat
to win wow yeah i think rookie one
the idea is that if you go f4 i give you
a check then you're happy then you're
happy yeah f4
check and then you can simply take the
pawn on f4 and that's a basic uh draw
but that's giving you everything i mean
i'm shocked that you can give me
everything right but alireza's
solution i think is just much simpler
which is
what christian wanted also also yeah
okay for chuck sorry we just get to this
no no no
did i do it wrong i apologize
what yeah there we go
rook a4 yeah can you try it already rook
a3 on the board
uh which
we thought was the by far the cleanest
yeah and we do have that four and a half
raw will be this is very very cool now
we know now now we know for sure takes
rook takes thirteen seven king ga rook
a8 also
and well i just wanted to say that we
should know our philadelphia you you
wait for
the pawn to advance to the sixth rank
and you know let's make it an
educational and then you go behind yes
okay and specifically with the g pawn
passive defense also works
king g8 you put the rook on a8
and you just keep so the game has been
agreed to a draw because well this is
very basic for players of this caliber
and draw a green drag a fighting draw
wonder i would say both sides with some
chances i mean alireza well this
exchange size exchange is really cool
but
five h4
he sees the initial it felt like he
outplayed um alireza from an equal
position a back and forth game all the
way i loved it this was a fun game this
was really cool i mean if you guys are
and a lot of
timor has earned a lot of haters
throughout the last couple of years
not the most fighting chess
but
when you force the guy to fight
what he can do he's impressive i mean if
anybody was in danger of losing to
i totally agreed i loved the game i
loved the round uh
a tough long long fighting round and we
still got uh
we might actually be seeing a repetition
in that one so after bishop to c4 this
is the position knight to d6 bishop to
e2 king to c6 and now we've seen this
position b4 this is where it all started
knight to f5 bishop to b5 king to c7 now
once again the repetition is uh there if
you wanted let's see whether he goes for
that
two minutes and 58 seconds and i do
think we're going to uh get another 15
minutes after 16 moves and that's in
only one move so duda is still trying
and he's playing basics the pawn is on
a6 the pawn is getting ready to ship to
the g sixes that's the absolute box move
right
not a7 only move no no no so you cannot
go knight d6 because this allows a7 king
b7 and this is the idea bishop to c6 you
have this threat in the position and the
only way to defend against that is with
bishop to d6 which most likely is going
to be played
a7 take take and then king to b7 yeah
that catches the pawn that's it this is
just it yeah we're going to see it
there's nothing to worry about
yeah a6 asking a final question
from his opponent bishop to d6 if it's
found is going to pretty much end the
game yeah when you think about the
longest game you've ever played just the
um
the actual sitting at the board not you
know like how much preparation it is for
the game and stuff like that what's your
longest game
uh aeroflot open actually back then had
this exact timeline germans no i germans
were before my time okay i never played
with the germans uh actually by the time
i was playing chess and germans were
already kind of a thing of the past yeah
um
no it was straight up eight and a half
hours
i was defending
i forgot which russian grand master i
was playing it was the ninth round of
the era for open so i was the absolute
last game left in the tournament people
were already like clear you know when
they start clearing
they pick up the pieces the vacuum
cleaners coming they're prepared for the
opening ceremony people are looking at
you like why is this game not over i got
napkins that i want to put on the table
and it was an opposite color bishop and
game where i'm down a pawn oh and it's
not like a fortress fortress it's a
fortress that you have to go around god
eight and a half hours no but i drew it
no
worthwhile christian jump in your
longest game uh i actually cannot think
of a very long game of uh my most likely
somewhere around six and a half seven
hours but there's nothing memorable okay
i didn't have like an eight eight and a
half hour game ever for
for me the question was
could i take your longest game and
christian's longest
put them together and i'll do you both i
had a 13 and a half hour game against
the guy from china the the game that
couldn't devour china but that was with
the germans were the germans right and
there were like five insurances
every morning we played at an olympian
during during this adjournment that the
never-ending adjournment
my team captain eloped with the russian
gal on board the american team captain
elope
john donaldson took off with elena
ashmaskaya
who was like
the she scored like 9 out of 11 or
something sweet
[Laughter]
fortunately natasha used the
wife of
grandmaster larry christensen took over
as team captain and she did a very very
commendable job in john's absence
it was great
i i play chess i i wake up and i've lost
a team captain
did that marriage last
like about five years five years okay
nice
nice
two more tournaments or tournaments um
after this move bishop dd6 um
you just showed one line with a7 and
bishop c6 check
that looked really easy draw like
there's no problem going on any other
the
bishop d6 is just i don't think so i
mean
at some point black plays for a win
right right if you're not i mean if you
don't do anything i'll play like e3
knight g3
yeah like that that will work yes um
no maybe no a7 just taking c7 king b7
the pawn is uh caught there's i i don't
see it
i mean
i'm looking at the engine okay bishop to
c4 is another move but do you really
want to risk
because
and then i can go e3 i can go knight to
e3 already e3 saying that black is
slightly better obviously it's still a
draw but
it is white who has to make the draw um
no i think at this point you understand
that your opponent just
passed the final test as you were
mentioning give your opponent tests this
is the final test he passed it with
flying colors bishop to d6 the only move
that doesn't lose in the position right
and right now you have to accept the
inevitable and that is this game is
going to finish in the draw well in
if we get this kind of fighting chess
throughout these rounds boy it's going
to be a
marvelous marvelous tournament to
commentate but it's going to be a long
one so that's why we're going to appeal
to our audience and say you know you
guys got to keep us on our toes ask us
questions feed his
positions and we'll do our best to
answer all your questions by the way we
should probably take a look at what's in
store for second round let's do it
because
we have
an absolute crazy match
round two round two we have richard
rapport
boy that could be a game that might
well
clinch the lead and maybe who knows i
mean if this game is decisive that's a
huge advantage everybody else draws
suddenly you got a one point lead after
two rounds that's crazy that is amazing
and duda versus ding and laren
uh as our fort
uh found there
is starting with the number one number
which means that he gets two whites
to start but don't forget that
that sounds good until that second half
when you go with two blacks
to start the second half of the event
yeah
uh so we do have the move a7 we are
going down the line that we have looked
at with christian uh takes on c5 is on
the board okay of course that is a check
so you have to take it back and king d7
obviously already played as he has
catched that right uh
bishop c6 already played king takes a7
already played i assume bishop takes c4
and i predict the move knight e3
because that is the most professional
and
pre-move knight takes g2 unless the g3
and you go knight g2 and it's like oh
you got g4 oh
nice
actually
[Laughter]
[Music]
two decisive games which means that we
have two leaders they face each other
tomorrow and
they really brought it to me this was
this was a candidates round yeah
interesting openings crazy middle games
back and forth games great preparation
great preparation this is what i want to
see in the candidates if i see games
like this every day i'm happy i'd be
very very happy this is a water round
excellent way to start in madrid
excellent way to start a tournament no
question about it really uh
this is
well this is the this is the way you get
a challenger somebody is going to be
tested throughout and uh
good play just just great stuff uh
bobby uh
i i i i don't know i mean both both the
the games that were won
were one
in very clean ways i mean impressive and
in a fight
i didn't feel that favi out prepared
carol no no you just got a position
and one side i played the other and the
same thing with napo i don't think the
net was even knight g4 is technically
correct i actually don't believe it's
technically correct but he just
outplayed his opponent during one of our
breaks um
ourselves
we were just
we were really kind of confused by uh
hikaru's move castle short we we we
doubled guessed the move at the time but
then during our break we really triple
doubled yes
why the king doesn't belong on g8 it
doesn't have any uh cover on d7 and on
c7 the king would be perfectly placed
and you get to play h4 and freedom it
doesn't belong
i feel it doesn't belong with the spirit
of the position the spirit of the
position was that you pushed your pawns
on the king side and that's right
would you should continue doing right uh
he's actually put the king completely in
the wrong side and it kills his play
yeah because his play
i think he felt at some point was going
to be d5 and it wasn't no d5 even though
it opened up the bishop
put the pawns on such clumsy squares if
you go back just a few moves later when
he does play the move d5 takes takes and
he's forced to play this ugly move e4
you start seeing something went wrong
totally totally wrong right but the the
all the positional
factors and the position uh the the
pawns on g4
is uh now a liability right upon on e4
gives up a lot of the dark squares in
the center
it it changed and it it all stemmed from
this move castle short which is really a
confusing move i mean
uh ikaru
is such a darn good player there's
nothing that i can teach him but the
king simply didn't belong on g8 and that
felt uh
the step that took him in the wrong
direction and at this level of trust it
really does get punished and fabi
proving why he is such a strong player
one of the favorites to take this
tournament let's take a look at our
standings as after day one fabinho
are the players on one point out of two
meanwhile as young sister of duda tamara
john of richard rapport
that are with half a point each and on
the bottom of the table our hikaru
nakamura and surprisingly digler who
started with the white pieces and is the
highest rated player
fallen yes and that is how we stand
tomorrow great matches of course the
headliner is definitely going to janna
pogba against fabiano carrano we already
have a barber for round number two yep
i'm excited to be there no question
about it and again for that match nepo
will be uh the one uh playing with the
white pieces against fabi tomorrow
absolutely absolutely
and our final thoughts
let's christian do the honors uh
christian what are your thoughts of this
exciting first round well guys i have to
say this was probably the perfect start
to a very long tournament and the
perfect start to the kit to the
candidates there is no better way than
to a potential four decisive games sure
we had only two but all of them could
have ended into a decisive result ali
reza is definitely taking the bulls by
the horns he showed that with his
opening preparation he came here to
fight so is timura jabo apparently and
everybody else in the field we have so
many developing stories in this
tournament and we're going to call all
the action from st louis and how do we
like our predictions guys i'd like a
reconsideration please
no no no none of that none of that
but it's a long tournament sorry i said
dick i don't i don't think i said that i
picked my hammer
but not he can come back i still have
faith uh you and var are looking very
very good christian our uh
congratulations and once again thank you
so much for sharing your day with us
tell all your friends where you've been
hanging out and uh we'll see you all
tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you